BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
THE TWO DAYS TO SANDRA DAY.
TOO THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
WILL INVITE -- THE LA -- AND
FINANCE TO JOIN US AT THE TABLE.
AND WE WILL PICK UP WHERE WE
LEFT OFF YESTERDAY [inaudible]
FOR THE SORRY AS FOLKS AGAIN
PHILIP THE TABLE WILL GO AHEAD
AND CALL WORLD ESTABLISH SHARK
MORE.
SENATORS METAL HERE.
WARLOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
ROTH.
SKINNER YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STING [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
WEBER HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVERYONE --
JUST A REMINDER -- WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A HARD STOP TODAY AT ONE
THIRTY OUR GOAL IS TO COMPLETE
EDUCATION.
AND COMPLETE RESOURCES AND
TRANSPORTATION WITH THAT WE'RE
STARTING ON PAGE THIRTY SEVEN
ISSUES THIRTY FOUR WE ARE IN
HIGHER ED UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
C. ISSUE FACULTY GOOD MORNING
REPRESENTED FROM THE LA -- WHAT
WE GET STARTED REASON CONCENTRA
SLUDGE ANALYST'S OFFICE?
OF THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU IS AN
ASSEMBLY ACTION RELATED TO
FACULTY DIVERSITY.
OFFER SOME CONTEXT -- IN RECENT
YEARS THE STATE HAS PROVIDED
SOME ONE TIME FUNDING FOR BOTH
TO UC AND CSU TO EXPAND --
PRACTICES AND AND TEST NEW WAYS
TO IMPROVE THE DIVERSITY OF THE
FACULTY HIRES.
AND THE OVERALL INTENT OF THE
ASSEMBLY ACTION IS TO TRY TO
EXPAND THOSE ONE TIME EFFORTS ON
ON ON AN ONGOING BASIS AND
ACROSS THE SYSTEM -- THE ACTIONS
ARE SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT FOR UC
AND CSU IN THE CASE OF YOU SEE
THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSES A FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION AN ON GOING
FUNDING -- TO RAMP UP.
EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
BEST PRACTICES FOR CSU THE
ASSEMBLY ADOPTS A BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD.
EXPEDITE LEGISLATIVE
EXPECTATIONS THAT CSU
INCORPORATE BEST PRACTICES INTO
ITS HIRING DECISIONS -- AS YOU
THINK ABOUT THESE DIFFERENT
APPROACHES AND DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS FOR THE TO IMPROVE
FACULTY DIVERSITY WE ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER WAYS -- TO EXPAND
PRACTICES ACROSS THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM AND EXPAND PRACTICES
USING ITS ENTIRE BUDGET AND
INCORPORATE THE MOST UP TO DATE
INFORMATION AND ALL OF ITS
HIRING DECISIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FINANCE MY COLLEAGUES
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING.
MORNING CHRIS FERGUSON WITH
FINANCE I THINK WE JUST FELT THE
WE DID NOT INCLUDE A PROPOSAL
REGARDING EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
HOWEVER ON THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR LANGUAGE FOR FULL
TIME FACULTY THAT'S LARGELY
CONSISTENT WITH AN ACTION TAKEN
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET --
OUT GROUP WHICH SHOP FINANCE DID
NOT HAVE CONCERNS WITH.
GOT IT QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
MEMBERS MISTER MOORE Là.
I'M JUST CURIOUS MADAM CHAIR IF
IF THERE'S A STUDY THAT'S BEEN
DONE [inaudible]
TO KIND OF ENCOURAGE THE
EFFICACY OF TENURE -- IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S A GOOD THING.
OR IS TURN YOUR NOT.
DOING WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING.
WITH THE MCCARTY SAID PAGING DR
WEBER OF SENATOR SKINNER AND
DOCTOR WEBER CAN UPON IF SHE SO
CHOOSES THEN SKINNER.
I AM NOT AWARE OF SUCH STORIES
ON TENURE BUT TENURE TRACK IS
ONE OF IS THE MAIN WAY.
THAT ARE CSU SYSTEM IN OUR UC
SYSTEM.
HIRE PERMANENT FULL TIME FACULTY
SO IN OTHER WORDS.
IF YOU'RE NOT ON TENURE TRACK
YOU TEND NOT TO BE A FULL TIME --
IN A FULL TIME FACULTY POSITION
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE A LECTURER
THAT TENDS TO BE PART TIME
THERE'S OTHER PART TIME TYPE
POSITIONS.
AND THE REASON I AM SUPPORTIVE
OF EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF FULL
TIME WHICH IN THIS CASE IT IN
THESE CATEGORIES ARE OF TENURE
TRACK.
IS HAVING -- TAUGHT AT VARIOUS
UC'S OVER THE YEARS PRIMARILY AS
A PART TIME EITHER LECTURE OTHER
CATEGORY.
I DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICE.
I COULD NOT HAVE OFFICE HOURS
BECAUSE THEY DID NOT HAVE AN
OFFICE AND SINCE I WAS ONLY PART
TIME I HAD OTHER JOBS SO MY
ABILITY TO SPEND TIME WITH ANY
OF MY STUDENTS OUTSIDE OF CLASS.
WAS PRETTY RESTRICTED AND AS WE
KNOW STUDENT SUCCESS IS OFTEN
DEPENDENT ON THEIR ABILITY TO
INTERACT.
WITH THEIR INSTRUCTOR OR IF IT'S
A LARGE ENOUGH CLASS THERE TA SO --
BOTH IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND OUR UC AND CSU SYSTEM
I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF OUR
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE AS MANY
FULL TIME FACULTY AS POSSIBLE.
BUT TO OUR RESERVATION LOOK AND
I GUESS I SHOULD SAY SOMETHING
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO OUT ON
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME WORK DONE
ON ON TEN YEAR CONTINUE TRACK
THE PROBLEM I THINK WITH MOST
FOLKS IS THEY MISUNDERSTAND WHAT
TENURE AREAS IN TEN YEARS NO
MORE THAN.
SAYING YOUR PERMIT FACULTY WITH
CERTAIN RIGHTS NOW IS ONCE YOU
ACQUIRE TENURE IT'S NOT A
PERMANENT THING I'VE KNOWN FOLKS
WHO'VE BEEN FIRED WHO IT TENURE.
OF LORD NOT DOING THEIRJOB AND
NOT PERFORMING AT A LEVEL THEY
SHOULD BE A DISMISS THIS
REGARDING STUDENTS SO IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT SAYS YOU CAN
NEVER BE FIRED AGAIN.
BUT IT SAYS THAT IF THEY'RE
GOING TO DO ANY ACTION ON YOU
YOU HAVE TO AT LEAST DO HAVE DUE
PROCESS AFTER YEARS OF WORKING
THERE.
HAVE TO NOTIFY YOU THAT TO TRY
TO REMEDIATE WHAT'S GOING ON
THAT THAT KIND OF STUFF AND SO
AS A RESULT IT IS NOT A
PERMANENT JOB THING BUT IT'S
ABOUT.
STATUS AS THE ONE OF THINGS THAT
DID HAPPEN AND AND AND I WENT TO
THE HEARING I'M TRYING TO
REMEMBER WHAT COMMITTEE DID I
THINK IT WAS HIGHER IT AND IT
HAD A COMMITTEE.
I HAD A MEETING AT SAN JOSE A
FEW YEARS BACK CONCERNING ALL
ALL STUDENT SUCCESS AND WOULD
HELP TO STUDENT SUCCESS.
AND THEY TALKED ABOUT --
DIVERSITY OF FACULTY.
THAT STUDENTS IF THEY HAVE
FACULTY THAT LOOK LIKE THEM THAT
HAVE BASICALLY UNDERSTAND THEIR
AGENDA AND WHAT'S GOING ON THEY
HAVE A GREATER SENSE OF OF
SURVIVING AND REMAINING IN THAT
INSTITUTION SO THAT.
SO THAT WAS REAL CLEAR VERY
STRONG AMONG COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WELL AS OTHERS.
IT ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT A PART OF BEING FACULTY IS
MENTORING AND SUPPORTING
STUDENTS.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE A LOT OF UNTIL
NEW FACULTY THEN -- YOU DON'T
YOU DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY OF
THEM TO BASICALLY BE WOULD
STUDENTS FOR THE LONG HAUL IT
MAY BE HERE TODAY BUT IF IF YOU
I WAS A FULL PROFESSOR TENURE
FACULTY FOR FORTY YEARS AND SO
AS A RESULT.
YOU KNOW I WALK THROUGH STUDENTS
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF NOT ONLY
UNDERGRADUATE BUT ALSO GRADUATE
EDUCATION IN TERMS OF BEING A
MENTOR SUPPORTER THEY KNEW WHERE
I WAS WE HAD OFFICE HOURS YOU
COULD HELP TO THOSE KIND OF
THINGS.
AND THAT'S CRITICAL IN TERMS OF
STUDENT SUCCESS -- ALSO WHAT'S
EQUALLY IMPORTANT IS THAT
INSTITUTIONS SUPPOSEDLY RUN BY
TENURED FACULTY.
THE WHOLE ISSUE OF FACULTY
COLLABORATION THE ACADEMIC
SENATE ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
AS A FACULTY MEMBER I WAS ON
PERSONNEL COMMITTEES I WAS ON
RECRUITMENT COMMITTEES I WAS ON
CURRICULUM COMMITTEES IN THE
SENATE.
SO WE WERE BASICALLY THE WHOLE
IDEA OF COLLEGIALITY AND RUNNING
THE INSTITUTION LIES IN THE
HANDS OF THE TENURED FACULTY --
SO THAT'S A PART OF THEIR
WORKFLOW TO BASICALLY HELP RUN
THE INSTITUTIONS SO IT HAS A A
LOT OF THINGS ABOUT IT THAT'S
GOOD IT HAS SOME THINGS THAT ARE
OBVIOUSLY MISUSED.
AND AND IT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE FACULTY THE CAMPUS TO
CORRECT THOSE THINGS WHEN THEY
ARE WHEN THAT WHEN THAT TENURE
STATUS IS MISUSED.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I WAS VERY
HELPFUL THANK YOUTHANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS ON ISSUE.
THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU WILL MOVE
ON ISSUE THIRTY FIVE SUPPORT
PROGRAMS FOR FORMALLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS.
ELIA.
THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU -- OUR
SERIES OF ACTIONS TAKEN BY BOTH
HOUSES -- THAT SUPPORTS UP
PROGRAMS IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
THAT PROVIDE ASSISTANCE FOR
STUDENTS WHO WERE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED -- THESE PROGRAMS
FOCUS BOTH ON PROVIDING.
A SERVICES TO SPEAK TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HOPING TO
ATTEND COLLEGE IN HELPING THEM
IN THE APPLICATION PROCESS ALSO
ONCE THEY ARRIVE ON A COLLEGE
CAMPUS THEY PROVIDE IS A SERIES
OF SERVICES TO HELP THE STUDENTS
SUCCEED -- WHAT'S THERE AND
ROLLED.
THERE ARE THREE ISSUES -- WE
THINK THAT YOU COULD CONSIDER AS
YOU AS YOU WEIGH THE DIFFERENT
HOUSES OPTIONS HERE -- THE FIRST --
AS WE WOULD NOTE THAT -- THE
ASSEMBLY ADOPTED A GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
A CSU PROGRAM AND THEN PROVIDED
MORE FUNDING IN ADDITION TO THAT.
ON THE SENATE ALSO ADOPTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE CSU
PROGRAM BUT ALSO PROVIDED ONE
TIME FUNDING.
ACROSS THE THREE HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS FOR THEIR
PROGRAMS SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO
THINK ABOUT AS YOUR WINGS
DIFFERENT APPROACHES A WHICH
SEGMENT YOU'D LIKE TO DIRECT
FUNDING TO AND WHEN WHETHER
THERE'S A A WAY TO SORT OF A
DIVIDE UP THAT FUNDING FOR
EXAMPLE BASED ON ENROLLMENT.
SECONDS WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
THE PURPOSE OF THE FUNDS COULD
COULD DIFFER DEPENDING ON HOW
THE PROGRAMS INTENDED USE THEIR
EITHER ON GOING A ONE TIME
FUNDING.
ON SOME PROGRAMS COULD EXPAND
THEIR SERVICES TO MORECAMPUSES
WITHIN THEIR SYSTEM SO FOR
EXAMPLE.
ABOUT HALF OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
DISTRICTS -- HAVE A A PROGRAM
AND SO THAT THE DIGITAL FUNDING
FOR SEIZE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
COULD BE USED TO EXPAND TO MORE
CAMPUSES.
ALTERNATIVELY IF SOME K<c.cyan> SOME</c>
PROGRAMS MIGHT.
TRY TO EXPAND MORE SERVICES AT
THEIR EXISTING CAMPUSES AND SO
THAT THOSE ARE TWO DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES AND YOU MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER WHICH OF THOSE MIGHT BE
YOUR HIGHEST PRIORITY WITH THESE
FUNDS.
AND THEN THIRD WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THE HOUSE IS DIFFERENT
TERMS OF ON GOING IN ONE TIME
FUNDING.
OF THE SENATE PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME FUNDING THE
ASSEMBLY PROVIDES ONGOING
FUNDING WE KNOW THAT BROADLY
SPEAKING THESE PROGRAMS DO
PROVIDE ONGOING SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS INTRODUCED TO THE
EXTENT YOU PROVIDE ONE TIME
FUNDING.
COULD CREATE COST PRESSURES IN
FUTURE YEARS TO SUSTAIN THESE
ACTIVITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FINANCE HE
ADMINISTRATION -- SUPPORTS THE
GOALS OF PROJECT REBOUND
INCLUDED FUNDING FOR THAT
PURPOSE -- FOR THE OTHER ITEMS
HERE -- THE MYSTERIES VOICE
RIGHT NOW THEY DON'T FIT WITHIN
OUR BUDGET FRAMEWORK IN PART FOR
THE REASON THE LA -- MENTIONED
ABOUT THAT MATCH BETWEEN ONE
TIME AND ONGOING COSTS -- IS
THERE ANY INTEREST IN I KNOW I'M
LOOKING AT THE CAMPUSES THAT
CURRENTLY ARE FUNDED UNDER
PROJECT REBOUND AT NIGHT NO THIS
ONE CAMPUS IN PARTICULAR IN IN
THE LA COUNTY THAT'S NOT THERE.
IS HOW DID THESE CAMPUSES COME
TO BE. TO TO PARTICIPATE.
RECORD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE ORIGINAL -- CAMPUS THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE PROGRAM WAS
UC SAN FRAN.
EXCUSE ME SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY I WHICH IS HOW TO
PROGRAM SINCE THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES.
AND IN TWENTY SIXTEEN EIGHT
ADDITIONAL CAMPUSES OF THE CS%
USE TWENTY THREE OPTED TO OUT ON
ANY PLAN FOR ADDITIONAL
EXPANSION.
AT THE GOVERNOR'S OR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
ONE MILLION ON GOING IS INTENDED.
TO BASICALLY TAKE THE PLACE OF
PHILANTHROPIC GRANT FUNDS THAT
ARE EXPIRING FOR THE PROGRAM IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE EXISTING
BECAUSE PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OF THE
THIRTY NIELSEN FELL BY THIRTY
SKINNER.
WHAT SORT OF MONITORING AND
TRACKING AND REPORTING
[inaudible]
OF SUCCESS.
I'M SYMPATHETIC BUT NOT WITHOUT.
SOME BENCHMARKS.
OF SUCCESS.
THESE PROGRAMS.
HOW WILL WE ACCOUNT FOR THE
UNIVERSE OF THOSE PARTICIPATING
HOW THEY ARE DOING AND
TRANSITIONING?
OF THE CSU HAVE CONDUCTED A
SURVEY OF PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS
FOR PROJECT REBOUND.
OF THEIR MOST RECENT SURVEY HAD
TO DO WITH -- WAS CONDUCTED IN
FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THEY
INDICATED IN THAT TIME THAT HE
87% OF THE PROGRAM GRADUATES
WERE EMPLOYED OR ENROLLED IN
GRADUATE SCHOOL AFTER GRADUATING.
AND THEY ALSO REPORTED THE
RESULTS OF THAT SURVEY BEING
THAT THEY HAD 0% RECIDIVISM RATE
AFTER THREE YEARS FOR THAT
COHORT OF GRADUATING STUDENTS
AND WHAT ABOUT YOU SEE
[inaudible]
THE WE DON'T HAVE ANY PARTICULAR --
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TODAY ON
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS BUT I I
SUSPECT THAT THEY ARE HAVING
POSITIVE RESULTS AS WELL.
WELL THAT'S NOT SUFFICIENT OKAY
YOU SEE.
THE AS YOU GO THE LONG HIGHER UP
THE EFFICACY AND SUCCESS AND THE
NUMBERS.
ARE GOING TO BE DIMINISHED
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE GREATER
PARTICIPATION IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS A TRANSITION.
BUT YOU SHE SHOULD NOT BE EXEMPT
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE LANGUAGE IN
THE BUDGET REQUIRES YOU SEE TO
REPORT.
AND TRACK SUCCESS JUST LIKE CSU
S..
WE CAN.
DO THAT THEN I COULD HAVE SOME
CONFIDENCE BUT JUST.
TO JD YOU SEE WELL NOW JUST DO
IT.
NOW WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTING THIS IS A DELICATE
AREA.
COULD BE VERY HELPFUL.
MANY INMATES HAVE HAD GREAT
SUCCESS [inaudible]
WITH THEIR PROGRAMS IN CUSTODY.
BUT KEEP TRACK OF WHICH IS ONE
OF THE GREAT DEFICIENCIES OF
CORRECTIONS HISTORICALLY IN ALL
PROGRAMMING.
IS A FAILURE TO KEEP TRACK OF
THE SUCCESS RATES.
AND JUST THROW MORE MONEY AND
MORE MONEY MORE MONEY.
AND WE DID NOT SEE SUCCESSES
HERE THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
BUT IT'S GOT TO BE DIRECTED
TOWARD SUCCESS AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
DEALING WITH A POPULATION THAT'S
MORE CHALLENGE MORE
DISADVANTAGED GOING IN TO THE
COLLEGE LEVEL.
REGIMENT.
AND LEVELS OF WORK IS QUIET SO
WE NEED TO KEEP TRACK OF THE
ROLE OF A JUST A BIT TRY TO
ANSWER MY COLLEAGUES.
QUESTION ON REPORTING -- IT'S
NOT APPARENT FROM THE MATERIAL.
IN YOUR BINDER BUT THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE WITH RESPECT TO
PROJECT REBOUND.
APPROVED SOME OF REPORTING
LANGUAGE FOR EXAMPLE THAT.
REQUIRES REPORTING IN APRIL --
ONE TWENTY TWENTY THIS SAYS ON
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDS FUNDING
SOURCES AND TYPES OF PROGRAMS AT
C. ISSUE CAMPUS IS USED TO
SUPPORT FORMERLY INCARCERATED
STUDENTS.
NEXT HOW THE CAMPUS PROGRAMS
COORDINATE WITH OTHER SUPPORT
SERVICES IN THE VERY STATEWIDE
AND LOCAL INITIATIVES FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE.
AND THE OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS FUNDING SO THAT REPORTING
LANGUAGE REQUIREMENT IS ON THE
SENATE SIDE.
WITH RESPECT TO PROJECT
REDUNDANCY ISSUE.
MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY.
I JUST LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NO CONCERNS
WITH THE SENATE'S PROPOSED
REPORTING LANGUAGE FOR PROJECT
RENOWNED.
THANK YOU WITH SKINNER.
THANK YOU --THIS.
IS CLEARLY MONEY THAT IS WE'RE
DEALING WITH THIS IN EDUCATION
BECAUSE IT'S EDUCATION MONEY
THOUGH THE IN OUR PUBLIC SAFETY --
BUDGET SUB FIVE WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF HEARINGS ON BOTH THE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS WITHIN
OUR STATE PRISONS AND THE
REENTRY PROGRAMS.
AND WE ARE NOW AT THE PIECES IN
THE SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE
PRESENCE BY RCS USE OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND A NUMBER
OF UC'S.
IN MANY MANY OF OUR STATE
PRISONS.
AND THE FACT THAT ARE DIFFERENT
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
ARE OFFERING COURSE WORK AT THE
PRISON LEVEL.
THEN HAS INCREASED THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHEN THEY LEAVE PRISON TO
ENTER THOSE FACILITIES.
AND WHAT AS HAS BEEN SORT OF
NOTED OF COURSE SUCH A STUDENT
DOES NEED SOME MORE SUPPORT THAN
OTHER STUDENTS.
AND THESE PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE --
THE CSU PROGRAM -- PROJECT
RENOWNED WAS STARTED I BELIEVE
IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE AND IT
WAS PRIMARILY AT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE UNTIL RECENTLY BUT NOW AS
DIFFERENT CSU CAMPUSES HAVE
EXPANDED IN THE STATE PRISONS IT
MAKES THAT MUCH MORE SENSE --
FOR PROGRAMS LIKE PROJECT
REBOUND TO ALSO EXPAND AT THE AT
THEIR OWN STATE FACILITIES.
SO I I WOULD ANTICIPATE NO I
HOPE THAT WHAT PROJECT REBOUND
HAS IN MIND IS TO DO SOMETHING
SIMILAR AS TO WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
WHEN IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WHEN
WE APPROVED THE FUNDING FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OPENED
UP A GRANT PROGRAM AND THE
DIFFERENT COMMITTEE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES THAT HAD EITHER STRONG
PRESENCE IN THE PRISONS. FOR A
GOOD NUMBER OF RE ENTRY FOLKS
ALREADY ENROLLED THEN APPLIED
FOR FUNDING TO BE ABLE -- TO IN
OKAY AB MAKE THEIR SUPPORT.
SERVICES ROBUST AND SO I NOTE
THE CHEERS POINT THAT THERE'S
FEWER CS USE THAN WE'D
POTENTIALLY HOPE BUT I WOULD --
ANTICIPATE THAT WITH THIS IF WE
WERE TO APPROVE.
THE FUNDS THAT WE WOULD SEE AN
EXPANSION OF CSU CAMPUSES THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE PROJECT
REBOUND -- PROGRAM NO IN THE UC
SYSTEM.
THE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS WE
STARTED AT UC BERKELEY AND THAT
PROGRAM NOT ONLY SUPPORTS THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE REENTRY
STUDENTS AT UC BUT ALSO SUPPORTS.
THE X..
THE DEVELOPMENT OF SUCH PROGRAMS
AT BOTH CSU CAMPUSES AND OTHER
UC'S. FIVE THERE ARE FEWER OF
OUR FORMALLY INCARCERATED WHO
ARE ATTENDING THE UC SYSTEM BUT
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH A NUMBER OF
THEM HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL AND MANY ARE NOW IN
PHD PROGRAMS.
SO I CERTAINLY CAN -- ASK
PROJECT -- RATHER UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS TO GIVE US SOME NUMBERS
ON THE SUCCESS SO FAR.
BUT OF WITH THE DIFF SMALL
NUMBER THAT HAVE BEEN AT THE UC
SYSTEM THAT THE INTERACTIONS
I'VE SEEN IN REPORTS I'VE SEEN
THAT THE SUCCESS RATE IS QUITE
HIGH.
BUT I THINK THIS -- THIS
RELATIVELY MODEST EXPENDITURE IN
THESE THREE SYSTEMS VERY MUCH
COMPLIMENTS.
THE BOTH THE EXPANDED
REHABILITATION THAT WE'RE DOING
WITHIN OUR STATE PRISON
FACILITIES AND OUR FOCUS ON
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
MISS MCCARTY.
YEAH THANK YOU YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY WITH ALL THAT PROGRAMS
AND EFFORTS FOR DOING CHANGING
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WE
NEED MORE FOCUS ON RE ENTRY --
THAT'S WHY ALL THESE PROGRAMS
ARE ARE WORTHY AND I WILL KNOW
THAT THEY'RE ALL PRUDENT AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT WITH THAT.
UC BERKELEY SCHOLARS BUT
SPECIFICALLY PROJECT RIBBON AT I
WILL NOTE WITH WITH A LOT OF
TIME THAT HAPPENS IS
PHILANTHROPY STARTS A PROGRAM.
AND SEE IF IT WORKS AND THEN THE
DENTIST THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE
THERE FOREVER ITSELF IT'S A
WORTHY PROGRAM TURN OVER TO THE
GOVERNMENT TAKE WE TRY THIS IT'S
PROVEN.
AND THAT THE MILLION THAT'S IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
WOULDN'T FIND PROJECT READ ON
THEY HAVE TO CUT BACK AT SOME OF
THOSE EIGHT CAMPUSES AND SO THIS
TO SEE.
THE ASSEMBLY ACTION WITH THE
THREE POINT THREE ONGOING KEEPS
THEM WHERE THEY'RE AT TODAY.
AND SO I THINK THAT THAT'S
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IT
THAT THE ONE MILLION I WOULD
HAVE THAT HAVE TO CUT SOME OF
THOSE THE CAMPUSES AND CERTAINLY
WOULD LIKE TO GROW TO OTHER.
ISSUES BUT AGAIN THIS ACTION
JUST ONLY ALLOWS A DATE TO KEEP
BROTHER AT TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
WILL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN MOVING
ON TO ISSUE THIRTY SIX STILL NOT
REACH.
ELIA.
THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU HERE ARE A
SERIES OF ACTIONS TAKEN.
BY THE GOVERNOR GOVERNOR IN EACH
OF THE HOUSES REGARDING --
HIGHER EDUCATION OUTREACH
PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS AT A HIGH LEVEL
OF PROVIDE SERVICES TO K. TWELVE
STUDENTS WITH THE OVER ARCHING
OBJECTIVE OF IMPROVING COLLEGE
PARTICIPATION.
I'M CONSIDERED AS ONE PACKAGE
THE TWO HOUSES -- ARE VERY
SIMILAR IN CLOSE IN TERMS OF THE
FUNDING AMOUNTS TO THE A
SENATE'S PROVIDING EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING IN THE ASSEMBLY IS
PROVIDING TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FUNDING. TO THE
ISSUE A CONFERENCE ARE REALLY
ARE THE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS --
THAT WOULD BE WOULD RECEIVE THE
FUNDING OTHER PROGRAMS ARE A MIX
OF THE PROPOSALS THAT WERE MADE
BY THE GOVERNOR AND ALSO SOME
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS.
TO AMEND HOUSES DON'T HAVE ANY
CROSSOVER IN TERMS OF THE PER
PROGRAMS.
IF YOU'RE CONSIDERING -- WHICH
PROGRAMS TO FIND AND AND THIS
ITEM OVERALL WE REACHED THREE
ISSUES FOR CONSIDERATION.
FIRST WE WOULD NOTE THAT EACH
PROGRAM HAS A SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT
FOCUSES IN TERMS OF THE
ACTIVITIES HE SUPPORTS A FOR
EXAMPLE.
SOME OUT REACH PROGRAM FOCUS
MORE ON IMPROVING FINANCIAL AID
AWARENESS OTHERS PROVIDE PEER
MENTORING AND TUTORING AND SO
YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER WHICH
OF THOSE ACTIVITIES ARE THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY FOR YOU AND
YOUR AND YOUR MAKING FINAL
BUDGET DECISIONS.
SECOND WE ALSO NOTE THAT SOME
PROPOSALS HAVE A A CLOSER SERVE
GEOGRAPHIC LINCOLN OR ARE LINKED
TO SPECIFIC AREAS OF THE STATE
OTHERS HAVE A MORE STATEWIDE
FOCUS WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO TRY TO
FIND WAYS TO TO MAXIMIZE THE
FUNDING AND ADDRESS.
A NEEDS ACROSS THE STATE.
THIRD -- WE ALSO NOTE THAT --
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS ARE
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND SOME OF
THEM AREN'T OUR NEW INITIATIVES.
AND A ONE OPTION FOR YOU IF
YOU'RE CONSIDERING WHICH
INITIATIVE DEFINED AS TO AS TO
FOCUS ON INITIATIVES THAT OUR
LONG STANDING AND HAVE A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD.
THAT MIGHT GIVE YOU SOME MORE
CONFERENCE AS TO HOW THE FUND TO
BE SPENT IN THE KIND OF OUTCOMES
YOU MIGHT EXPECT TO SEE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS THE
ASSEMBLIES ACTIONS AND APPROVING
OUR PROPOSALS ON THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT SUCCESS
AWARENESS INITIATIVE.
AS WELL AS THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION STUDENT LOAN OUR
REGION IT SHOULD HAVE.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE SENATE
ACTION IN APPROVING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH. TO ADMINISTER
INNOVATION GRANTS TARGETED FOR
THE SAN JOAQUIN AN INLAND EMPIRE
REGIONS OF THE STATE
[inaudible]
QUESTION.
MEMBERS THREE MARLA.
MA'AM CHURCH SEEMS LIKE WE HAVE
TWO INITIATIVES GOING ON ONE IS
TO PROVIDE FREE.
COLLEGE AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
LEVEL ONE AND NOW HERE WE'RE
TRYING TO MAYBE ASSIST.
IN EDUCATING THEM ON HOW TO
FINANCE.
EDUCATION SO I'M.
JUST CURIOUS MAYBE IN FIFTY
WORDS OR LESS WHAT IS A STUDENT
SUCCESS AWARENESS TEAM.
CERTAINLY I THINK THE THE
STUDENT SUCCESS AWARENESS
INITIATIVE AT THE THAT WOULD BE
HOUSED AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
AND MATERIALS TO THE COLLEGES.
TO A MESSAGE TO STUDENTS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM --
STUDENT SUCCESS INITIATIVES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE AND OUT THERE TO
STUDENTS AS WELL AS PROVIDE SOME
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
OPPORTUNITIES TO FACULTY -- TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW THE
PROBLEMS FRAMEWORK --
ESTABLISHES COLLEGE GOING
CULTURES AND REALLY HELPS --
STUDENTS SUCCEED.
THAT THE TEAM IN IN MANY
RESPECTS IS REFERRING -- TO THE
ACTUAL PROVISION OF OUT REACH
AND MATERIALS TO COLLEGES AS
OPPOSED TO A SPECIFIC TEAM OF
INDIVIDUALS. FOR YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED THAT THIS IS LACKING.
I THINK WE'VE IDENTIFIED THAT
THERE IS A GOD THAT IT IS A
POSITIVE THING TO PROVIDE.
THIS TYPE OF INFORMATION OUT
REACH TO COLLEGES AND ULTIMATELY
TO STUDENTS TO HELP THEM.
BE SUCCESSFUL -- IN THEIR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ENDEAVORS.
THIS IS A ONE TIME.
THAT'S CORRECT I THINK.
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE.
VERY AWARE D. A. B. -- NINETEEN
YEAH I HAVE EXEMPTIONS ARE
TUITION EXEMPTIONS CAME TO BE IN
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FISCAL YEAR SO THIS REALLY IS
THE FIRST YEAR OF THE PROGRAM --
IT IS A NEW PROGRAM IN THAT
RESPECT SO WE'RE WE'RE
DEVELOPING SOME MATERIALS AND
PROVIDING SOME OUT REACH.
TO SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THANK.
Q. ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS [inaudible]
WITH MAYES.
TALK A BIT ABOUT THE THE
INNOVATION GRANTS AND AND WHY
SAN JOAQUIN IN INLAND EMPIRE --
IF YOU HAVEN'T REALIZED MUST
THAT MIGHT BE A LITTLE.
BIASED -- TOWARDS THE INLAND
EMPIRE -- BUT WHAT WE'LL.
TALK ABOUT THE INNOVATION GRANTS.
SERVICE PROPOSAL IS TARGETED FOR
THE SAN JOAQUIN INLAND EMPIRE
REGIONS OF THE STATE FOR A FEW
REASONS -- PRIMARILY WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THOSE AREAS AS AREAS
THAT ARE PARTICULARLY DESERVING
AT THIS POINT IN TIME OF SOME
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT FOR
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES.
IN MULTI SEGMENTAL EDUCATION
FROM BOTH KINDERGARTEN ALL THE
WAY THROUGH A UNIVERSITY LEVEL.
AND SAN JOAQUIN AND ONE INLAND
EMPIRE IN PARTICULAR.
BOTH OF THOSE AREAS HAVE LOWER
PER CAPITA AVERAGE INCOME
COMPARED TO THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE HIGHER RATES OF
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPARED TO THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE AND ALSO LOWER
RATES OF UC AND CSU ELIGIBILITY
DESPITE HAVING.
A LARGER NUMBER OR INCREASING
NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
IN THE REGIONS FOR THOSE REASONS
AT THIS PROPOSAL IS TARGETED.
AT AWARDING GRANTS TO
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS WHERE
THERE K. TWELVE OR HIGHER
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS IN
THOSE TWO REGIONS.
I GUESS I'M JUST TRYING TO TO TO
THINK OF WHY WHY WE WOULDN'T
WANT TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT I
THINK WE'VE ALL KNOWN FOR A LONG
TIME WITHIN THOSE TWO COUNTIES
UP THROUGH THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EVEN IN THE NORTH STATE.
AND THOSE ARE AREAS THAT ARE --
DISADVANTAGED WE OFTEN FEEL --
LIKE WE DON'T GET OUR FAIR SHARE --
AND IT'S ESPECIALLY WE'RE TALK
ABOUT OPPORTUNITY BOB AND SO IT
SEEMED TO ME APPROPRIATE TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT.
A SUPPORT THAT EFFORT.
I MEAN TO SUPPORT THE SENATE
ACTION OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
KING.
QUESTION SO JUST -- TO TO FIND
AT THE THINK THE REASON WE ENDED
UP BRIDGE ACTING IT AND MOVING --
THE MONEY TO CAL SO BECAUSE
WITHOUT THAT THAT KELSO PROGRAM
SINCE IT HAD ALREADY BEEN UP AND
RUNNING RATHER THAN HAVING A
BRAND NEW PROGRAM.
NEW -- HAVEN'T TO SET UP NEW
ADMINISTRATION ON A PARTICULAR
REGION HALF THE MONEY GO INTO AN
EXISTING PROGRAM THAT SEEM TO
HAVE SUCCESS OR JUST WANT
UNDERSTAND WHY.
WHY NOT INVEST IN THE CURRENT
PROGRAM INDOORS IF YOU KNOW WHAT
THE COMPROMISE OF ONE OR?
TWO WHEN I GET RID OF IT.
WHY HAVE A WHOLE NEW?
PROGRAM WHEN YOU HAVE AN
EXISTING PROGRAM THAT'S CHARGED
WITH DOING THIS.
WE DEFINITELY RECOGNIZE THE
VALUE IN THE CAL SO PROGRAM IN
THE EXISTING SORT OF CONSORTIUM
BASED PROGRAMMING EFFORTS THAT
THAT PROGRAM PROVIDES.
HOWEVER THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
IS MORE TARGETED TO SPECIFICALLY
TO THE SAN JOAQUIN IN INLAND
EMPIRE REGIONS OF THE STATE.
BECAUSE WE HAD IDENTIFIED THOSE
AS AREAS THAT PARTICULARLY
NEEDED SOME ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT.
AND I WOULD I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT ON THE INNOVATION GRANT
CITED ISN'T JUST FOCUSED ON OUT
REACH THAT'S INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES TO HELP WITH STUDENT
SUCCESS WITH CREATING.
COLLEGE GOING CULTURES WITH
FOCUSING ON THIS TWO GENERATIONS
STRATEGY -- THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT FORWARD
WHICH IS HOW CAN WE HELP THE
STUDENTS OF TODAY AND ALSO HELP
THE STUDENTS OF TOMORROW THAT
ARE THEIR CHILDREN.
AND AND AND THAT'S GREAT BUT I
GUESS WHY NOT JUST PASSED THE
EXISTING.
PROGRAM TO GO DO THAT THEN.
SET UP A WHOLE NEW STRIPPER SAYS
THAT THE HOME TO STRUCTURE AND
FRAMEWORK TO DO IT WHEN WE DON'T
KNOW IF IT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
SUCCESSFUL.
SHOULD I I WOULD GO BACK.
TO THE CURRENT KELSO PROGRAM IS
FOCUSED ON STUDENT OUTREACH
WEARS A THINK WERE WERE FOCUSED
ON A MORE BROAD STRATEGY THAT
INCLUDES THIS TO GENERATION
STRATEGY -- SO IT'S NOT JUST
TARGETED TOWARD OUTREACH.
NO UNDERSTOOD BUT THEN WHY NOT
JUST ASK COUNSEL TO EXPAND THEIR
SCOPE BECAUSE YOU'RE ASKING.
PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T COME FORWARD
IT.
TO DO SOMETHING THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY.
DO OR WE DON'T KNOW.
EVEN ACCESS.
SO I I THINK.
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY KELSO PASSAGE
ITS FOCUS TODAY AND I THINK --
WE WERE ATTEMPTING TO FOCUS ON
TWO SPECIFIC REGIONS OF THE
STATUS AS OPPOSED TO THOSE BROAD
FIFTEEN CONSORTIUM THAT ARE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO WE WERE
DEFINITELY MUCH MORE TARGETED IN
OUR APPROACH -- BUT CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE GOD YOU KNOW WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM.
THE COUNTRY JUST ASK HOUSE UP.
TO TARGET AS WELL.
ANYTIME WE TARGET SOMETHING WE
NEED TO CREATE SOMETHING NEW OR
COULD WE ACCESS PEOPLE WHO'VE
BEEN DOING IT FOR A WHILE.
TO FOCUS A LITTLE BIT.
CHAU.
I THINK IN MANY RESPECTS YOU
HAVE YOUR KELSO PROGRAM AND WE
WOULD HAVE THIS INNOVATION GRANT
PROGRAM -- ULTIMATELY THE
INNOVATION GRANTS ARE ALSO
OPERATED BY A OUR EXISTING
INSTITUTIONS AS WELL SO WE WOULD
BE LOOKING AT PARTNERSHIPS WITH
YOU SEE CSU.
OCCUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES YOUR K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS SO IT IN MANY
RESPECTS WERE ALSO SUPPORTING
THE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE --
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SENATOR A THE THING
ABOUT DRUGS AND JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT WHILE I'M.
AMBIVALENT WITH RESPECT TO NEW
PROGRAM VERSUS KELSO BY I WOULD
NOTE FOR THE RECORD THAT -- IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OR THE
INLAND EMPIRE OF WAS LEFT ON THE
TRAIN STATION PLATFORM AND TRAIN
PULLED OUT I DON'T SEE INLAND
EMPIRE IN THE KELSO PROGRAM SO.
WE CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE TO MAKE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS.
TO IT WOULD SEEM TO ME FOR THOSE
OF US WHO COME FROM THAT AREA OF
FIFTH CAL SOAP IS THE FINAL
DESTINATION FOR THIS.
THIS FUNDING.
THANK MANAGER THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THIS OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I I AGREE --
I THINK PART OF THE REASON FOR
JUSTIFYING THIS FUNDING IS THAT.
THESE ARE A COUPLE REASON THE
STATE THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND.
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS I THINK
IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE PROCESS
DIRECT OUR RESOURCES IN THAT
DIRECTION SO REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT WE INSTITUTE NEW
PROGRAM USE EXISTING PROGRAM I
THINK IT'S ABOUT ON US TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT MONEY GOES TO
WHERE IT'S MOST NEEDED.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER COMMENTS.
WILL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE THIRTY
SEVEN CAL GRANTS COMPETITIVE
SUMMER AND ACCESS AWARDS ALEJO.
THANK YOU THE STICKING WITH THE
LA L..
THIS ISSUE COVER SEVERAL ACTIONS
RELATED TO THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
BOTH HOUSES REJECTED THE
GOVERNOR'S NINETY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL TO STUDENTS
PARENTS.
AND INSTEAD REDIRECTED THE FUNDS
TOWARD OTHER CONTENT PRIORITIES.
THE SENATE BUT MOST OF THESE
FUNDS BETWEEN TWO MAJOR ACTIONS.
ONE OF THOSE ACTIONS EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE AWARDS
WHICH ARE TYPICALLY AVAILABLE TO
OLDER STUDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM.
THE OTHER ACTION WOULD EXPAND
THE SIZE OF THE AXIS.
WHICH IS AVAILABLE TO LOWER
INCOME CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS TO
ASSIST WITH THE LIVING COSTS.
ASSEMBLY IN CONTRAST PRIMARILY
RETRACTED THE FUNDS TOWARD
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE AWARDS.
THE BY A LARGER AMOUNT.
IT ALSO DOCTORTRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD PRIORITIZE
STUDENT PARENTS FOR THOSE AWARDS.
FINALLY BOTH HOUSES A DOCTOR
POLICY CHANGE THAT WOULD MAKE
STUDENTS ELIGIBLE FOR CAL GRANTS
DURING THE SUMMER.
WITHOUT THIS COMING TOWARD THE
MAXIMUM TIME LIMIT FOR RECEIVING
AID.
THE BIGGEST DECISION BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY IS HOW TO
DISTRIBUTE THE AVAILABLE FUNDS
BETWEEN PROVIDING MORE
APPLICANTS WITH AWARDS TO THE
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM.
AND INCREASING THE SIZE OF THOSE
AWARDS THROUGH THE ACCESS
COMPONENT.
BOTH OF THESE AUGMENTATIONS ARE
REASONABLE.
AS MANY OF YOU NOTE REGARDING
THE COMPETITIVE AWARD PROGRAM
THERE ARE ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
EACH YEAR FOR ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND AVAILABLE WORDS.
SUGGESTING THAT THERE IS A LARGE
AMOUNT OF ON THAT DEMAND FOR
THIS PROGRAM.
AS FOR THE ACCESS OR TO MOUNT
THE CURRENT AWARD OF ABOUT
SIXTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR
COVERS A RELATIVELY SMALL SHARE
OF STUDENTS LIVING COSTS.
CONSIDERATION WE WOULD RAISES
LEGISLATURE WAYS THESE TWO
POSSIBLE ACTIONS IS THAT THEY DO
HAVE DIFFERENT FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS IN THE OUT YEARS.
ADDING COMPETITIVE AWARDS IS
ACTION THAT WAY IT SIMPLY PHASE
AND OVER THE COURSE OF SEVERAL
YEARS AS NEW AWARDS CONVERT TO
RENEWALS.
SO THAT THE COST OF FULL
IMPLEMENTATION COULD BE
SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER THAN IT IS
IN YOUR ONE IN CONTRAST
INCREASING THE SIZE OF THE AXIS
AWARD WOULD ESSENTIALLY TAKE
FULL EFFECT IN YOUR ONE THAT'S
GENERATING.
SOME LESS COST PRESSURE IN THE
OUT YEARS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
I MAKE THREE POINTS THE FIRST IS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
GENERALLY -- IS SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CONCEPT OF INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF PORTS AND THAT IS WHY
THE GOVERNOR INCLUDED AN
INCREASE AND THOSE COMPETITIVE
AWARDS IN HIS GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND MAY REVISION.
THE SECOND POINT -- IS IT IS A
REAL PRIORITY FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO FOCUS ON A TWO
GENERATION APPROACH AND BREAK
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY AND MAKING
SURE THAT BY INVESTING IN
STUDENTS WHO ARE PARENTS WE HELP
THOSE STUDENTS WERE IN SCHOOL
AND WE HELP THEIR KIDS AND SO
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
ESPECIALLY IN AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE MANY PEOPLE DO NOT
RECOGNIZE THAT ALMOST A QUARTER
OF ALL COLLEGE STUDENTS WHEN YOU
LOOK BETWEEN TWO AND FOUR YEAR
COLLEGES.
OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE ALSO
PERRANCE AND SO WE THOUGHT -- IT
WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO INCLUDE
THIS TO GENERATION APPROACH AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE PUTTING A
LOT OF RESOURCES IN A WAY THAT
CAN ACTUALLY CHANGE BEHAVIOR.
AND HELPS IN PERRANCE BREAK OUT
OF THAT CYCLE POVERTY AND CREATE
A BETTER FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR KIDS.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
THESE FAMILIES DEPENDING ON
THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR UP. TO SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN EIGHTY THREE THE
PROGRAM AND WE THINK THAT TYPE
OF RESOURCES IS REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR ACHIEVING THE GOVERNOR'S
GOALS AND WE HOPE THAT THEY WILL
BE GIVEN DUE CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MEMBERS [inaudible]
SENATOR ROBB.
WELL ONE OF THE CONSIDERATIONS
THAT.
TO ENTERED INTO THE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL HERE OUT OF BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE WAS THE
STATISTICS THAT WE WERE PROVIDED
THAT INDICATES THAT OUT OF SIXTY
TWO THOUSAND STUDENT PARENTS WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A NEW
COMPETITIVE AWARD. FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND DID NOT RECEIVE.
ONE AND SO IT OCCURRED TO US IF
WE TOOK THAT MONEY AND WE BUMPED
UP THE NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE
GRANT AWARDS WE MIGHT ACTUALLY
HAVE A MAKE A BIGGER IMPACT HAVE
HAVE.
GET MORE BANG FOR OUR BUCK SO TO
SPEAK AND AND ACTUALLY PROVIDE
MORE RESOURCES TO STUDENT
PARENTS TO ALLOW THEM.
TO DISSIPATING COMPLETE.
TO EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS.
I'LL JUST BRIEFLY COMMENT AND
THEN LET MY COLLEAGUES WEIGH IN
AS WELL I THINK IF YOU DO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE AWARDS -- YOU
CERTAINLY WOULD REACH SOME
STUDENT PARENTS AND THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES I THINK THE ISSUE IS
THAT THAT RESOURCES ONE
SPECIFICALLY BE DIRECTED AT THEM
YOU'RE HELPING A BROADER RANGE
OF PEOPLE ALL OF WHOM MAY BE
DESERVING OF HELP IN SOME WAY.
UP BUT IT DOESN'T REALLY GETS
THAT FCUS OF HELPING STUDENTS
PARENTS DIRECTLY THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM.
YEAH I WOULD I WON'T ADD MUCH
MORE BUT I WOULD JUST SAY THE
WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO STEPPED
VERSUS BREATH SO WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THE WE WENT ON A A
DEEPER VERY.
DIED TARGETED APPROACH WHERE'S
THERE'S A A BROADER APPROACH OF
SERVING MORE STUDENTS WITH THE
LOWER WORK.
BUT OF COURSE THE UNFORTUNATE
THING IS WHEN YOU'RE.
TALKING ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PLUS -- APPLICANTS FOR
A PROGRAM WHETHER IT'S GOT FORTY
THOUSAND OR THIRTY THOUSAND OR
FIFTY THOUSAND THE UNFORTUNATE
THING IS WE'RE NOT REALLY --
CURRENTLY DOING THE JOB WE NEED
TO DO.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THE AID TO
FOLKS TO GET INTO SCHOOL GET
CREDENTIAL THEY NEED AND AND GET
BACK OUT AND GET A JOB AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE THIS THING
OUT BECAUSE WE SPENT A LOT OF
MONEY AND A LOT OF TIME AND AND
ATTENTION ON CREW.
TECH EDUCATION AND JOB SKILLS
TRAINING.
WERE MOSTLY TALKING ABOUT THOSE
FOLKS.
I THINK IT'S A FAIR STATEMENT
WHO DON'T MOVE IMMEDIATELY INTO
SCHOOL FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND SO
IF THERE ARE TWO OR THREE YEARS.
THEY THEY DON'T QUALIFY FOR THE
CAL GRANT ENTITLEMENT THEY HAVE
TO COMPETE IN THE COMPETITIVE
POOL -- AND THAT'S REALLY THE
PROBLEM WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO CUT IT BUMP UP THESE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS.
TO SOMETHING MORE THAN. THIRTY
THOUSAND OR EVEN FORTY THOUSAND
OR FIFTY THOUSAND THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS WITH MCCARTY.
THANK YOU.
BEFORE I GET INTO IT THE PURPLES
LIFE I THINK ALL THREE RECOGNIZE
THAT.
LUCK TODAY COLLEGES MUCH MORE
THAN TUITION AND SO THOSE ARE
THE ISSUES IS IT'S OTHER COSTS
AND SO.
RECOGNIZE PROPOSAL -- OUT FROM
THE GOVERNOR AS WELL AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE WITH THE
SUMMER SCHOOL TO HELP STUDENTS.
GRADUATE -- WITH IN A TIMELY --
PERIOD SO THOSE ARE ALL POSITIVE
I THINK JUST TO ADD ON TO WHAT --
SENATOR A ROTH MENTIONED WE WE
FELT AS WELL THE SENATE THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY HELP MORE PARENTS
MORE STUDENT PARENTS BY.
FINDING THE AMOUNT OF COMPOUND
WORDS BECAUSE SOME OF THE
STUDENTS WHO FRANKLY APPLY IN
THE COMPETITIVE POT.
OUR PARENTS OLDER STUDENTS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS MORE
LIKELY TO BE PARENTS IN IN.
IN THE IN THE ASSEMBLY PLAN WE
ACTUALLY HAVE -- ADDITIONAL
POINTS TO TO GET TO YOUR ISSUE
FOR FINANCE. TO RECOGNIZE
COMPETITORS STUDENTS WHO ARE
PARENTS TILT TO FOCUS ON THE
PREMISE THAT YOU HAVE TO
INCORPORATE THAT.
IN THE PROPOSAL WHICH I THINK IS
WORTHY SO IT COMES DOWN TO THIS
I THINK THAT.
NOT WITHSTANDING THAT OUT YOUR
COSTS WHEN YOU DO THAT THE
RENEWALS FOR COMPETITIVE.
THAT THE THE ACCESS AWARDS WHICH
THE SENATE ONES WHICH IS I DON'T
WANT TO DIMINISH ACCENT REALLY
FOCUS ON THE NON TUITION COSTS.
IS YOU KNOW ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT BUCKS AN ADDITIONAL
WORK PER STUDENT.
VERSES GIVING ANOTHER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO DIDN'T WIN
THAT CAL GRANT LOTTERY A CHANCE
AND SO.
RIGHT NOW YOUR ODDS ARE --
REALLY LONG AND SO YOU KNOW WITH
THIS THERE WOULD GO TO ONE OF
FOUR SO.
DRAMATICALLY INCREASES THE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOMEONE TO GET
THE BIG AWARD AND FOCUS.
ON CALLS AND SO I THINK THAT'S
HOW WE SHOULD PROBABLY FRAME THE
ISSUE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS.
IT WILL BE THE ITEM OPEN MOVING
ON CAL GRANTS FOR AB FIFTY FOUR
STUDENTS ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT L.
L. [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS IS AN ASSEMBLY PRIORITY AND
IT COVERS SEVERAL ACTIONS
RELATED TO FINANCIAL AID FOR AB
FIVE FORTY STUDENTS.
AB FIVE FORTY STUDENTS INCLUDING
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WHO ATTEND
THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL OR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR AT LEAST
THREE YEARS.
ARE EXEMPT FROM NON RESIDENT
TUITION CHARGES THAT YOU SEE CSU
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE STUDENTS ARE ALSO GENERALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR STATE FINANCIAL AID
EXCEPT THEY ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
THE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING.
IN ADDITION AB FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
ARE ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
AID INCLUDING PELL GRANTS
FEDERAL LANDS IN FEDERAL WORK
STUDY.
ASSEMBLY TOOK THREE ACTIONS
RELATED TO THIS ISSUE.
FIRST TO CATER TO SERVICE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM THAT WOULD
PROVIDE A WAY TO FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER SEMESTER.
UP TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS WHO COMPLETED REQUIRED
SUBCOMMITTEE SERVICE REQUIREMENT.
ASSEMBLY SUGGESTED THIS IS
INTENDED TO REPLACE THE INCOME A
STUDENT CURRENT THROUGH THE
FEDERAL WORK STUDY PROGRAM.
SECOND THE ASSEMBLY ALSO DOCTOR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
MAKE AB FIVE FORTY STUDENTS
ELIGIBLE FOR COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT AWARDS.
AND THIRTY ASSEMBLY ADOPTED
PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
AMEND AB FIVE FORTY SO THAT
STUDENTS WHO ATTEND THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL FOR TWO
YEARS RATHER THAN THREE YEARS.
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR RESIDENT
TUITION AND STATE FINANCIAL AID.
WELL THIS LAST ELIGIBILITY
CHANGES LANGUAGE ONLY CHANGE
WHEN A THREE COULD HAVE SOME
FISCAL IMPACT RELATED TO
INCREASE STATE FINANCIALLY IT
COSTS AND FORGOTTEN ON RESIDENT
TUITION AVENUE.
THANK YOU.
GREAT SEEING ANY QUESTIONS ON
THIS.
ITEM.
WILL MAKE ONE COMMENT FROM
FINANCES -- WHICH IS THAT ON THE
ASSEMBLY IS PROPOSAL TO EXTEND --
AB FIVE FORTY ELIGIBILITY FOR
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES SUPPORT THE
ASSEMBLY IS A PROPOSAL OVER
THERE ON THE OTHER ITEMS THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT SUPPORT
THEM AT THIS TIME FOR COST
REASONS [inaudible]
NUMBER QUESTION.
I JUST WANNA DO ONE QUICK PLUG --
IN REGARDS -- TO THIS PARTICULAR
ITEM IT IS GERMANE -- BUT BUT
NOT ADDRESS HERE IN THIS BUDGET
ITEM -- THERE IS A BIT O AN
INEQUITY -- WE'VE PROVIDED
THROUGH AB FIVE FOURTEEN OTHER
PROGRAMS FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
HERE IN THE U. S. -- FOR THIRD
IN OUR HIGH SCHOOL FOR THREE
YEARS BUT WE DO NOT PROVIDE ANY
ASSISTANCE IN FACT -- IT'S A
PROBLEM GOING TO CAL STATE OR
YOU SEE FOR THOSE DOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN HERE FOR
MORE THAN THREE YEARS -- AND
THERE'S A VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF
THEM BUT I DO THINK THAT
SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE FIXED
WE PROVIDE FOR THOSE THAT ARE
UNDOCUMENTED BUT THOSE.
WHO'VE BEEN HERE THAT ARE
DOCUMENTED PARENTS CAME OVER ON
A LEGAL VISA AND WE DO NOT
PROVIDE FOR AND THEY END UP
HAVING TO PAY OUT OF STATE
TUITION SO WITH SOMETHING I
THINK WE'VE GOT A FIX IN THE
FUTURE.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ISSUE THIRTY NINE CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS [inaudible]
HELLO.
THIS ISSUE COVERS ACTIONS
RELATED TO COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS FOR CHILDREN.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME TO CREATE A NEW
INITIATIVE THAT WOULD PROVIDE
GRANTS TO LOCAL ENTITIES IN
SUPPORT OF CHILD SAVINGS ACCOUNT
PROGRAMS.
THE SENATE REJECTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT
REDIRECTED TWENTY MILLION OF THE
FUNDS TOWARD A SIMILAR EXISTING
INITIATIVE CALLED EVERY KID
COUNTS.
THE ASSEMBLY ON THE OTHER HAND
ADOPTED TWENTY FIVE MILLION OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
IT ALSO ADOPTED INITIAL TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME TO
CONTINUE STATEWIDE INITIATIVE
THAT WOULD DEPOSIT FUNDS INTO
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT. FOR
EVERY NEW BORN.
LEGISLATURE WAYS VARIOUS
APPROACHES TO EXPANDING
PARTICIPATION COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS.
WE WOULD RAISE JUST A COUPLE OF
ISSUES FOR CONSIDERATION. ONE
ISSUE HAS TO DO WITH THE
GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION OF
BENEFITS.
THE STATE'S EXISTING COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNT PROGRAM EVERY
KID COUNTS HAS ONLY BEEN OPEN
THUS FAR TO ENTITIES THAT HAVE
EXISTING CHILD SAVINGS PROGRAMS.
WHICH TEND TO BE CONCENTRATED
WITHIN CERTAIN AREAS OF THE
STATE.
IF THE LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO
FIND MORE LOCAL GRANT THAT MAY
WISH TO MAKE SOME OF THESE
GRANTS AVAILABLE TO SEE TAUGHT
SAVINGS PROGRAMS IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE. FOR THE BENEFIT
THE MORE EVENLY DISTRIBUTED.
A STATEWIDE APPROACH WOULD BY
DESIGN ADDRESS THIS CONCERN
ABOUT GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION.
THE OTHER CONSIDERATION WOULD
RATE HAS TO DO WITH TARGETING
THE FUNDS. SIX CHILDREN FROM
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES ARE
CURRENTLY LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
COLLEGE SAVINGS LEGISLATURE MAY
WISH TO TARGET CALCIUM'S
INITIATIVES TOWARD THE FIGHT
AGAINST. FOR EXAMPLE IF IT
CHOOSES TO FIND MORE LOCAL
GRANTS THAT COULD PRIORITIZE
GRANTS TO AREAS THAT SERVE
HIGHER POPULATIONS OF LOWER
INCOME STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
IF ON THE OTHER HAND IT TO THE
STATE WIDE APPROACH IN MAY WISH
TO SEND AND CONCEALING FOR
RECEIVING CERTAIN BENEFITS SUCH
AS MATCHING INCENTIVES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FINANCE TWO POINTS
FIRST THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES THAT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS THE RIGHT LEVEL --
FOR BEGINNING THIS PROGRAM AND
THE SECOND IS THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES THAT THE EMPHASIS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE LOCAL REGIONS
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE AND HOW TO DESIGN PROGRAMS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE REACHING
STUDENTS IN THOSE AREAS -- AND
IN PARTICULAR MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE NOT ONLY SERVING EXISTING
PROGRAMS BUT HELPING SEAT NEW
PROGRAMS IN AREAS OF THE START
STATE THAT AREN'T SERVED YET.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
MR MCCARTY YEAH AT NIGHT WE
OBVIOUSLY THINK THIS IS A GREAT
EFFORT RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
STUDENTS IF THEY HAVE. FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS OR FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR NAME FOR
COLLEGE YOU'RE STILL EQUALLY
MUCH MORE LIKELY TO GO TO
COLLEGE LIKE.
SEVEN EIGHT TWO ONE I WILL NOT
YOUR POINT RIGHT HERE JUST
YESTERDAY.
OUR MAYOR FORMER LEADER HERE THE
SENATE PROPOSED A BUDGET FOR THE
CITY.
WHICH HAS SEVERAL HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO AUGMENT
THEIR EVERY KID CAL'S A WORD
THAT WE THEY RECEIVED THIS YEAR
FROM OUR PREPARATION TWO YEARS
AGO AND THAT WAS THE WHOLE IDEA
IS TO SEE THESE LOCAL PROGRAMS
AND INSPIRE THEM. TO STEP IT UP.
AND SOMETHING THAT -- CERTAINLY
I'D WORK ON HERE LOCALLY WITH
OUR WITH OUR LOCALS AND SACKED
AND IN WEST SACK AND SO.
WE'RE SEEING IT COME TO FRUITION
RIGHT HERE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER MOORE Là.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT UNDERSTANDING
THIS PROGRAM ARE WE RESIST FIFTY
MILLION TO MARKET [inaudible]
AND PROMOTE [inaudible]
OR WE SIGN IN.
YOUR MARKET ACCOUNTS FOR OUR
STUDENTS IT'S PRIMARILY IN THAT
SENSE OF GRANTS DIRECTLY FIRST
THAT MONEY WOULD GO TO STUDENTS
ACCOUNTS BUT IN TERMS OF HOW
IT'S SET UP IT'S DESIGNED TO
ENCOURAGE.
MATCHING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL SO
THAT IT'S NOT SIMPLY THE STATE
FUNDING THESE ACCOUNTS BACK TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS POINT MAKING
SURE THAT DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
STEPPING UP TO HELP BEGIN THESE
PROGRAMS.
SO THEN WOOD THE STATE PUT.
SOME AMOUNT OF MONEY INTO A
STUDENTS ACCOUNT IN THE IN THE
IN THE STATE MONITORS THAT.
WHILE THEY PROGRESS TOWARDS
COLLEGE SAID THIS IS ONE TIME
FUNDING SO IT'S REALLY DESIGNED
AROUND SUPPORTING NEW PROGRAMS --
THAT ARE STARTING UP IN THESE
DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE STATE.
I JUST HAD THAT THE LANGUAGE IS
THE IS REALLY DESIGNED AROUND
TRYING TO GET AT A MINIMUM OF A
HUNDRED DOLLARS DEPOSITED INTO
THAT STREETS ACCOUNT. FOR GRANT
RECIPIENTS.
CAN HELP TO MORE RESEARCH THANK
YOU CAPTURE.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ISSUE FORTY TEACHER RECRUITMENT
AND PREPARATION ELIO.
BOTH HOUSES PROVIDE ROUGHLY
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS TEACHER SHORTAGES BUT
THE TO TAKE DIFFERENT APPROACHES.
THE MAN ACTION IN THE SENATE WAS
TO ADOPT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE LOAN REPAYMENT TO
TEACHERS.
WITH MODIFICATIONS INCLUDING ONE
THAT WOULD REQUIRE RECIPIENTS OF
THE LOAN REPAYMENT TO WORK IN
SCHOOLS FACING TEACHER SHORTAGES.
THESE ON THE OTHER HAND REJECTED
THE GOVERNOR'S LET ME PAYMENT
PROPOSAL AND INSTEAD REDIRECTED
THE FUNDS TOWARD SCHOLARSHIPS
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE AS UP
FRONT AID. TO STUDENTS PURSUING
TEACHER CREDENTIALS IN CERTAIN
SUBJECT AREAS. TO QUALIFY FOR
THE STATE STUDENTS WOULD NEED TO
COMMIT TO WORKING IN THE SUBJECT
AREAS FOR FOUR YEARS. FOR REPAIR
THEIR FUNDS.
THE MAIN DIFFERENCE IN THE TWO
HOUSES APPROACHES AS A MATTER OF
TIMING WHETHER THE AID IS
AVAILABLE TO TEACHERS WHILE
THEY'RE STILL PURSUING THEIR
CONVENTIONAL AS A SCHOLARSHIP.
OR AFTER THEY COMPLETED THEIR
CREDENTIAL.
AS THEIR COMPLETING THE WORK
REQUIREMENTS.
RAISE A COUPLE OF CONSIDERATION.
ON ONE HAND A PRINT SCHOLARSHIPS
COULD SERVICE STRONG INCENTIVES
FOR STUDENTS TO PURSUE CERTAIN
KERR POTS.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE
BECAUSE SOME STUDENTS MAY BE
AVERSE TO TAKING OUT LOANS.
ON THE OTHER HAND IT MAY BE
WORTH NOTING THAT UP FRONT
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM COULD HAVE
HIRED MINISTRY OF COSTS AS
STUDENTS WOULD RECEIVE AID
BEFORE THEY COMPLETE THE
REQUIRED WORK.
AND THE ADMINISTERING AGENCY MAY
NEED TO TRACK THE STUDENTS AS
THEY COMPLETE THE REQUIREMENTS
AND COLLECT THREE PAYMENTS FROM
THE STUDENTS IF THEY DO NOT
COMPLETE AS REQUIREMENTS.
WHETHER THE LEGISLATURE CHOOSES
TO OFFER THE STATE AS AN UP
FRONT SCHOLARSHIP OR LOAN
REPAYMENT WE KNOW THAT IT DOES
HAVE OPTIONS TO TARGET THE FUNDS
TOWARD AREAS OF GREATEST NEED.
AND ASSEMBLIES PROPOSAL FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S A REQUIREMENT
THAT PRESENTS TEACH IN CERTAIN
SUBJECT AREAS FACING CHARGES
SUCH AS SCIENCE MATH AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL AS
PREVIOUSLY NOTED AS A
REQUIREMENT THAT TEACHERS WORK
IN SCHOOLS FACING SHORTAGES.
THE LEGISLATURE MAVEN MUST
CONSIDER COMBINING THESE
CRITERIA SAID THAT THE FUNDS GO
TO TEACHERS WORKING IN SHORT
SUBJECT AREAS WITHIN HIGH NEED
SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FINANCE WILL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES.
CERTAINLY I TEMPORE FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF BOTH HOUSES
INVESTMENT IN THIS AREA -- BUT
ULTIMATELY I THINK THE ONE
IMPORTANT ASPECT FROM THE
LANGUAGE TEN POINT FOR US IS
THAT WE HAVE SOME ASPECT OF THE
EMERGENCY CREDENTIAL UP FOCUS IN
OUR SCHOOLS FOR THE WERE ALSO
TARGETING TOWARD THAT ASPECT.
I THINK WERE OPEN TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON EXACTLY
WHAT THAT LANGUAGE LOOKS LIKE
WHAT THEIR TOP FRONT WAR ON THE
BACKEND BUT CERTAINLY WE'D LIKE
THAT ONE FOCUS ON EMERGENCY
CREDENTIALS INCLUDED.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS SENATOR
SKINNER FOLLOWED BY MORE LOT.
TOM THIS THIS IS ONE OF THOSE --
I DON'T KNOW IF I'D WANT TO CALL
IT QUANDARY BUT ON THE ONE HAND.
GIVEN THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA IN TEACHER SALARIES
BEING ABLE TO PAY BACK THE LOAN
IS QUITEA BURDEN SO THE ABILITY
TO FORGIVE ALONE.
HAS THERE'S A LOT OF LOGIC TO IT
ON THE OTHER HAND.
WOULD WE BE INCENTIVIZING MORE
PEOPLE TO GET A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL WITH THE UP FRONT.
GRANT OR SCHOLARSHIP AS ASSEMBLY
STRUCTURED IT AND DO WE HAVE IS
PART OF OUR TEACHER SHORTAGE THE
FACT THAT FEWER STUDENTS MAY BE
MEN TRYING TO PURSUE A
CREDENTIAL JUST BECAUSE IF THEY
GIVEN THE COST OF THE COLLEGE
INVESTMENT TO GET THE CREDENTIAL
AND THEN THAT.
YOUR INCOME AS A TEACHER.
IT THAT THAT MAY BE ESPECIALLY
IN RIGHT NOW WITH -- OUR COST OF
LIVING IN THE LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
AND SUCH THAT MAY BE A BARRIER
TO ARE GETTING STUDENTS SO I
DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE.
IF THERE'S ANY.
EXTERNAL DATA THAT MIGHT HELP US
TO SEE WHICH WOULD WHICH OF
THESE APPROACHES WOULD.
HELP US INCREASE GIVE US THE
MOST LIKELIHOOD OF INCREASED
NUMBER OF CREDENTIALS OF
TEACHERS WHO ACTUALLY TEACHING
CALIFORNIA BUT I DON'T KNOW I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S EVEN
AVAILABLE BUT I THINK -- YOU
KNOW THAT TWO OR JUGGLING
[inaudible]
MARLA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING ON SUB ONE
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND AB. ONE
OF THE THINGS RECESSION DID WAS
CERTAINLY CLEARED A LOT OF YOUNG
TEACHERS -- AND YOU WERE MORE
SARS SORT OF HOPING WHILE I WAS
ON THAT COMMITTEE THAT WE WOULD
DO A SURVEY BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
GO BACK TO TEACHING.
SO WHY IN WHERE ARE THEY NOW ON
WHAT'S GOING ON AND HOW DO WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO COME BACK
[inaudible]
SO.
OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU'RE A
NEW TEACHER IF THERE'S A
RECESSION OR IF ENROLLMENT
LEVELS -- DECLINES THEN IS THE
NEW TEACHER THAT'S RELEASED
FIRST IT'S THE LIFE -- METHOD.
AND SO THAT.
THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF TOUGH FOR
YOUNG KIDS TO TO FACE THE WHITE
OR TAKE AN EXTRA YEAR OF
EDUCATION.
WITH THE POTENTIAL THAT I'LL BE
THE FIRST. ONE TO BE REMOVED
FROM STAFF SO [inaudible]
DOES THIS.
PROGRAM THE TEACHER SERVICE
CREDIT SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM DOES
IT HAVE LIFE FOR PROTECTION.
ANOTHER WORDS IF IF IF A STUDENT --
NOW TEACHES IN IN THE SECOND
YEAR THEY'RE LAID OFF BECAUSE OF
WHATEVER.
THAT WOULD THEY HAVE TO GET BACK
THE SCHOLARSHIP OR A PORTION OF
IT -- PROGRAM -- OR WITH WITH
WOULD THEY BE PROTECTED FROM
THAT [inaudible]
JUST.
JOINT I DON'T BELIEVE THERE ANY
SPECIFIC LIFO PROTECTIONS IN
THERE THERE ARE A WITHIN THE THE
ADMINISTRATION STRUCTURE THERE
IS A TO PEARL DEFERMENT --
PERSPECTIVE IN THE PROGRAM --
THAT'S A CARRY OVER FROM THE OLD
APPLE PROGRAM AND WHAT THAT DOES
IS IT ENABLES I BELIEVE IT'S FOR
APPROVED TEN YEAR PERIOD FOR
PORTIONS OF YOUR SCHOLARSHIP OR
IN THAT CASE LOAN FORGIVENESS.
TO BE DEFERRED FOR UP TO TEN
YEARS THERE ARE SPECIFIED
REASONS IN THE WALL WHY THOSE
DEPARTMENTS CAN OCCUR -- BUT
CERTAINLY I THINK THE MORE
IMPORTANT ASPECT THAT WERE WERE
FOCUSED ON AS WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SEVERAL THOUSAND EIGHT THINK
IT'S EIGHT THOUSAND TEACHERS ON
WAIVERS ARE PERMITS IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE
KNOW IN 201-617-5000 PERMITAN
WAIVERS WERE ISSUED IN STEM
AREAS SPECIAL EDUCATION
BILINGUAL -- TEACHING
ASSIGNMENTS -- SO CERTAINLY I
THINK WERE FOCUSED ON HOW WE CAN --
INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS USING THIS
PROGRAM IN SCHOOL SITES THAT
HAVE HIGH NUMBERS OF TEACHERS
THAT ARE ON THESE EMERGENCY
CREDENTIALS TODAY SO WE KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE A NEED.
WE KNOW THAT THEIR TEACHERS
NEEDED IN THESE AREAS AND NOW IT
IS HOW CAN WE IN SENT ADDITIONAL
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS TO BE IN
THOSE SCHOOL SITES.
YEAH AND I'M JUST TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RUG PULLED OUT FOR AND FROM
UNDERNEATH THEM BECAUSE THEY
DON'T CONTROL WHETHER THEY'RE
LATE OFFERED [inaudible]
CERTAINLY UNDERSTOOD.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY YEAH I
THINK THERE'S TWO ISSUES HERE
THE ONE AS AS MISS SKINNER SAID
THERE ARE TEACHERS WHO ARE.
STRUGGLING AND IN THE BAY AREA
AT THAT INCREDIBLE ARTICLE FEW
WEEKS AGO DOUBLE AND TRIPLING UP
WITH FEDERAL FEATHER FELLOW
TEACHERS AN APART MANNER.
LIVING WITH A GRANDMA BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD.
DESPITE THEIR LIVES AND TEACHER
SALARY WAS SO MUCH STUDENT DEBT
SO MORE IT HELPED ADDRESS THOSE
BUT ALSO DEALING WITH THE FACT
THERE'S A THOUSAND CLASSROOMS
TODAY.
PRIMARILY LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE A TEACHER THAT'S NOT
QUALIFIED REALLY.
I KNOW IT NóI ELSE TO PUT IT
AND SO YOU KNOW THE EFFORTS IS
IT A WINDFALL TO DO WE DO HAVE A
PROGRAM THAT HELPS PEOPLE THAT
ARE YOU TEACHING OR DO WE HELP.
GET PEOPLE IN THERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND SO.
WE LOOKED AT THAT THE AT THE
RESEARCH FROM THAT LPI LEARNING
POLICIES TO WHICH IS HEADED BY.
LINDA DARLING HAMMOND USE NOW OF
COURSE THE GOVERNOR'S -- BOARD
OF EDUCATION -- THAT CHIEF AND
THIS WAS THE ONE THAT WE THOUGHT
WAS THE MOST THAT PROVE IN TO
GET THE BIGGEST BANG FOR THE
BUCK AND GET TEACHERS.
IN THOSE HIGH.
HI HI I NEEDED AREA CLASSROOMS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OFTEN.
FINAL ITEM UNDER OUR EDUCATION
SECTION -- SHE FORTY ONE MENTAL.
BRIAN ANDERSON LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
UNDER -- MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR STUDENTS -- THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION.
ON GOING ON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING TO PROVIDE STERN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT THE UC
SYSTEM.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED THIS
REQUEST AND IN ADDITION PROVIDED.
FIFTEEN MILLION ON GOING IN
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME FROM THE
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUNDING. FOR
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AT THE THREE HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS.
THE SENATE REJECTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND INSTEAD
PROVIDED A TOTAL OF FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME.
OF WHICH FIVE HUNDRED AND TEN IS
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND.
AND FORTY MILLION IS FROM
PROPOSITION [inaudible] SIXTY
THREE FOR PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
I K. TWELVE EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
AND VARIOUS PUBLIC -- HIGHER
EDUCATION AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO THEIR
STUDENTS [inaudible]
RICHEST NOTE AS CONTEXT -- THE
OTHER FUNDS SOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE OBVIOUSLY STERN MENTAL
SERVICES IS A PRIORITY OF ALL.
THREE BODIES HERE -- MANY HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTES TO PROVIDE
THESE SERVICES PRIMARILY ON A
FEE FOR SERVICE BASIS WITH
STUDENTS -- FOR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS THEY ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE THESE SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES THE
STATE PROVIDES ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION ON GOING -- FOR
THOSE STUDENTS -- IN ADDITION.
MANY SCHOOLS HAVE REPORTED USING
THEIR SUPPLEMENT ON
CONCENTRATION GRANT FUNDING
UNDER L. C. F. F. TO SUPPORT
THESE SERVICES AND RECENTLY THE
STATE PROVIDED THIRTY MILLION.
IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO SUPPORT.
OF VARIOUS BEHAVIOR ON ACADEMIC
INTERVENTIONS KNOWN AS THE MULTI
TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT THESE
INCLUDE MANY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES [inaudible]
FINANCE.
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT ITS MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL IN TERMS OF
THE FUNDING FOR YOU SEE AND WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT THIS IS PART OF A
PRETTY ROBUST MENTAL HEALTH
PACKAGE IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
INCLUDING FOR TRAINING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE SENATE SPACE
SPECIFIC PROPOSAL -- WE WOULD
LOVE TO MORE AND MORE INTERESTED
IN SOME OF THE DETAILS AROUND
HOW THE SENATE IS.
ENVISIONING THIS -- BUT WE WILL
REITERATE THAT OUT RIGHT NOW
GIVEN HOW WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
GENERAL FUND AND AND PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT IN PARTICULAR -- WE
DON'T SEE THESE OTHER ITEMS
FITTING AND AS WELL AS WITH
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE WHERE
WERE PROPOSING A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN THE WORK
FORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING.
PROGRAM TO EXPAND THE MENTAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE SO WE DON'T SEE
THESE OTHER ITEMS FITTING INTO
THE BUDGET RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SENATOR ROBB FOLLOWED BY MORE
LOT.
WELL I WILL SAY THAT THE
TESTIMONY THAT WAS PRESENTED.
IN BUDGET SUB ONE WAS PRETTY
COMPELLING IN THIS AREA AND
COMPELLING BOTH OF THEM IN THE
FIRST REGARD THE STUDENTS WHO
WERE ATTENDING UC AND SEE ISSUE
IN TERMS OF WAIT TIMES FOR
APPOINTMENTS AND AND ISSUES SUCH
AS THAT BUT FRANKLY EVEN MORE
COMPELLING IN THE K.. TWO TO
TWELVE ARENA A. OF THIS YEAR.
TYSON PTA FOLKS COME TO SEE ME
IN MY OFFICE AND THEY BROUGHT
SOME STUDENTS WITH THEM IN.
A TALK TO THE PARENTS AND THEY
TALK TO ME AND THEN THEY TURNED.
TURN TO A YOUNG YOUNG MAN I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER HE WAS TWELVE
OR THIRTEEN SITTING ON THE COUCH
IN THE OFFICE IN.
THEY SAID -- YOU KNOW JOHNNY
TELL YOUR STORY AND HE SAID I
WAS AT SCHOOL ONE DAY AND I WENT
TO THE BATHROOM.
AND THERE WAS A YOUNG BOY MY AGE.
SITTING ON THE FLOOR CRYING
UNCONTROLLABLY -- I DID NOT KNOW
WHAT TO DO.
I TURNED SINCE WE DIDN'T HAVE A
SCHOOL NURSE OR COUNSELOR.
ON THE CAMPUS -- I BECAME THE
COUNSELOR. TO CALM THE YOUNG MAN
IN.
GETTING TO THE POINT WHERE HE
COULD RETURN THE CLASSROOM.
AND IN THE TEACHER COULD HELP
THEM.
HEY IT BECAME A BOTHERSOME TO ME.
WE HAVE COUNTIES WITH PROP SIXTY
THREE MONEY.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY THE LAST TIME I
CHECKED.
AT ABOUT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS SITTING IN
THE BANK.
LA PROBABLY AS CLOSE TO A
BILLION.
SO THE IDEA HERE IS TO TRY TO
JUMP START THE SYSTEM.
AND TO GET COUNTIES.
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN WORKING.
PRIMARILY WITH THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION -- TO
CREATE PARTNERSHIPS. TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH AS SINCE.
ON THESE CAMPUSES PERHAPS MAYBE
NOT FULL TIME IN ON EVERY CAMPUS
BUT HAVE SOME SYSTEM.
SO THAT STUDENTS KNOW WHO TO
TURN TO PARENTS KNOW WHO TO TURN.
TO AND TEACHERS IN CLASSROOMS
KNOW WHO TO GO. TO TO PROVIDE.
WHAT IS OBVIOUSLY SOME FAIRLY
BADLY NEEDED SERVICES? TO
STUDENTS UP TO CLEAN K. TO
TWELVE BUT IT ALSO -- COULD
IMPACT TO CC ISSUE AND AND YOU
SEE AS WELL.
THAT'S REALLY THE POINT OF THIS
SOMEBODY HAS TO START DOING
SOMETHING.
NOW SOME COUNTIES -- AND SOME
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION ARE
ACTIVELY INVOLVED ARE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN PARTICIPATING ON THE
PROP.
SIXTY THREE COMMITTEES AT THAT I
GUESS EXIST AROUND THE STATE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DIVIDE UP THIS
MONEY.
OTHERS NO PARTICIPATED ALL AND
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS DON'T
<c.blue>VEN KNOW THAT ASSET TO THEIR</c>
THE TAKEN TAP.
SO WHAT WHAT WE HAVE WE HAVE
FAILED.
THIS EDUCATION SYSTEM WHEN IT
COMES TO ROLLING OUT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AND WHEN IT BEGINS TO IMPACT.
OF TWELVE YEAR OLDS.
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES BUT THAT'S A
DISGRACE SO I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
IS.
THE PERFECT WAY TO DO THIS BUT
SOMEBODY'S GOT TO FIND SOME
MONEY.
OR GET A BIG CROWBAR TO PRY
MONEY OUT OF COUNTIES. TO FORCE
THEM TO INVEST IN SERVICES.
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
END OF SPEECH PERFECT BUT THANK
YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING TO
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU SIR
FOR SHARING THE STORY.
MISTER MOORE Là.
MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANT.
TO THANK SENATOR ROSS -- FOR
WHAT HE'S TRYING TO DO -- BUT
IT'S NICE TO SEE THE GOVERNOR
ASK FOR FIVE POINT THREE MILLION
AND THEN WE RESPOND WITH FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION --
THERE'S GOT TO BE AN AWARD IN
THERE FOR THAT [inaudible]
BUT I'M.
I AM NOT PRE MED BUT I I HAVE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME.
MEANWHILE SERVICES ACT OVER THE
LAST.
DECADE OR SO.
IN A LOT OF MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
YOU REALLY START TO REVEAL
THEMSELVES WHEN PEOPLE TURN
ABOUT TWENTY ONE SORT OF HAPPENS
IN COLLEGE AND OR SEEING A SHOW
UP A LOT EARLIER FOR A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS.
DURING THE BREAK I HAD THE
CHANCE -- TO OBSERVE A PROGRAM
IN NEWPORT BEACH WITH HOAG.
MEMORIAL PRESBYTERIAN HOSPITAL.
IT'S CALLED A SPIRE AND THEY
TAKE THE PARENTS AND THE KIDS TO
TAKE HIM OFF CAMPUS IN THEIR
TEACHING BOTH BECAUSE PARENTS
ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING?
BUT THEIR CHILD WHEN HE AND IF
THEY BASED ON A MODEL OUT OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
AND IT WAS VERY IMPRESSIVE BUT
WHAT WAS MISSING.
FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE WAS THAT
THE KIDS WOULD LEAVE THE CAMPUS
GO TO THE THE CAMPUS FOR THE
HOSPITAL.
BUT THEY WOULDN'T GET CREDIT FOR
THE COURSES.
AND SO THERE'S GOT TO BE MAYBE
WITH SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS
LOOKING FOR INNOVATION WHICH IS
WHAT'S BEEN HOLDING UP MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
EVERYTHING HAS TO BE INNOVATIVE
AND THERE'S REALLY NOTHING
INNOVATIVE ANYMORE -- IF IF WE
COULD FOCUS ON JUST DOING MORE
INTEGRATION SEVERAL THE SILOS --
WITH PROGRAMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW IF IT NEEDS
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
IT MAY JUST ALREADY BE SITTING
THERE SO IT'S NOT REALLY LIKE A
NEW REVENUE -- SOURCE BUT MAYBE
MAYBE WE NEED TO WORK WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE MAYBE WE
NEED IT BECAUSE OF BECAUSE WORK
WERE CHIPPING AWAY.
BUT WE'RE WE'RE USING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT OUT TO TO
FIND FOR LAURA'S LAW WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT.
SENATOR STEINBERG AND I DID BACK
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WITH SB FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE WHAT WORK WERE USING.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE SECTOR.
AS A AS A REVENUE SOURCE FOR
THAT NO PLACE LIKE HOME PROGRAM
TO WORK WITH CANADA DOING THINGS
RIGHT BUT IT'S ALL GOING
LEGISLATIVELY.
IT'S A MAYBE WE NEED TO LOOK AT
A A BETTER PACKAGE AND HOW WE
INTEGRATE THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT WITH EDUCATION.
SO WE IDENTIFY THINGS MORE.
EARLIER AND PROVIDE THE STAFFING
WITH ACCOUNTS ARE NOT ONLY A YOU
KNOW HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUSES BUT
BUT ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES ART.
I THINK.
THE WEEK WE COULD LOOK AT A
LITTLE MORE.
BROADLY BECAUSE WE WE HAVE
RESOURCES.
AND AND HOW DO WE USE THEM MORE
EFFECTIVELY -- AS OPPOSED TO
JUST ALWAYS BEING.
LIMITED BY A COMMITTEE THIS
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES HAS NOW
THAT'S NOT INNOVATIVE FORGET IT
IT'S LIKE WAY TO SAY WE GOT WE
GOT TO GET PAST THAT IT'S THAT.
GET IT TO WHERE IT WORKS.
AND SO THERE'S MY SPEECH THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU BOTH AND GOOD
SPEECHES THEY WERE INDEED.
THEY NEED TO BE BETTER THAN
THOSE TO MR MCCARTY SO BRING IT
YEAH I DON'T KNOW MUCH I CAN ADD
ON THE THE MERIT OF THAT I'M NOT
GOING TO ADD YOU GUYS BOTH JUST
TALK ABOUT IT WE HAD.
A COMPELLING TESTIMONY IN OUR
COMMITTEES WELL ESPECIALLY FROM
THOSE CALLS STUDENTS TALKING
ABOUT WHAT STUDENTS FACE THESE
DAYS WITH THEIR FINANCIAL
PRESSURES AND A NUMBER -- TWO
CAUSE OF DEATH FOR THOSE THIS
COHORT IS SUICIDE.
AND THE PRESIDENT EVER
UNIVERSITY HERE.
THEIR OWN SON TOOK HIS LIFE AS A
COLLEGE STUDENT SO HE'S BEEN A
LEADER IN THIS SPACE I THINK THE
ISSUE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT'S
IT'S EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING THESE
COUNTIES ARE SITTING ON THEIR
MONEY.
BUT THERE IS SOME MONEY AT THE
STATE LEVEL THAT WE OUGHT TO SET
SOME STATE PRIORITIES AND SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING AND I
APPLAUD THE SENATE'S FALLS ON
OURS IS.
IS IT YOU KNOW WE WORKED WITH
THE SAME AGAIN SOON TALK ABOUT
WHAT COULD SENSE STATE
PRIORITIES BE WITH THAT STATE
ADMIN MONEY THIS IS SITTING
THERE.
AT AND NOT LEAVE IT TO SOMEBODY
ELSE BUT THIS IS ONE WHERE WE
THINK THAT.
THAT THAT WE HEARD FROM A
STUDENT WHO SAYS SHE HAD A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS SHE WENT TO
GO SEE -- SOMEBODY AND THEY SAID
WE'LL COME BACK IN THREE WEEKS
WELL THE CRISIS IS TODAY.
NOT THREE WEEKS I HAD STOPPED
ONE OF MY LIFE I HAVE FINALS AND
AND IT'S SOMETIMES LIFE OR DEATH
AND SO ONE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
INTEGRATED INTO THE HEALTH
CENTER NOT.
HE IS NOT SOMEWHERE ELSE BECAUSE
IT'S IT'S A HEALTH ISSUE GO ON
THERE FOR YOU KNOW MIGRAINE
HEADACHE OR SOMETHING WITH YOUR
BODY IT'S A HEALTH AILMENTS A
MENTAL HEALTH SHOULDN'T.
BE SOMEWHERE SIZE SHOULD BE IN
THERE WITH THE HEALTH SERVICES
SELL IS DOT THE STIGMA ATTACHED
BUT I THINK WORK FOCUS ON IS
TRYING TO SET THESE UP.
AS A STATE PRIORITY AND SO MUCH
COMPETITION IN GENERAL FUND WE
TALKED YESTERDAY ABOUT.
ENROLLMENT IN CSU AND YOU SEE
ACCESS AND SO THIS WE THINK THAT
UNDER PROP SIXTY THREE THERE IS
A AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO FOCUS ON
SOME STATEWIDE PRIORITIES.
IN A SIDE TO BE.
ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
A GREAT TO BE IT WAS IT WAS
SENATOR NIELSEN.
TARGET POPULATION IT WILL SOME
OF THESE.
THE DATE SHOULD BE THE RE
ALIGNED.
POPULATION THOSE WHO HAVE
TRANSITIONED OUT OF CUSTODY AND
INTO THE COMMUNITY. ONE OF OUR
GREAT DEFICIENCIES IS HAVING
SOMEWHERE FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS
TO RECEIVE SOME TREATMENT OR
SOME HELP.
IS THAT PART TARGET POPULATION
GOING TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS
PROGRAM THE REAL LINE AB ONE OH
NINE REALIGNED POPULATIONS.
BUT CERTAINLY UNDER THE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL IF -- THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WERE ENROLLED AND INSTITUTE OF
HIGHER LEARNING THEY WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO TRANSITION.
TO RESOURCES AND TRANSPORTATION
AND WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT
DEPARTMENTS -- HEARING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY TO EPA TWO FOUR THREE
FIRE PROTECTION YOUR RESOURCES.
TOXIC SUBSTANCES IN CONTROL
DEPARTMENT FOOD NAG [inaudible]
CPUC TRANSPORTATION DMV.
ALL THOSE FALL WITHIN RESOURCES
AND TRANSPORTATION [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
AND WHERE [inaudible]
TRANSITIONING.
THE STAFF AND PERSONNEL WHO
FOCUS ON THESE POLICY AREAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO GET STARTED.
WITH ISSUE NUMBER ONE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA NASH NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY.
THE MARINE MAMMAL CENTER PAGE
FOUR OF THE AGENDA LA -- GOOD
MORNING RACHEL EHLERS WITH THE
LA NOW.
THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU HERE IS TWO
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME FOR THE MARINE MAMMAL
CENTER ADDED BY THE ASSEMBLY.
NEITHER THE GOVERNOR NOR THE
SENATE HAD PROPOSALS ON THIS
ISSUE.
THIS FUNDING WOULD PROVIDE
GRANTS FOR THE CENTER WHICH IS A
PRIVATE NONPROFIT AGENCY LOCATED
IN MARIN COUNTY TO RESCUE AND
REHABILITATE MARINE MAMMALS SUCH
AS SEA LIONS AND SEALS. FOR
CONTEXT THE STATE HAS PROVIDED
SIMILAR ONE TIME GRANTS IN THE
AMOUNT OF EITHER ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OR TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR EACH OF THE PAST FOUR YEARS.
THANK YOU FINANCE WE SUPPORT THE
SENATE ON THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WITH MORE LAW AND SHOULD MANAGER
JUST WONDERING WHY ONE SPECIFIC
MAMMAL CENTER WHEN WE HAVE QUITE
A FEW.
IN CALIFORNIA ALONG THE COAST AB.
I'M A NO BETTER NO WORSE KIND OF
GUY YOU SOME GONNA DO IT FOR ONE
SHOULD BE DOING IT FOR ALL --
ANY ARE SIMPLY COLLEAGUES CHOOSE
TO RESPOND OR LA -- HAVE A
PERSPECTIVE.
IF NOT WE'LL KEEP MOVING TO GET
AN ANSWER FOR YOU MISTER MOORE
Là THANK YOU.
ISSUE TO CONSERVATION GENOMICS.
ALEJO THE INFERENCE -- ISSUE
BEFORE YOU IS TEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
FOR AT CONSERVATION SONOMA
GENOMICS INITIATIVE -- WHICH WAS
ADDED BY THE ASSEMBLY THE
GOVERNOR AND SENATE DID NOT HAVE
PROPOSALS IN THIS AREA.
THE FUNDING WOULD GO TO A
COLLABORATIVE OF PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES LED BY UCLA TO
DEVELOP A DATABASE AND MAPS
DETAILING THE LOCATIONS OF
THREATENED SPECIES AND THEIR
GENETIC VARIATION.
AND ALSO TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE
EXPECTED IMPACTS OF A CHANGING
CLIMATE IN ORDER TO HELP INFORM
LAND USE DECISIONS AND
CONSERVATION ACTIONS.
THANK YOU FINANCE THE
DESTRUCTION SUPPORT SENATE ON
THIS AS WELL.
ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ON CONSERVATION GENOMICS DO NOT
MIX BECAUSE THE MORE LIVE ACTORS
MANAGER WHY WHEN WHEN WE USE CAP
AND TRADE REVENUES FOR SOMETHING
LIKE THIS.
GOOD ANSWER FOR YOU ON THAT AS
WELL SUTTER MARLATT.
MOVING ON ISSUE THREE
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
IMPLEMENTATION.
SO THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU HERE IS
A COLLECTION OF EXPENDITURES
FROM PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
WHICH WAS THE WATER AND PARKS
BOND PASSED BY VOTERS IN JUNE.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THIS BOND --
IN VARIOUS CATEGORIES AND
SPENDING FOR NINETEEN TWENTY AM
BOTH HOUSES APPROVED ALL OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS -- THAN
BOTH HOUSES ALSO EACH ADOPTED
SOME ADDITIONAL ACTIONS SO
SPECIFICALLY BOTH HOUSES ADOPTED
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRING
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION REPORT
ON HOW IT SPENDS SEVENTY MILLION
<c.blue>OLLARS THAT BOTH HOUSES</c>
APPROVED. TO IMPLEMENT VOLUNTARY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT PROJECTS
ALONG THE SACRAMENTO AND SAN
JOAQUIN RIVERS BUT BOTH HOUSES
ARE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT -- THE
LANGUAGE IS IS SIMILAR BUT
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT.
AND THEN IN ADDITION THE SENATE
ADDED FUNDING FOR THREE SPECIFIC
PROJECTS FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR TIJUANA RIVER POLLUTION
CONTROL PROJECT IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A RESTORING ALAMEDA
CREEK THAT FLOWS INTO THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY.
AND THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ARROYO SECCO
PROJECTS IN PASADENA.
THE ASSEMBLY ADDED FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR COMPETITIVE GRANTS
FOR HABITAT RESTORATION PROJECTS
THAT WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
AND TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
RELATED TO THE TIJUANA RIVER FOR
INTERNATIONAL COOPERATION
ACTIVITIES.
FINANCE.
I WILL MAKE TWO POINTS SAID IN
GENERAL THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT ITS MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL THE FIRST IS
THAT WE DO THINK IN TERMS OF THE
SPECIFIC PROJECTS THAT BOND
FUNDS SHOULD BE ALLOCATED.
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE PROCESS
AND ON THE SECOND POINT
REGARDING THAT'S ONE OF RIVER
I'LL LET MY COLLEAGUE SPEAK TO
THANK YOU.
SIR DO I GO WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE REGARDING THE TWO
ONE RIVER BASIN WATER QUALITY
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WHILE WE
SHARE LEGISLATURE'S CONCERN
REGARDING THIS ISSUE WE WANT TO
WORK ON THE ISSUE A LITTLE BIT
MORE BROADLY.
IN ADDITION THE LANGUAGE DOES
RESULT A SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURES BY INCREASING -- THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT CALIFORNIA
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE POLLUTION
ISSUES ACROSS THE BORDER -- AND
THE POLLUTION IN THE TO WONDER
BASS AND DOES REPRESENT AN
INTERNATIONAL ISSUE -- THAT IT
LIKELY DOES REQUIRE SOLUTION
DRIVEN BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAD ADMINISTRATION WILL CONTINUE
TO MONITOR THE SITUATION AND
CONTINUE TO APPLY PRESSURE
PRESSURE TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ADDRESSES ISSUES.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SENATOR NIELSEN.
IN WHAT FORM DOES THIS
ASSISTANCE.
WHAT DOES IT TAKE DO YOU DEPLOY
PERSONNEL AS THE LOCALS ARE
NEGOTIATING WITH THE AGENCY TO
STATE GOVERNMENT THESE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS DO THEY PROVIDE
RESOURCES?
OUT HOW DOES THIS WORK WHAT FORM
OF ASSISTANCE.
ARE WE PROVIDING WITH THESE
RESOURCES.
ARE YOU M..
ASKING REGARDING THE TIJUANA
RIVER SENATOR NIELSEN YES WELL
IT WOULD BE OTHERS ARE A LOT OF
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS THAT ARE.
IN PROCESS NOW.
SO IT WOULD NOT JUST BE THE
TIJUANA RIVER OKAY SO THE
SEVENTY MILLION THAT BOTH HOUSES
APPROVED AND FROM PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT AND THEN IN BOTH
HOUSES ADOPTED BUDGET BILL ARE
SPECIFICALLY AROUND VOLUNTARY
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS THAT ARE
BEING -- NEGOTIATED ON THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER AND SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER -- IN CONNECTION WITH THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD'S WATER QUALITY CONTROL
PLAN FOR THE DELTA THAT'S THAT'S
UNDER WAY TRYING -- TO
ESSENTIALLY -- UNDERTAKE HABITAT
RESTORATION PROJECTS THAT WOULD
CREATE BENEFITS FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE -- IN ORDER.
TO HELP REDUCE IT REDUCE SOME OF
THE REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS SO
THAT'S KIND OF AROUND THAT
SEVENTY MILLION IN THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE.
ON THE TIJUANA RIVER THERE ARE
ARE TWO PIECES THAT THE HOUSES
TOOK THE ASSEMBLY ADOPTED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
ALLOW -- FOR FOR EXAMPLE FOR
STATE STAFF TO GO ACROSS THE
BORDER TO WORK ON SOME ISSUES
WITHOUT.
HAVING TO GO THROUGH MORE
NOTIFICATION PROCESSES THROUGH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SOME KIND
OF FACILITATING SOME OF THAT --
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING ON THE
SENATE SIDE THERE WAS FIFTEEN
MILLION PUT IN PLACE FOR A
SPECIFIC PROJECT TO TRAIN --
ADDRESS SOME OF THE POLLUTION
THAT'S COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
THROUGH THE RIVER THOUGH THE
MONIES GO TO EXISTING AGENCIES
AND WHO ARE NEGOTIATING.
THESE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS AND
SO ON THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
YES IT WOULD GO THROUGH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
THANK. THIRTY MORE LOT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THE FOR
BILLING ARE BY AND WE'RE JUST
RELEASING. ONE BILLION -- SO IS
THERE A PLAN OR OR A SCHEDULE
FOR ISSUANCE OVER.
WHAT TIME PERIOD SO IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THE CURRENT YEAR WERE
THERE WAS ONE POINT THREE
BILLION THAT WAS APPROPRIATED BY
THE LEGISLATURE THAN FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY IT'S A DIFFERENT
IT'S AN ADDITIONAL BILLION SO
IT'S A ABOUT HALF ALREADY IN
THESE FIRST TWO YEARS AND THEN --
USUALLY WHAT HAPPENS WITH BONDS
IT WOULD TAKE A LITTLE WHILE FOR
THAT TO PERCOLATE DOWN AND THEN --
THERE WILL BE FUTURE
APPROPRIATION REQUESTS THAT COME
BEFORE YOU IN FUTURE YEARS.
AND THE FIFTEEN POINT FIVE NEW
POSITIONS -- WILL THOSE BE PAID
OUT OF BOND PROCEEDS YES AND
THERE WERE QUITE A FEW MAYBE
AROUND FIFTY I WANT TO SAY THAT
WERE IN THE CURRENT YEAR AS WELL
SO THIS FIFTEEN ARE IN ADDITION
TO THAT THE THEY HELP IMPLEMENT
THE PROGRAMS AT THE DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES AND ARE.
PAID BY BOND.
IN THE MISTER THIS ONE OF FUND --
IT SEEMED OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS THAT GOVERNOR BROWN WAS
RELUCTANT TO ISSUE.
IN BONDS FOR THE SCHOOL BUILDING
PROGRAM.
BASED ON YOU KNOW WHAT COULD WE
AFFORD TO PAY OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND BECAUSE MR FRIENDS GONNA BE
SQUEEZE BY THESE PRINCIPAL
INTEREST PAYMENTS.
AT IS THAT A CONCERN OF YOURS
REGIS COME AT GO WITH IT AS IT
AS IT AS IT'S DICTATED.
SO I THINK FOR THIS BOND IT'S
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS SO YOU KNOW WE WILL WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN TERMS OF
HOW THE MONEY WILL ACTUALLY BE
SPENT IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
BOND.
WHEN IT COMES MORE BROADLY TO
EDUCATION BOND FUNDING WE KNOW
THAT'S A LARGER CONVERSATION
THAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN IN THE
UPCOMING MONTHS?
AND OBVIOUSLY FOR THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WE ARE BALANCING
THE TRADE OFF BETWEEN THE NEED
FOR CAPITAL EXPENDITURES FOR OUR
SCHOOLS AND THE FACT THAT IF
THERE ARE MORE BONDS TO YOUR
POINT.
THERE IS MORE PRESSURE ON THE
GENERAL FUND SO THE GOVERNOR IS
CONSCIOUS OF THAT TRADE OFF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE LET'S TRANSITION.
THE ISSUE.
FOR THERE IS TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS ARE WITHIN CAL EPA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL.
ROSS BROWN WITH THE LA -- SO
THIS ITEM HAS TWO DIFFERENT
PIECES ALL COVER THE FIRST AND
THEN TURN OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
TO SUMMARIZE THE SECOND.
FIRST PIECE IS RELATED TO THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED ROUGHLY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO EXTEND FUNDING FOR
TWENTY TWO POSITIONS FOR THREE
YEARS -- THAT WERE APPROVED A
COUPLE YEARS AGO IN THE BUDGET --
THE POSITIONS AND POINT EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN WHICH IS A PROGRAM
FOCUSED ON REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION IN HEAVILY POLLUTED
COMMUNITIES.
THE SENATE REJECTED THE
EXTENSION OF THE FUNDING THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED THE FUNDING
FOR TWO YEARS INSTEAD OF THREE
ON THIS ISSUE WE DO RECOMMEND
THAT THE THE ASSEMBLY VERSION
BECAUSE WE DO THINK THE WORKLOAD
JUSTIFIES THE EXTENSION OF THE
POSITIONS FOR TWO YEARS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JOHN MARTIN AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- THE SENATE
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST
FOR SEVENTY SEVEN AND FORTY NINE
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND AND THE-SHIFT TO FIND ILLEGAL DRUG LAB
CLEANUPS FROM THE GENERAL FUND
INSTEAD OF FROM THE ILLEGAL DRUG
LAB CLEANUP ACCOUNT.
THE ASSEMBLY REJECTED THE
REQUEST WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
MAY BE A COMPROMISE BEING WORKED
OUT -- THAT WOULD APPROPRIATE
SAID THAT FINDING TO THE ILLEGAL
DRUG LAB CLEANUP ACCOUNT THAT
WOULD FACILITATE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT BECAUSE YOU WOULD BE
ABLE TO BETTER TRACK THE AMOUNT
OF SPENDING.
ON THESE ACTIVITIES [inaudible]
FINANCE.
ON THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD -- WE
SUPPORT -- THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL
AND WE ARE COMFORTABLE WITH THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT IN LANGUAGE
THAT DAY PROPOSED.
AND ON THE ILLEGAL DRUG CLASS
LAB CLEAN UP ISSUE -- WE SUPPORT
THE SENATE PROPOSAL THANK YOU
QUESTION SENATOR NELSON.
CHARACTERIZE THAT SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORT LANGUAGE WE'VE NOT SEEN
IT WHAT IS IT GONNA SO THAT IS
FROM THE ASSEMBLY SO I SHOULD
TURN THAT OVER TO THE LA -- THE
THE THE GENERAL JUST IS JUST TO
GET MORE MAKES OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MORE INFORMATION
ON KIND OF THE ON GOING WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE ACTIVITIES
OTHER POSITIONS ARE APPROVED ON
A LIMITED TERM BASIS AND SO.
THIS IS A RELATIVELY NEW PROGRAM
AND SO THE THE LANGUAGE IS SORT
OF INTENDED TO MAKE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GOOD INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT THE OUTCOMES OF THE
PROGRAM HAVE BEEN AND WHAT THE
ON GOING WORKLOAD WOULD BE.
ELDERS A VERY IMPORTANT POINTS
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIVE
REAPPROPRIATION FOR DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL.
THE ASSEMBLY RE APPROPRIATED
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
TO PROVIDE LOCAL ASSISTANCE
GRANTS TO RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICTS.
OF FIVE MILLION FOR THE WINNER
RISE HABITAT INCENTIVE FUND AND
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO EXTEND
THE ENCUMBRANCE PERIOD TWO THREE
YEARS.
AND THEN TWO MILLION GENERAL
FUND FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL TO PROVIDE A
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANT TO THE
LEVINE AND WEBER SCHOOL SITE --
WE VIEW THESE THREE
APPROPRIATIONS IS TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT STATE TO FULLY EXPEND
FUNDS FOR THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSES.
FINANCE WHILE THE ADMINISTRATION
DID NOT PROPOSE THESE RE
PREPARATIONS WE ARE COMFORTABLE
WITH THEM IN SUPPORT THE
ASSEMBLY APPROACH GREAT
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OUT COLLEAGUES WE'RE PREPARE TO
ACTUALLY TAKE ACTION ON THIS
ITEM.
ON THE RECOMMENDATION IS THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION.
ARE THEY SHE FIVE THE THE AYE.
CAPTION.
IS THE RESERVATION I SEE SOME.
ON OUR SIDE [inaudible]
OKAY GREAT.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
WHAT THE THING ON ONE SECOND
PLEASE [inaudible]
HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT LET'S NOT TAKE
ACTION ON THIS LET ME WE STILL
HAVE SOME ISSUES WE NEED TO
REVIEW.
HELP CENTER NIELSEN.
HOW ABOUT IF WE OF VOTE ON EACH
OF THE ITEMS ON TO THE ASSEMBLY --
RECOMMENDATIONS SEPARATELY ITEMS
ONE TWO AND THREE WOULD THAT
WORK FOR YOU AND THEN WE CAN
TAKE ACTION NOW.
IS THAT OKAY.
SALT.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION -- THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER -- THAT WILL
TAKE.
THE FIRST SECTION THREE
APPROPRIATION THE REMAINING
BALANCE OF APPROXIMATELY.
TWO THIRTY THOUSAND WITH A VOTE
OF FIVE OH ON THE ASSEMBLY AND
FIVE ZERO ON THE SENATE WILL
MORE.
IT'S A SIMPLE.
ITEM TO THE REPURPOSE IN THE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
GENERAL FUND FOR THE WINTER RICE
HABITAT INCENTIVE PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THE MOTION.
SKINNER GAVE ME THE MOTION THE
ASSEMBLY I HAVE. FOUR FOUR ONE
FOUR ONE ON THE ASSEMBLY.
ANNIE OKAY WITH THIS AND AND AND
FOR ALL ON THE SENATE.
ON ITEM THREE THE
REAPPROPRIATION OF TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR THE D. T. S. C..
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE IT'S FIVE
OH ON THE SENATE SIDE.
YES [inaudible] FOR ONE THANK
YOU IF WE DID ONE HOW ABOUT THAT
EUREKA.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX ENHANCED FIRE
PROTECTION.
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF FIVE
THREE IN FIRE PROTECTION
[inaudible]
LA -- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST
COMPUTERS WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M SO THIS BY
PROPOSAL HAS A COUPLE OF
PROPOSALS IN AND THERE'S A
COUPLE A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES THAT ARE A CONFERENCE.
SO IN JANUARY THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED AT NINETY FIVE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS MOSTLY FROM
THE GENERAL FUND.
FOR MULTIPLE DIFFERENT THINGS
FOR CAL FIRE TO ENHANCE FIRE
RECITE RESPONSE AND SUPPRESSION --
SUCH AS FIRE ENGINES ADDITIONAL
STAFF SEEN.
A C. ONE THIRTY AIR TANKER
PROGRAM -- AS WELL AS THE HEALTH
AND WELLNESS PROGRAM AND OTHER
ITEMS.
IN A MAY THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED A
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN BUDGET
YOUR PLUS ONE AND TWO POINT TWO
MILLION AND THE FOLLOWING YEAR
AFTER THAT. FOUR EIGHT EXCLUSIVE
USE CONTRACT FOR A C. -- ONE
THIRTY TANKER AND THIS PROPOSAL
IS REALLY TO BE PAIRED WITH THAT
THE C. ONE THIRTY PROGRAM THAT
WAS PROPOSED.
IN JANUARY ARE THE CONTRACT SEE --
ONE THIRTY TANKER WOULD BE USED
ON BOTH TO FIGHT FIRES IN THE
UPCOMING FIRE SEASON AND OVER
THE COURSE OF THE YEARS OF THE
CONTRACT.
AS WELL AS PROVIDE EIGHTY AND
ACCESS TO AC ONE THIRTY PLAN IN
ORDER TO TRAIN THE PILOTS THAT
WOULD BE UNDER CONTRACT WITH CAL
FIRE -- TO TO FLY THE END.
THE C. ONE THIRTY PLANES THAT
THAT THAT CAL FIRE IS PROPOSING
TO RECEIVE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND SEEKING FUNDING.
FOR ON THE U. S. SENATE APPROVED
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- MOSTLY AS
IS WE'RE PRETTY MUCH ALL AS IS
FOUND BUT THEN ADDED ON BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRING SOME
REPORTING ON THE HEALTH AND
WELLNESS PROGRAM.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED MOST OF
THE PROPOSAL BUT REJECTED AT THE
C. -- ONE THIRTY TANKER PIECE OF
THE PROPOSAL.
I WHICH IS THIRTEEN POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE INITIAL
YEAR OF OPERATIONS TIME.
TO BEGIN STAFFING UP IN TRAINING
CREWS A FOR IT -- THE RECEIPT OF
THE C. ONE THIRTY AIR TANKERS
WHICH ARE KEVIN IF YOU TO YEAR.
AS WELL AS TO START SOME CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS TO CONSTRUCT
BERWICK'S FOR AND THAT ON LARGER
FLIGHT CREWS THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED.
ON THE ASSEMBLY ALSO REJECTED
THE ASSOCIATED MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL FOR EIGHT AND EXCLUSIVE
USE CONTRACT FOR AS HE WENT
THIRTY OR TANK TANKER.
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS -- AND
THEN LASTLY THE ASSEMBLY ADDED
TO SOME BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE --
FOR AROUND -- DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTIONS AND REQUIRING THAT
SOME OF THE NEW POSITIONS BE
ENROLLED IN A BURN THE BURN BOSS
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
THIS BEING -- ESTABLISHED THAT
WAS SET IN PLACE BY THE WILD FOR
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE FROM LAST
YEAR ON THIS REALLY JUST INSURES
THAT -- STAFF THERE WILL.
AND BE GETTING TRAINED ON THE
PROPER WAY TO DO A PRESCRIBED
FIRE.
SO THE ISSUES THAT ARE IN
CONFERENCE ARE PRIMARILY THAT
THE C. ONE THIRTY PROGRAM THE
JANUARY PEACE AS WELL AS THAT
MAKE PROPOSAL.
AND ON THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
FROM BOTH HOUSES IS ALSO IN
CONFERENCE.
SO DURING THE COURSE OF THE
BUDGET CYCLE THERE WERE SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF DIFFERENT
METHODS OF FIGHTING FIRES -- IN
PARTICULAR IN THE C. ONE
THIRTIES THERE WAS SOME MEDIA
REPORTS ABOUT.
ON THE LARGE AIR TANKERS MAYBE
NOT BEING THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO FIGHT FIRES
BECAUSE IN THE INSTANCES WHERE
THERE REALLY NEEDED THESE VERY
LARGE CATASTROPHIC FIRES.
THEY CAN OFTEN BE GROUNDED
BECAUSE THE WEATHER CONDITIONS
WILL ALLOW THEM TO FLY THE WINDS
MIGHT BE.
TO GUSTY OR THE SMOKE MIGHT AND
PREVENT THEM FROM FLYING.
I'M OUR OFFICE HAD ALSO RAISED
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT JUST A
GENERAL LACK OF INFORMATION ON
THE AND OVERALL.
ASSESSMENT OF WHICH APPROACHES
TO FIGHTING FIRES ARE MORE COST
EFFECTIVE -- AND SO WE'D
ACTUALLY RECOMMENDED AND IT'S
NOT PART OF THIS ITEM IS PART OF
YOUR S. ARE A LEGEND OF THAT
YOU'LL GET TO LEADER.
BUT WE HAD RECOMMENDED I'M DOING
AN ASSESSMENT -- OF HAVING HOW
FAR REALLY LOOK AT WHAT ARE THE
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW CAUGHT MORE
COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH AS THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION OF THE S. R. O.
BUDGET -- INCLUDE SAID
ASSESSMENT SO WE THINK IF YOU DO
WANT TO HAVE THAT ASSESSMENT
DONE IF YOU DO DECIDE TO GO
FORWARD THAT -- A POTENTIAL
COMPROMISE HERE -- IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN THAT WOULD BE TO
MAYBE DO ONE YEAR OF FUNDING FOR
THE C. ONE THIRTY PROGRAMS AT
LEAST FOR CERTAIN PIECES OF IT --
IN PARTICULAR PROVIDING THAT
EXCLUSIVE USE CONTRACT CLEAN FOR
A YEAR COULD HELP INFORMING
ASSESSMENT OF HOW FREQUENTLY IT
WAS USED -- WERE THERE INSTANCES
WHERE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN DESIRE
TO BE USED BUT ENDED UP BEING
GROUNDED HOW BECAUSE OF WEATHER.
AND AND SO THAT COULD BE ONE
POTENTIAL COMPROMISE BETWEEN THE
TWO HOUSES -- IF YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THE ASSESSMENT
PROVIDING WHEN YOU'RE MAYBE
DOESN'T HELP THAT MUCH I AM.
BY IF YOU ARE I'M INTERESTED IN
MORE INFORMATION THAN THAT AND
THAT WHEN YOU'RE WOULD BE
HELPFUL.
THANK YOU FINANCE PLEASE MAKE
THREE BRIEF POINTS FIRST IS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT MEASURES
AS PART OF ITS PACKAGE FOR
FIGHTING WILDFIRES.
BUT THE C. ONE THIRTIES ARE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT AT THESE --
TANKERS ARE BEING TRANSFERRED
AND RETROFITTED AT NO COST TO
THE STATE SO ALL THESE ARE
OPERATIONAL COSTS AND WE THINK
WE REALLY NEED TO START OUR IN
THE BUDGET YEAR TO GET THESE UP
AND RUNNING AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE WE KNOW GIVEN WHAT WE
SAW LAST YEAR THAT.
WE HAVE TO BE PREPARED FOR
WHATEVER COMES -- AND SO THE
SECOND POINT IS WE DO SUPPORT
THE SENATE ACTION ON THIS
PROPOSAL AND WE ARE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE SENATE SO -- LANGUAGE
REGARDING HEALTH AND WLLNESS
REPORTING -- AND THIRD -- FOR
THAT LANGUAGE -- FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WE BELIEVE THAT REDUCES
FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF PUTTING
RESOURCES IN THE HIGHEST NEED
AREAS OF THE STATE IN TERMS OF
MOST WILD FIRE RESCUE -- SO FOR
THAT REASON WE SUPPORT THE
SENATE PROPOSAL ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH.
WELL I ASSUME -- THIS EFFORT IS.
AN EFFORT TO MODERNIZE YEAR
FLEET.
WITH THE ACQUISITION OF THE UC
ONE THIRTIES IS THAT IS THAT THE
PROGRAM.
THAT'S CORRECT YES.
WHEN THE AIRFORCE RESERVE IN THE
AIR NATIONAL GUARD BOWS FLY SEE
ONE THIRTIES AND?
BOTH HAVE A FIRE FIGHTING
MISSION.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA I THINK THE
AIRFORCE RESERVIST ON COLORADO
SPRINGS COLORADO.
A MY RECOLLECTION I WOULD NOT ON
THIS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE SO I
DIDN'T HEAR THE DISCUSSION.
IS OUR CALIFORNIA AIR FLEET IS
AGING IS THAT NOT CORRECT.
AND THE PROP.
BENSON BERMAN FINE IT'S
ABSOLUTELY YES IT IS AND THE
PROBLEM WITH AN AGING.
FLEET OF FLYING A FIRE FIGHTING
MISSION IS THE STRESS ON THE AIR
FRAME IS PRETTY SIGNIFICANT WHEN
YOU'RE DOING WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO TO DROP THE
RETARDANT.
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE?
AND THE RISK IS THE WING SNAP
OFF.
AND THEY DON'T PLAY VERY WELL
WITHOUT WINGS.
SO I'M A LITTLE.
PERPLEXED BY THE DECISION NOT TO
PROCEED WITH THIS.
C. ONE THIRTY PROGRAM.
UNLESS WE'RE GETTING OUT OF THE
AIR TANKER BUSINESS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO JUST PUT
BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND HAVE
HELICOPTERS WITH BUCKETS
[inaudible]
CAN [inaudible]
ANYBODY [inaudible]
ENLIGHTEN ME.
PROBABLY NOT LET ME GO TO CENTER
NIELSEN AND THEN BACK TO MR TING
CENTER NIELSEN.
WE CAN'T JUST BLITHELY SAY THAT.
THE FIXED WING AIRCRAFT ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR THE TIMES THEY
ARE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL FOR THE
TIMES.
AND HAVING BEEN VERY CLOSE TO
THIS FOR LITERALLY DECADES THE
FLEET IS IN TROUBLE.
AND WE DO NEED.
TO AND THESE PLANES ARE COMING
AT LITTLE COST BUT WE DO HAVE TO
HAVE.
THE THE BEEFING UP OF THE FLEET
MEETING THE RESILIENCE QUALITY.
THE SAFETY.
AND WE DEFINITELY NEED THE
TRAINING.
I DON'T MIND SOME LANGUAGE HERE
BUT THIS IS REALLY CRITICAL TO
OUR ABILITIES TO RESPOND.
THERE ARE MOMENTARY
CIRCUMSTANCES WE SAW ON THIS
JUST THE LAST YEAR WE'RE BECAUSE
OF SMOKE.
SOME OF THOSE FIXED WINGS COULD
NOT BE DEPLOYED.
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE THEM
AVAILABLE.
AND NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH
BECAUSE THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
FIRES THAT WE'RE NOW DEALING
WITH SO I WOULD WANT TO MOVE THE
SENATE VERSION.
THANK YOU I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THAT THE AIR FLEET IS AGING AND
THAT WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE C. ONE FIFTIES THAT WE ARE
RECEIVING IS THAT THEY'RE ABOUT
FIFTY YEARS OLD IS THAT.
CORRECT YOU KNOW THE AGE OF THE
AIRCRAFT.
I DON'T KNOW THE ACTUAL AGE OF
THE ALL OF THE AIRCRAFT I THINK
SOME OF THEM MAY BE DIFFERENT IN
AGE THEIR SEVEN OF THEM IN TOTAL
I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY WERE ALL
WHAT'S THE RANGE OF THE AGE.
I'M NOT SURE OF TIME AND I CAN
GET THAT INFORMATION A FIVE
YEARS OLD TEN YEARS OLD I MEAN.
I I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER AGAIN
ART ARE UNDERSTANDING THE
PRESENTATION SUBCOMMITTEE THAT
THEY WERE FIFTY YEARS OLD BUT
WHAT'S THE LIFE EXPECTANCY OF
THE STARCRAFT OF THESE AIRCRAFT.
I DON'T KNOW THE LIFE EXPECTANCY
I KNOW THAT.
A NUMBER OF THE AIRCRAFT WERE
ALREADY USING ARE KIND OF
SIMILAR I KNOW THAT THE AIRFORCE
IS DOING.
RETROFITS -- TO THESE AIRCRAFT
SO THAT HELPS -- WITH THE WITH
LIFE EXPECTANCY WE CAN GET THOSE
AT THAT INFORMATION FOR YOU.
AND UNDERSTOOD SIZE SO I THINK
ARE ARE CONCERNED FROM.
OUR HOUSE WAS WE TOTALLY AGREE
THAT WE NEED TO AFRAID TO SLEEP --
THE QUESTION WAS IS THE FOR
BRINGING AIR AIRCRAFT THAT'S AS
OLD AS OUR OLD FLEET WHETHER
THAT WAS ACTUALLY AN UPGRADE IN.
WITH THAT WAS REALLY THE MOST
APPROPRIATE USE OF MONEY --
TOTALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
WE'RE GETTING THIS FOR FREE.
I THINK WE WANTED TO STEP BACK
FOR A SECOND AND ASK THE THE
BIGGER QUESTION WHICH IS.
IS THIS REALLY -- ABOUT RATHER
THAN SPENDING THE MONEY TO
OPERATE.
OLD PLANES SHOULD WE ACTUALLY BE
TAKING MONEY GOING TO BUY NEW
PLANES WHICH I KNOW WOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE.
COSTLIER BUT IN THE LONG RUN MAY
BE THE BETTER FINANCIAL DECISION.
SO I THINK THAT WAS OUR CONCERN
THAT WE WERE INHERITING FIFTY
YEAR OLD PLANTS.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU I'M SURE I COULD
PROBABLY SAID SHED SOME LIGHT ON
THIS -- CRAFTER LIKE HOUSES
THEY'RE NOT LIKE CARS SO IF YOU
TOTALLY REFURBISHED AIRCRAFT YOU
CAN REALLY MAKE IT.
LIKE A NEW AIRCRAFT AND THAT'S
OFTEN THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
SOLUTION IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE
AIRFORCE IS DOING ON ITS LARGE
BOMBERS.
THEY'RE REFURBISHING BE FIFTY
TWOS THAT ARE FIFTY YEARS OLD --
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THAT'S THE
MOST COST OF WHAT EFFECTIVE WAY
OF MEETING THAT MISSION SO IF
I'M SURE THAT THEY HAVE CRUNCH
THE NUMBERS AND IF THEY'RE
SATISFIED WITH THAT DECISION I'M
HIGHLY CONFIDENT THAT THE C. ONE
THIRTIES CAN BE.
RETURNED TO A CONDITION THAT'S
GOING TO SERVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR MANY YEARS -- I
DO SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF
THE ASSEMBLY ABOUT.
WHETHER OR NOT A LARGE FLEET OF
C. ONE THIRTIES IS GOING TO HELP
US IN OUR FIRE FIGHTING MISSION
BUT I THINK IT'S DEFINITELY THE
DIRECTION WE NEED TO MOVE AND SO --
I WOULD SUPPORT.
EITHER THE SENATE'S PROPOSAL OR
AT THE VERY LEAST THE LA --
COMPROMISE THAT WOULD GIVE US
SOME FUNDING TO GET THAT PROGRAM
RULING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY OTHER US
INTO NIELSEN WELL I WOULD I'D
LIKE TO ADD THAT.
ALL THE EGGS ARE NOT IN THE C.
ONE FORTY BASKET.
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WE'VE.
EMBARKED ON SOME HELICOPTERS.
TO A GREAT CAPACITY.
THEY ARE YOU THEY HAVE A UTILITY
AND DIFFERENT AREAS AND SOME
PLACES WHERE THESE FIXED WING
CANNOT OPERATE.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT CAL FIRE IN
ITS ENTIRETY IT RELATES TO THE
IN.
ALL OF THE EQUIPMENT THAT THEY
USE THE GROUND EQUIPMENT THE
ENGINES.
THE SUPPORT EQUIPMENT ON THE
GROUND AND OF COURSE THE YEAR AS
WELL.
AND THIS THIS IS A A GOOD STEP
IN A IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
I WOULD ARGUE VERY VOCIFEROUSLY
AT AT A VERY CRITICAL TIMING
MOMENT BECAUSE THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE FIRES WERE NOW AFTER HAVING
TO FACE.
CENTER OFF.
I WILL ALSO IN A MEANS OF THE
FACT THAT THE THE AIR FORCE
STILL USES THE C. ONE THIRTY
PLATFORM FOR THE FIRE FIGHTING
MISSION IN VARIOUS.
VERSIONS -- INDICATES TO ME THAT
IT MUST BE A FAIRLY EFFECTIVE
PLATFORM TO DELIVER.
A FIRE RETARDANT AND IS PROBABLY
SOME ADVANTAGE TO HAVE A A
SYSTEM THAT'S COMPATIBLE WITH
THE THE MILITARY WHEN WE DO CALL
THE MILITARY IN TO HELP --
SOMEWHAT COMPATIBLE ANYWAY --
IT'S PROBABLY AN ADVANTAGE THERE
AND I WILL ALSO NOTE THAT --
WHEN I WAS -- IN THE SERVICE.
THERE WAS A OF THE C. ONE THIRTY
PLATFORM AND IT'S VARIATIONS IN
THEIR MANY OF THEM WAS PART OF A
FAIRLY RIGOROUS -- A PROGRAM TO
A TO RE HAVE BEEN AND INSURE
THAT THE WING STRUCTURE THE BOX
STRUCTURE -- WAS WAS SUITABLE
FOR MILITARY TACTICAL AIRLIFT
OPERATIONS WHICH ARE THE THE
MOST US PASSED ONE OF THE MOST
STRESSFUL OPERATIONS THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR IN OUR AIR FORCE
FLEET.
AND MOST OF THE AIRFORCE
AIRPLANES UNFORTUNATELY ARE OVER
FIFTY YEARS OLD SO I I WOULDN'T
I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE ASSEMBLY I WOULDN'T WORRY
ABOUT THESE PLANS.
FINANCE YOUR BIGGEST AT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S AERIAL PROGRAM I
MEAN THE REASON THE S. TO
SURROUND AND WORKING AS WELL AS
THEY ARE NOW IS BECAUSE THAT
PROGRAM.
INCLUDES PERIODIC BY BRINGING
THE PLANES OUT OF SERVICE AND
SENSUALLY STRIPPING THEM DOWN
AND REBUILDING THEM AND SO
THAT'S HOW THEY MAINTAIN THESE
WHAT FOR SONGS AND THAT IS PART
OF THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE SEEN NONE WILL HOLD
THE SADDAM OPEN.
ISSUE SEVEN PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS PROGRAM CONTINUATION
UNDER CAL FIRE.
BY THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS O GOING IN IT
TO CONTINUE -- THE PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS YEAH PROGRAM AT CAL
FIRE THIS PROVIDES I'M TRAINING
MANAGEMENT TRAINING AND AND
OTHER PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
TO ALL CAL FIRE PLEASE.
THE PROPOSED MAKES A FUNDING --
IS WHAT'S IN QUESTION HEARING
CONFERENCE THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE GENERAL FUND A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FIND.
AND THEN ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN REIMBURSEMENTS -- THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED THE THE
PROPOSAL AS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR WITHOUT MIX OF FUNDING
AND THE SENATE APPROVED THE
TOTAL FOR A MILLION BUT WITH A
DIFFERENT MIX OFFUNDING
BASICALLY TAKING OUT THAT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND FROM GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FIND.
AND INSTEAD INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUND SO THE
ISSUE ON CONFERENCE FOR YOU IS
THAT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND IN GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FIND OR HAVING THAT
FUNDING COME FROM TURN OFF AND
THANK YOU FINANCE.
A WE SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL AND WE THINK IT MAKES
SENSE GIVEN THAT SOME OF THESE
EMPLOYEES ACTIVITIES ARE
SUPPORTED BY G. R. F. --
PROPORTIONAL.
SHARE IS APPROPRIATE HERE.
EXCELLENT QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE NUMBER GOING TO HOLD THE
SADDAM OFTEN.
ISSUE A WILDFIRE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE ADJUSTMENT CALIFORNIA LA
JOH.
SO IN THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED IN
THE SPRING TIME. EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FIND AND TWO POSITIONS
FOR CALIFORNIA A POOR IN THE
REVIEW AT A WILD FIRE MITIGATION
PLAN SO CAL FIRE IS WORKING WITH
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
AND PROVIDING TECHNICAL SUPPORT
ASSISTANCE.
ON AND ASSISTING IN THE REVIEW
OF THOSE WELFARE MITIGATION
PLANS THAT ARE SUBMITTED BY
UTILITIES.
I'M GIVEN THAT THESE PLANS ARE
MUCH MORE ROBUST UNDER SB I KNOW
WHEN I'M ADDITIONAL STAFF WAS --
REQUESTED.
THE SENATE APPROVED GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AS PROPOSED THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BUT LIMITED TO A TWO
YEAR TERM.
THANK YOU FINANCE SO WE ARE --
ALTHOUGH THE SENATE WE ARE IN
CONCURRENCE WITH THE SENATE WE
ARE ACTUALLY COMFORTABLE WITH
THE ACTIONS OF EITHER HOUSE IN
THIS CASE.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THREE NINE HOLE THAT I'VE ITEM
OPEN.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE.
NINE HELLO -- OFFICE OF THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL FIRE AND LIFE
SAFETY UNDER CAL FIRE ELIA.
SO THIS PROPOSAL CAME OUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MISSION BASED
REVIEW OF THE OFFICE OF THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL ON AND AN
ADDRESS I AM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS WORKED WITH THE
OFFICE I'M GOING THROUGH SORT OF
PROGRAM BY PROGRAM.
THE COMPLETED A PORTION OF THE
MISSION BASED REVIEW FOR THAT
FIRE AND LIFE SAFETY DIVISION
AND THEN MADE THIS PROPOSAL TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO THAT
DIVISION OUT BASED ON THE REVIEW --
WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED
WAYS AND ONE POINT SIX MILLION
IN FUNDING?
IN THE AND BUDGET YEAR AND A ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION IN FUNDING ON
GOING AND EIGHT POSITIONS -- TO
HANDLE INCREASED WORKLOAD I'M
SOMEONE TIME FUNDING -- FOR AN
ANALYSIS AT THE FEE STRUCTURE OF
HOW ARE THE FOR MARTIAL CHARGES
FEES.
AND AND THEN TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- TO CLARIFY THE
INSTANCES WHERE THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
CONDUCTING CERTAIN INSPECTIONS --
AS WELL AS VARIOUS TECHNICAL
CHANGE AS ARE THE ASSEMBLY
APPROVED THE PROPOSAL AS
PROPOSED ON AND THE SENATE
REJECTED THE PROPOSAL.
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE REASON
WHY IT WAS REJECTED WAS JUST
BECAUSE THE MISSION BASED REVIEW
IS ON GOING IN AND SO ON THE
LEGISLATURE HASN'T HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THE FULL AND
COMPLETE.
PICTURE OF THE FINDINGS FROM
THAT MISSION BASED RUBIO.
I'M IN THIS CASE BECAUSE OF THAT
COMPONENT OF THE MISSION BASED
REVIEW -- RELATED TO THIS
DIVISION HAS BEEN COMPLETED --
AND THE PROPOSAL DID SEEM TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD
ANECDOTALLY OVER THE YEARS -- WE
THINK THAT AND APPROVING THE
PROPOSAL I'M GOING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION AND CAN CAN
MAKE SENSE -- IF THEY'RE STILL
ONGOING CONCERNS ABOUT WANTING
MORE INFORMATION BACK ON THE
RESULTS OF THE MISSION BASED
REVIEW OR HOW IT FITS IN WITH
THE OTHER COMPONENTS OF THAT.
ON THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALWAYS
AB REQUIRE ADDITIONAL --
REPORTING BACK ON THAT -- AND
THIS IS ALSO A PROPOSAL THAT
COULD BE BROUGHT BACK IN A
FUTURE HERE AS WELL SO.
THANK YOU ARE AND FINANCE OF THE
SENATE TODAY IS PREPARED TO VOTE
AND ACCEPT THE ASSEMBLY VERSION.
AND FINANCES SUPPORTS THE
ASSEMBLY VERSIONS THE AUDIO
NOTED HOW WE THINK THAT THE
RELUCTANCE IN THE SENSE OF TWO
IS REALLY IT WAS BASED ON HOW
FAR WERE IN THE ENTIRE OFFICE
STATE FARMERS REVIEW BUT WE HAVE
COMPLETED REVIEW OF THE FIRE AND
LIFE SAFETY DIVISION.
AND WE'RE GOING THROUGH THAT
OFFICE DIVISION BY DIVISION SO
WE THINK THAT THESE RESOURCES
ARE REALLY CRITICAL THIS TIME TO
SUPPORT CAPITAL PROJECTS AND
IMPROVE THE REVIEWS OF THE FIRE
MARSHAL'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU ALL ENTERTAINMENT
MOTION TO ACCEPT IS THE ONLY
VERSION.
THANK YOU -- THE SENATE IS THAT
A QUESTION FOR THE MORE LOT
THIRTY MORE LOCK.
IS WHEN WILL THIS REVIEW BE
COMPLETED IT'S ARE AT THE
DEADLINE.
THE THE NATURE OF THE MISSION
BASED REVIEW APPROACH IS THAT WE
DON'T PUT A FIXED DEADLINE ON
THEM BECAUSE WE WERE TRYING TO
GO THROUGH AND KIND OF TAKE
ISSUES AS THEY COME UP AND MAKE
SURE WE FOLLOW THEM THROUGH ALL
THE WAY TO GET TO THE CORE OF
THE ISSUES.
BEFORE WE TRY AND SOLVE THEM --
BUT WE THINK THAT WILL BE DONE
WITH THE OFF STATE FIRE MARSHAL
IN TOTALITY ALL OF ITS DIVISIONS
PROBABLY IN ABOUT ANOTHER YEAR.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FIVE IN A
TEAM -- MOTION THE SENATE IS A
VOTE OF OKAY.
MISTER MOORE Là [inaudible]
A THREE TWO ONE WE'RE FIVE ON
THE ASSEMBLY IS FIVE TO NOTHING.
THANK YOU MOVING ON TO ISSUE TEN
THE CALIFORNIA BIODIVERSITY
INITIATIVE UNDERSEA THE FAA.
LA -- WHEN YOU'RE READY?
SHAMMAR WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THE ASSEMBLY
APPROVED THE GERM PLASM
COMPONENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S BIO
DIVERSITY PROPOSAL WHICH WOULD
REVIVE. FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE.
THE SENATE REJECTED THE
GOVERNOR'S THAT THAT THE GERM
PLASM COMPOENT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BIODIVERSITY PROPOSAL
AND INSTEAD APPROVED EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AS FOLLOWS. TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR THREE YEARS
FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE
PLATE FUND -- FOR COLLECTION OF
RARE PLANTS THROUGH CONTRACTS OR
GRANTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA PLANT
RESCUE PROGRAM AND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON
GOING FOR A POSITION TO OVERSEE.
THE CONTRACTS ARE GRANT AND
MONITOR AN UPDATE THE STATUS OF
NATIVE PLANTS REGARDING THE GERM
PLASM PROGRAM -- WE THINK
THEY'RE REASONABLE ARGUMENTS FOR
HOUSING COMPONENTS AND FUNCTIONS
OF THE PROGRAM IN EITHER THE
PARCHMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
OR THE DEPARTMENT IF THEY NAPA
CULTURE.
ELIA FUSE ME FINANCE.
CALIFORNIA BIODIVERSITY
INITIATIVE WROTE BACK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THREE NINE
WILL HOLD THE SADDAM OFTEN.
ISSUE ELEVEN HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND SUNSET
EXTENSION [inaudible]
ELIA.
ASA THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU IS
WHETHER TO EXTEND ANNUAL FUNDING
FOR THE HABITAT CONSERVATION
FUND AS PROPOSED IN TRAILER BILL
BY THE ASSEMBLY THE SENATE AND
GOVERNOR HAD NO PROPOSAL ON THIS
ISSUE.
THIS FUND WAS CREATED BY A VOTER
INITIATIVE PROPOSITION ONE
SEVENTEEN IN NINETEEN NINETY THE
INITIATIVE REQUIRES THE STATE TO
DEPOSIT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY INTO THIS FUND BY A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS.
I EACH YEAR BUT A CERTAIN AMOUNT
MUST COME FROM THE STATE'S
TOBACCO TAX FUNDS IN RECENT
YEARS THAT'S BEEN ABOUT HALF
ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION OF THE
THIRTY MILLION.
AND THE STATE HAS USED VARIOUS
OTHER RESOURCES TO MAKE UP THE
REMAINDER OF THE THIRTY MILLION
INCLUDING GENERAL FUND.
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE FUND
AND BONDS -- PROPOSITION ONE
SEVENTEEN ALSO SPECIFIED HOW THE
MONIES FROM THIS FUNDS MUST BE
USED EACH YEAR THE BULK OF IT --
IS FOR THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD.
TO ACQUIRE LANDS FOR
CONSERVATION IN VARIOUS
SPECIFIED CATEGORIES THERE'S
ALSO SOME FUNDING FOR PARKS AND
CONSERVANCY'S TO DO ACQUISITIONS
AS WELL.
THE REQUIREMENT FOR THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION OF THIS
THIRTY MILLION AND THE REQUIRED
EXPENDITURE CATEGORIES ARE
EXPENSE AS SCHEDULED TO SUNSET.
IN TWENTY TWENTY SO THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL WOULD EXTEND THEM FOR
AN ADDITIONAL TEN YEARS.
I WILL NOTE THAT ALTHOUGH THERE
WAS NO ACTION TAKEN BY THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE ON THIS
ISSUE THERE IS ACTIVE
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD EXTEND
THIS SB.
FOUR SEVEN FOUR I WOULD EXTEND
THE FUN BUT WITHOUT THE
CONTINUES APPROPRIATION IT WOULD
MAKE IT CONTINUING -- CONTINGENT
ON AN ANNUAL BUDGET
APPROPRIATION AND ALSO WOULD
REMOVE THE SPECIFIC EXPENDITURE
CATEGORIES WITHIN THE FUND'S.
THANK YOU FINANCE A WILL KNOW
THAT WHILE THE GOVERNOR DID NOT
HAVE A PROPOSAL HERE -- WE ARE
COMFORTABLE AND SUPPORT THE
ASSEMBLY IS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
PERFECT THANK YOU QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER NIELSEN
[inaudible]
ANALYSTS.
THIS WILL RESULT IN MORE
ACQUIRING OF LANCE.
AND HAS THE BILL OVER THE
DECADES A PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA
OF ACQUIRING LANDS INDOOR
CONVERSION INTO PARKS OR
WHATEVER.
THE STATE HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THESE.
THIS WOULD APPEAR TO BE A PRETTY
BOLD PLAN.
OF TAKING LANDS IN THE STATE
AUTHORITY.
BUT IS THERE A PLAN TO MAINTAIN
THESE PLANTS.
I THINK OFTEN MANY OF THESE
GRANTS ARE -- FROM LAND TRUSTS
OR OTHER NON NONPROFIT OR OTHER
ENTITIES THAT APPLY FOR THE
FUNDS IN ORDER TO DO THAT
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROCESS THROUGH WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD SO WHILE
THERE MAY BE SOME CATEGORIES
WHERE THE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE OR THE STATE PARKS TAKE
ON THE LAND I DON'T.
THINK THAT'S EXCLUSIVE FOR ALL
THESE I THINK MANY OF THEM ARE
COMING FROM THE FIELD IF YOU
WELL -- APPLYING TO TIP PUT LAB
LAND IN CONSERVATION.
AND SOMETIMES THEY ARE NOT
MAINTAINED THAT IS A PROBLEM
THAT IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
THE STATE HAS STRUGGLED WITH FOR
LANDS THAT ARE IN STATE
OWNERSHIP ONGOING OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE FOR SHORE
[inaudible]
QUESTION.
THE NUMBER HOLD OF SADDAM OFTEN
THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE TWELVE CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
HELLO WHEN YOU'RE READY.
ROSS BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DO HAVE A
HANDOUT ON THIS ISSUE THAT --
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE IN YOUR
PACKETS ALL GO THROUGH THAT VERY
BRIEFLY -- SO IF YOU TURN TO
PAGE ONE OF THE HAND OUT.
JUST PROVIDES A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE THREE DIFFERENT CAP
AND TRADE.
EXPENDITURE PACKAGES ON JUST THE
REVENUES -- EXPENDITURE AMOUNTS
AND THEN IN DEAR FUND BALANCES --
SO A COUPLE THINGS TO HIGHLIGHT
HERE ON THE REVENUES ABOUT THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY ADOPTED AN
ASSUMPTION OF HIGHER REVENUES IN
THE IN THE GOVERNOR DID AND BOTH
HOUSES ALSO ADOPTED -- SOMEWHAT
HIGHER SPENDING -- THAN THE
GOVERNOR DID -- SO THE SENATE
ADOPTED ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS MORE IN THE
OVERALL SPENDING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE THE ASSEMBLY
IS ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS MORE.
AND YOU CAN KIND OF SEE THE THE
AND FUND BALANCES UNDER UNDER
THE DIFFERENT PLANS AND THE
TABLE THERE -- SO JUST A COUPLE
OF QUICK COMMENTS FIRST ON THE
THE REVENUE -- WE ACTUALLY THINK
BOTH THROUGH GOVERNOR'S REVENUE
ASSUMPTIONS AS WELL AS THE
HOUSES BOTH HOUSES REVENUE
ASSUMPTIONS ARE REASONABLE THAT
JUST KIND OF A DIFFERENCE IN.
THE LEVEL OF RISK ASSOCIATED
WITH THEM.
BASICALLY THE GOVERNOR'S --
ABSTINENCE ASSUME -- PRICES
CONTINUE IT THE WAY THEY THEN
ESSENTIALLY COLOR OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS WHERE AS BOTH.
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY ASSUME --
THE MARKET FOR ALLOWANCES AND
PRICES KIND OF CONTINUE AT THE
WHAT WAS SEEN IN THE MOST RECENT
AUCTIONS SO WE THINK FOR BOTH --
REASONABLE BUT THE SENATE
ASSEMBLY -- VERSIONS RICHEST
SOMEWHAT MORE RISKY AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KIND OF KEEP IN
MIND ABOUT KIND OF HOW TO PLAN
FOR THAT IF YOUR SIM IN SOMEONE
HIGHER REVENUES GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY IN REVENUES.
COUPLE THINGS TO THINK ABOUT ONE
THE FUN CONDITION THAT KIND OF
THE OVERALL SIZE OF THE FUND
CONDITION -- IN THE FUN
CONDITIONS OVER BOTH HOUSES ARE
ARE SOMEWHAT MODEST -- BUT THE
ASSEMBLY IS A SLIGHTLY HIGHER --
ALSO WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CONSIDER BOTH PLANS AS WELL AS
THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN INCLUDE SOME
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THEY GIVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SOME
AUTHORITY. TO FOR CERTAIN
PROGRAMS TO ADJUST THOSE
ALLOCATIONS DOWN WORD OF REVENUE
COMES IN LOWER THAN EXPECTED SO
THAT'S A OUT ONE WAY TO CAN
MITIGATE AGAINST THE THE RISK OF
LOWER THAN EXPECTED REVENUES.
AND THEN THIRD THE FINAL ISSUE%
IS JUST ONE THING ABOUT THE
OVERALL PACKAGE IN THE AMOUNT OF
SPENDING WE THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND.
OUT YOUR REVENUES IN THE LEVEL
OF RESOURCES THAT MIGHT BE
AVAILABLE BEYOND THE BUDGET YEAR
AND SO -- OUR VIEW OF KIND OF
LOOKING AT THE OUT YEAR REVENUES
THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE THAT THE
AMOUNT THAT'S AVAILABLE.
FOR A DISCRETIONARY EXPENDITURES
THAT ARE ALLOCATED IN THE BUDGET --
WILL BE COULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS THAN KIND OF THE AMOUNT
THAT'S IN THIS BUDGET AND SO
THINKING ABOUT -- YEAH REVENUE
THAT'S AVAILABLE COULD BE YOU
KNOW AND AND THE RANGE OF A
BILLION DOLLARS OR LASSEN THESE
PACKAGES PROVIDE ABOUT ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION AND SO THINKING
ABOUT THAT WHEN YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT HOW MUCH.
MONEY TO LEAVE IN THE FUND
BALANCE FOR FOR FUTURE YEARS WE
THINK IS AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION.
SO -- PAGES TWO AND THREE OF THE
HAND OUT.
INCLUDE JUST A SUMMARY OF THE
WE'LL GO OVER THOSE IN DETAIL --
IN GENERAL WE JUST.
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ALLOCATE IN FUNDING ACCORDING TO
ITS PRIORITIES AND DIFFERENT
GOALS.
A HIGH LEVEL THE ASSEMBLY --
ALLOCATES MORE MONEY THAN THE
SENATE DOES TO A COUPLE PROGRAMS
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
GENERALLY AND I SHOULD SAY.
FORGET ABOUT THE ASSEMBLY
PACKAGE -- ALLOCATES MONEY TO
KIND OF GENERAL CATEGORIES OF
PROGRAMS AND NOT -- SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS I THINK WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THOSE --
THOSE DETAILS WOULD BE WORKED
OUT THROUGH THIS PROCESS -- SO
THE ASSEMBLY ALLOCATES MORE THAN
THE SENATE TO LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION AND TOXIC ENTRY
CRITERIA POLLUTANT PROGRAMS --
OR AS THE SENATE -- TENDS TO
PRIORITIZE -- FOR ITS --
RESILIENCY AN ADAPTATION AND
SOME AND AGAIN AND WASTE A
VERSION AND RECYCLING.
SO THE FINAL PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
PAGE -- FOUR JUST NOT ONE NOTE
EVERYTHING ON THIS PAGE WITH SIR
FOR YOUR REFERENCES ARE SOME
DIFFERENCES AND BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE AND PLACER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE IN PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE -- FOR THE
PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
ONE THING ON NOTE IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY PACKAGE BOTH THE CENTER
IN THE ASSEMBLY REJECTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND TRADING AT THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD I
WOULD BE KIND OF A NEW -- PART
OF MONEY FOR G. R. S. -- BUT THE
ASSEMBLY PACKAGE ALLOCATED
INSTEAD TWENTY SEVEN MILLION TO
A PROGRAM THAT'S CURRENTLY
OPERATING AT THE CC IN WITH.
ALLOCATE MORE MONEY FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
TRAINING THROUGH THAT PROGRAM --
AS FAR AS THAT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ADOPTED BY
THE ASSEMBLY -- ONE THING I'LL
I'LL NOTE NOW THAT LAST BULLET
THERE IS THAT IT PROVIDES A
LEGISLATURE THE INTENT IS TO
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN.
ON OPTIONS THAT CARP IS
CONSIDERING TO ADDRESS -- A
FUNDING GAP AND IT'S CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT WHICH IS
THE PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
INCENTIVES. FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES THROUGH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD SO -- IN MY
COMMENTS THEY'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
FINANCE THE WILL OPEN OPEN OPEN
IT FOR QUESTIONS SO THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
SUPPORT THE NAY REVISION
PROPOSAL AND I WILL MAKE I JUST
TWO COMMENTS AND AND HAPPY TO GO
INTO ANY DETAILS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HERE.
THE FIRST IS THAT THE LEVEL OF
SPENDING -- IN THESE PROPOSALS
FOR G. R. F. -- THAT NAY AUCTION
RESULTS CAME IN AND NOW WE TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS UP TO AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE -- COMPARED TO WHAT WE
LAST PROPOSED THAT BEING SAID
THAT LEVEL IS STILL TENS OF
MILLIONS OR IN ONE CASE EVEN
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
HELLO -- THE LEVELS PROPOSED BY
EITHER HOUSE SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROPOSAL THAT IS
ENACTED IS ACTUALLY IN LINE WITH
THE REVENUES THAT WE EXPECT.
AND THEN THE SECOND POINT THAT I
WANT TO MAKE -- IN RELATION TO
THE LAST COMMENT FROM THE LA --
REGARDING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A KEY
COMPONENT OR NEEDS TO BE A KEY
COMPONENT OF TRANSITION TO A LOW
CARBON ECONOMY AND SO IT IS IN A
VERY IMPORTANT PART.
OF THE GOVERNOR'S CAP AND TRADE
PLAN AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING THAT WITH YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR MAYES FOLLOWED BY MR
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- WANTED
TO JUST DOUG GO OVER A COUPLE OF
ITEMS HERE IF I IF I CAN -- I
THINK.
MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT WHAT WE
START TO TALK ABOUT CAP AND
TRADE IT IS A BIT OF A SENSITIVE
SUBJECT. FOR ME IN FACT I STILL
HAVE A SCHOLARS -- BECAUSE OF OF
IT NOW THEY'RE ALL HEALED NOW
BUT THERE IS SOME THAT'S WHY I
LET YOU SPEAK FOR A THANK YOU --
BUT THERE ARE SOME SOME SCHOLARS --
AND ONE A KILLER -- ITEM THAT
WAS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WHEN WE
DID THE NEGOTIATIONS -- WAS THE
FINAL SUNDAY THAT -- AND RELIVE
THE WHOLE THE WHOLE EXPERIENCE --
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I HAD
FAILED TO DO NUMBERS TO EDUCATE
FOLKS PRIOR TO THE DEAL BEING
DONE -- AND IT WAS -- MONDAY HE
A LATE MONDAY EVENING -- AND THE
REASON WE DIDN'T GET OUT OF IT
BEFORE THAT MONDAY EVENING WAS
ON SUNDAY -- THERE WAS -- NIT
FINAL NEGOTIATIONS WITH AG A TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MEMBERS THAT
WE HAD IN OUR CAUCUS WE'RE GOING
TO BE SUPPORT OF THE WHOLE
CONCEPT WAS THAT AG HAD TO BE.
A TAKEN CARE OF AND THE FARMER
PROGRAM -- WHAT WHAT'S NOW THE
FORMER PROGRAM WAS A BIG PIECE
OF THAT PUZZLE?
DURING THE INITIAL THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR THAT WAS THE GOVERNOR
SUBMITTED WAS TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THE FORMER
PROGRAM I BELIEVE NOW THE MAY
REVISION.
IT'S NINETY MILLION -- BUT THE
LAST YEAR WAS A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION AND AND ONE
CARD IS DONE THEIR ANALYSIS IT
IS STILL SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN
WHAT THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS GONNA
NEED. TO BE ABLE TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
OTHER CRITERIA POLLUTANTS IN
REGARDS -- TO TO AG EQUIPMENT
AND SO WHY ARE WE FUNDING IT AT
LEAST A HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MEN
ON REALITY IT NEEDS TO BE MUCH.
MUCH HIGHER.
OF METAL ME DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO JUST FOR CONTEXT --
LAST YEAR'S CAP AND TRADE
PACKAGE WAS A ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR.
OVERALL PACKAGE IN AS THE ELLIE --
CORRECTLY NOTED -- THE REVENUES
FLUCTUATING KIND OVER TIME YOU
KNOW THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
LESS.
YOU KNOW IN OUT YEARS AND SO THE
MAY REVISION PACKAGE.
OVERALL WAS ONE POINT TWO FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS SO.
THE FARMER PROGRAM WHILE YOU'RE
CORRECT IT IS LESS.
IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT A LOT OF THE
OTHER CATEGORIES ALSO -- ARE
LESS COMPARED TO WHAT THEY WERE
IN PRIOR YEARS SO -- WHAT I CAN
JUST SAY IS IS THE THAT
PARTICULAR PROGRAMME WASN'T
SINGLED OUT IN FOR OR OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT THERE IS --
THE AB SIX SEVENTEEN THE PROGRAM
FOR EXAMPLE LAST YEAR IS TWO
FIFTY THIS YEAR IT'S TWO HUNDRED
THERE'S SOME OTHER EXAMPLES IT
JUST REFLECTS THE FACT THAT AS
AN OVERALL PACKAGE.
THERE'S LESS AVAILABLE AND OF
GET.
YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN WHICH
IS THE ACT DIESEL REPLACEMENT
CHECKS A LOT OF BOXES AND TURNS
TO GHG REDUCTIONS IN TERMS OF
REDUCTIONS IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOSTLY
IMPACTED AS WELL AS BENEFITING
THE AG SECTOR SO -- WE DO THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM WHICH
IS WHY WE HAVE UCH A STRONG
INVESTMENT BUT IT JUST REFLECTS
THE AMOUNT OF OVERALL
AVAILABILITY.
AND YET WE WERE STILL ADDING IN
NEW PROGRAMS AS WELL.
INTO THIS WAS A JUST A TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION I MIGHT HAVE
MISSED THAT SO I'LL SPEAK
BRIEFLY THEN MAC INFO ON THIS.
ONE NEW PROPOSAL IS THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT IN THE SENSE THAT
THERE ARE THE OTHER PROPOSALS IN
OUR CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM DO NOT
HAVE THAT DIRECT FOCUS ON
TRANSITION TO A LOW CARBON
ECONOMY FOR WORK FORCE WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BUT AS MATT.
MENTIONED THE OVERALL PACKAGE IS
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS OF THIS
IS ABOUT 3% OF THE OVERALL.
OKAY.
AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE MORE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT AND
THERE'S ONE OTHER ITEM.
IN LOOKING AT THIS IN REGARDS TO
FOREST'S.
THERE'S TWO HUNDRED MILLION FROM
THE GOVERNOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FROM THE SENATE I THOUGHT THE
GOVERNOR WAS PROPOSING.
NOT TO UNDERMINE WITH THREE
HUNDRED MILLION IS THAT GENERAL
FUND OR OR OR DID I DID I
MISUNDERSTAND THIS IS BACK IN
FEBRUARY.
TALKING ABOUT THAT WE HAD TO TO
DO MORE INVESTMENT. FOR FOR FOR
HEALTHY FORESTS -- I THOUGHT
WITH WE'RE GONNA LOOK INTO A
MILLION TO THREE HUNDRED MILLION
[inaudible]
THE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL OF TWO HUNDRED MILLION
IS A CONSISTENT WITH A SB NINE A
ONE A FRAMEWORK OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION.
ON AN ONGOING BASIS NOW THAT
ISN'T TO SAY THAT THERE AREN'T.
OTHER INVESTMENTS IN THE
FORESTRY FORCED HEALTH AREA IT'S
A PORTFOLIO APPROACH AS WE
TALKED ABOUT THE C. ONE THIRTIES
WE TALKED ABOUT ADDITIONAL
ENGINES.
THE YEAR ROUND ENGINES ALSO HAS
A FIRE PREVENTION.
OF BENEFIT IN THE SENSE THAT
WHEN IT'S OFF OF A OFF PEAK
SEASON THEY'RE ALSO DOING
ADDITIONAL FUEL REDUCTION WORK.
SO IT'S KIND OF A A PORTFOLIO
APPROACH BUT IN TERMS OF THE CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN
THAT'S REALLY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION.
OKAY AND THEN DEFINING MADAM
CHAIR OF THE ONE THING IF I
COULD ADVOCATE FOR HIS ANY
FLEXIBILITY IN THIS AT ALL OF
THE IF WE COULD INCREASE THAT
FARMER.
A FARMER AMOUNT.
SIR -- MR OBERNOLTE FOLLOWED BY
MISTER MOORE LOT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO I'D
LIKE TO TAKE YOU BACK ON THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE ON
FOREST'S BECAUSE I WHEN I SERVED
ON BUDGETS OF THREE I WAS ALWAYS
AMAZED.
AT THE DIFFERENCE THE
DEFICIENCIES WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
USE OF G. G. R. F. MONEY IF YOU
LOOK AT THE TO FIND EFFICIENCY
AS HOW MANY TONS OF CARBON CAN
WE REDUCE FOR A GIVEN DOLLAR
THAT WE SPEND.
BY.
FUELS REDUCTION WITH AND
ENFORCED INITIATIVES WERE ALWAYS
NEAR THE TOP OF THAT LIST.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE.
THAT A LARGE FOREST FIRE
REPRESENTS A HUGE DE
SEQUESTRATION OF CARBON DIOXIDE
AND THAT ONE FOREST FIRE CAN
WIPE OUT ALL THE RESTORE CARBON
REDUCTION EFFORTS AND THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE STATE.
THE IN IN -- ONE OF THAT FOR THE
FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR SO I REALLY
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE USE OF DID
YOU ARE A FUNDS FOR THAT AND
ALSO I THINK THEY'RE CONGRUENT
WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT.
STATE PRIORITIES NOT THE LEAST
OF WHICH IS -- WHEN THE WITH THE
THE YOU UTILITY PROBLEMS SB NINE
ONE WE'RE HAVING OBVIOUSLY BUT
ALSO AIR QUALITY BECAUSE THAT
BLACK CARBON THAT?
GETS SUBMITTED BY THOSE FOREST
FIRES IS -- IN A REALLY THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE THING FOR QUALITY
THAT WITH THAT -- THAT OCCURS SO --
THE I WOULD ENCOURAGE US TO
CONSIDER.
A LEVEL OF EXPENDITURE CLOSER TO
THE SENATE VERSION DOWN WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED OR
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY HAS PROPOSED.
IN THAT RESPECT.
I ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT -- THE
PLACEHOLDER PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
THE TO THE ASSEMBLY VERSION I
WONDER IF SOMEONE COULD TALK
ABOUT.
WHAT EXACTLY THE INTENT IS WITH
THAT BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A BIT
OF CONFUSION?
AND THAT'S THAT'S PROBABLY --
NOT FOR THE DEAL WELL MAYBE THE
LA OFFICE.
SO -- ALL THE DIFFERENT PIECES
OF THE PLACEHOLDER PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THERE'S A FEW DIFFERENT
PIECES ARE JUST CURIOUS IF THERE
WAS A PARTICULAR PIECE ABOUT THE
AB FORTY SPECIFICALLY
[inaudible]
THE I'M SORRY THE WHAT THE WHAT
AB FORTY RELATED.
PIECE [inaudible]
THE I'M SORRY I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH AB FORTY PIECE OKAY IT'S
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THERE.
IS SOME INTENT LANGUAGE THAT
MIGHT -- ATTEMPT TO PUT LIMITS
ON INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE
SALES OF VEHICLES.
SO IS THIS THAT -- CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON THAT YEAH SORRY --
SO THAT -- THERE IS. ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION OF FUNDING FOR
RESEARCH THAT WOULD GO TO THEIR
RESOURCES BOARDS TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGY -- TO MOVE THE STATE --
TO WERE ALL LIGHT LIGHT DUTYVEHICLES WOULD BE ZERO EMISSION
AND SO THAT STRATEGY -- WOULD BE
DUE TO BE COMPLETED AND AND
PRESENTED TO THE LEGISLATURE BY
JUNE THIRTIETH -- TWENTY TWENTY
THAT WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY VERSION
BUT NOT THE SENATE AND NOT IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
THAT'S CORRECT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAN I'M SURE THIS IS
THE DISCRETIONARY.
EXPENDITURE PLAN WHAT IS THE NON
DISCRETIONARY PLAN [inaudible]
SO -- IF YOU'RE GONNA REFER TO
THE TABLE ON PAGE ONE OF THE
HAND OUT -- SO CAN I GET THE
DIFFERENT PIECES OF THE OVERALL
PACKAGE OF SPENDING -- AND SO
THERE'S FOUR DIFFERENT PIECES ON
THAT -- THE BIGGEST DOLLAR
AMOUNT THERE IS THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS SO AND CURRENTLY
IN STATE LAW 60% OF ANNUAL
REVENUE WILL AUTOMATICALLY GETS
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED TO
CERTAIN PROGRAMS -- YOU KNOW
HIGH SPEED INCLUDING HIGH SPEED
RAIL AND VARIOUS TRANSPORTATION
RELATED PROGRAMS -- THERE'S ALSO
SOME SMALLER PIECES RELATED TO
SOME ACTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN IN PREVIOUS YEARS -- WHERE
FUNDING IS KIND OF AUTOMATICALLY
ALLOCATED -- TO ALL SAID IN AN
EXTENSION OR EXPANSION OF SALES
TAX EXEMPTION -- PROVIDED TO
OFFSET THE SUSPENSION -- THAT'S
OUR AC SO THOSE ARE CATEGORIZED
AS KIND OF OFF THE TOP BACK
FILLS IN THAT CHART THAT YOU SEE.
AND THEN FINALLY THERE'S JUST
SOME RESOURCES -- FOR KIND OF
ONGOING ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
THAT AGENCIES WHICH HAVE BEEN
CUT APPROVED IN PREVIOUS YEARS
AND SO THEY ARE -- TYPICALLY
CONSIDERED AN SORT OF THIS --
THIS A GENERAL DISCUSSION AROUND
DISCRETIONARY EXPENDITURES.
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN BECAUSE I
WOULD LOOK.
AT THAT CLEAR TITLE WITH I CAN
ASK MORE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
SO NOW THAT I KNOW OUR HIGH
SPEED RAIL IS AT THE TAKES CARE
OF THAT -- BUT THE SERMON
OBERNOLTE.
KIND OF ASKED THE QUESTION I
WANTED TO ASK BUT MAYBE OVER FOR
DO A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY -- PART
IN THE CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS.
AS OUR FINING IN THERE FOR
HARDENING ELECTRIC [inaudible]
POWER LINES.
NOT IN THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS.
SO WHERE IS IT IN THE
DISCRETIONARY.
IS IT JUST THE EIGHTEEN MILLION
IN THE SENATE.
OUR PROPOSAL WORDS AS WILD LINE
WHILE DANCE BECAUSE WE URBAN
INTERFACE AND OTHER.
FIRE PREVENTION -- SO THERE'S A
VARIETY OF PIECES RELATED KIND
OF FORESTRY AND FIRE PREVENTION
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY OF THOSE
KIND OF SPECIFIC PIECES
INCLUDING MONEY SPECIFICALLY FOR
KIND OF HARMONY IN.
ELECTRICAL LINES -- THIS YEAR
WE'RE FOCUSED ON WILDFIRES --
BUT FOCUSED AND PGA ANY AS A
UTILITY WERE I MEAN THIS IS THE
FOCUS AND HERE WE HAVE A REVENUE
OPPORTUNITY. TO DO SOMETHING SO.
IT DID IT'S BEEN THE EMPHASIS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE NOT MAYBE
THIS.
ONE BUT THE PRIOR GOVERNOR OF OF
ELECTRIFYING THIS STATE.
AND IF WE'RE GONNA TRY TO GET
EVERYONE TO DRIVE ELECTRIC CARS
IN FOR GONNA TRY AND GET
EVERYBODY TO DRIVE ELECTRIC
TRUSTS.
WHICH TAKES AN INCREDIBLE
ELECTRICITY. TO TO CHARGE -- IT
ANY OF THE UTILITY POWER LINES
ARE CAUSING OUR WILDFIRES WHICH
THEN CREATE THE GREENHOUSE GASES
THAT WIPE OUT ALL THE EFFORTS.
THAT YOU BENEFIT FROM FROM
ELECTRIC CARS.
IT SEEMS TO ME SOMEWHERE IN HERE
WE SHOULD BE DOING SOMETHING TO
TO PROTECT OUR GRADE BECAUSE WE
HAVE.
TO DEVELOP A LARGER STRONGER
GRADE. TO TO USE MORE
ELECTRICITY THE POWER ALL THESE.
ELECTRIC CARS TYPE I AM I
MISSING THE CONNECTION WHY ISN'T
THE BUDGET PLAN.
TRYING TO INCORPORATE WILDFIRES
ELECTRICITY.
UTILITIES.
WHERE WHERE IS THE INTEGRATION
AYE AYE AYE WHAT I'M MISSING?
THIS CAP AND TRADE IS AN IS A
NATURAL REVENUE SOURCE RIGHT.
TWO MEN ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO AS PART OF THE ISSUE
THAT YOU JUST HEARD ON AGENDA
PAGE ELEVEN THE WILDFIRE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE -- THERE'S A
COMPREHENSIVE PROPOSAL THAT HAS
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FOR BOTH
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
AS WELL AS CAL FIRE.
OF THAT IMPLEMENTS THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SB NINE A ONE
WHICH IT REALLY FOCUSES ON WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MITIGATING
THE RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
UTILITY CAUSED WILDFIRES AND
THERE'S GOING TO BE ADDITIONAL
REGULATORY.
ACTIONS TAKEN AT THE PC RELATED
TO THE UTILITY REQUIRED OF OFF
AYE MITIGATION PLANS TO GET SET
THIS THIS VERY THING SO IT IS
JUST LIKE WITH WE TALK ABOUT CAO
FIRES PORTFOLIO APPROACH OF
ADDITIONAL ENGINES FIRE
PREVENTION.
AIR ATTACK OF THE WILDFIRE --
MITIGATION IS ALSO A PORTFOLIO
APPROACH WHERE WE'RE PUTTING
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS ON
UTILITIES -- WE'RE ENGAGING
ADDITIONAL -- FORCED HEALTH --
INPUT OF ACTIONS THE RESULT IN A
FEW REDUCTION AND FIRE
PREVENTION AND AT THE SAME TIME
WE'RE BEEFING UP OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE CAPABILITY SO IT'S KIND
OF AN ODD.
ALL OF THE ABOVE APPROACH -- AND
THERE WILL BE AN ADDITIONAL
ISSUE WHEN YOU GET TO THE PC AS
WELL RELATED TO THESE WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLANTS. SIX I GUESS
WERE MISSING IT IS IS ON PAGE
ELEVEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTEEN
THOUSAND OF G. G. R. F..
FUNDS IN AND I'M I'M THINKING TO
HARDEN THE ASSETS.
I'M NOT THINKING OF LESS THAN A
MILLION DOLLARS I'M THING AGAIN
I THINK FEES OR I MEAN THESE ARE
UTILITY -- ASSETS.
RIGHT BUT THERE ARE FORCE.
AND THERE ARE RESIDENTS.
ATTENDED.
THE SOMEHOW THERE'S GOTTA BE YOU
KNOW WE'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
MANDATING.
THAT THEY THEY BUILD MORE POWER
LINES TO DO WHAT WE WANT THEM TO
DO THIS I THERE'S THERE'S GOTTA
BE A COLLABORATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible] ONE OF CENTER
NIELSEN.
IT REFERS HERE TO THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE.
ANOTHER FIRE PREVENTION DOES
THAT MEAN ONLY THE URBAN
INTERFACE IN TERMS OF ASSESSING.
I WOULD RATHER SEE THAT INCLUDED
ALL WILD LANDS NOT JUST THE
URBAN INTERFACE.
BUT THESE FIRES.
ORIGINATE.
IN THE WILD LANDS NOT JUST AT
THE URBAN INTERFACE LEVEL.
ARE WE GOING TO BE ATTENDING TO
THOSE OTHER LANDS IS THAT A PART
OF THIS PLAN.
YEAH SO -- THAT WAS KIND OF PART
OF THE THE SENATE'S PACKAGE AND
I BELIEVE THAT PEACE IN
PARTICULAR WAS RELATED TO THINGS --
RELATED TO KIND OF SNOW
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND HOME
HARDENING AND MAKING SURE
THEY'RE CLEAR KIND OF EVACUATION
ROUTES -- WHEREAS THERE THE
OTHER SOME OF THE OTHER -- POTS
OF MONEY PARTICULAR CALIFORNIA'S
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR WHICH IS KIND OF MORE
GENERAL AND BROUGHT IT KIND OF
THE LANDSCAPE LEVEL OF FORESTRY
ACTIVITIES WHERE IS -- THAT
WHILE IN URBAN AND A SPACES IS
MORE ABOUT KIND OF LOOKING A
THE PROTECTING -- HOMES IN THAT
IN THAT INTERFACE AND EVACUATION
ROUTES AND SOME WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ISSUES AS WELL.
LET ME CLARIFY ANOTHER POINT
RAISED THE IS THE LANGUAGE IN
THERE ABOUT.
PHASING OUT OR ELIMINATING.
THE INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINES
SOME KIND OF STUDY FROM CARP
TOWARDS THAT END.
IS THAT A PART OF THIS AND
ANYWAY.
YES SO THERE IS MONEY FOR THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO STUDY THAT
ISSUE AND THEN REPORT BACK. TO
IN THE ASSEMBLY VERSION EXCUSE
ME SORRY.
YEAH WELL I AS USUAL I THINK
THEY'RE BOARD GET BETTER AHEAD
OF ITSELF.
ANOTHER [inaudible]
MAYBE.
KIND OF QUIET ITEM IN HERE BUT
IS THERE LANGUAGE THAT SAYS
FUNDING SHALL NOT BE ALLOCATED
FOR THE PURCHASE OF FULLY
AUTOMATED CALL AUTOMATED CARGO
HANDLING.
WHICH WOULD AFFECT OUR PORCH
VERY SIGNIFICANTLY.
IS THERE SUCH LANGUAGE.
THE ASSEMBLY PLACE HOLDER OR
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE INCLUDES.
A PROVISION ON THAT ISSUE AND
WAS THERE ANY REASON GIVEN FOR
THAT LANGUAGE.
WE'LL SEE IF ANY OF OUR I KNOW
WHY THE LANGUAGE IS THERE A WILL
FIXING OF OURS IN THE COLLEAGUES
CAN RESPOND -- AS WE GET TO THE
LISTENER TO NIELSEN.
ALL RIGHT WELL LET THAT COULD
ALSO BE A LITTLE BIT OF A
PROBLEM.
AS FAR AS OUR PORTS ARE
CONCERNED.
IN THE ACCESS AND THE AMOUNT
THAT WE CAN DELIVER FROM OUR
PORTS [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF A
COUPLE ISSUES -- AND REYES --
THE SOME ON THE WRONG PAGE SEE.
SO ON THE IF WE LOOK AT THE LA
OWES REPORT -- PAGE TO WEAR IT --
BREAKS DOWN THE DIFFERENT
ALLOCATIONS -- BY -- WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDING THE
SENATE'S RECOMMENDING AND THEN
THE ASSEMBLY AND I WAS WAS NOTED
THE ASSEMBLIES.
IS -- CATEGORY NOT SO MUCH
BROKEN DOWN -- BUT ON THE LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION WHICH
COVERS ARE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROJECT OUR AND CLEAN TRUCKS AND
BUSES IN OFF ROAD IN VERY SAID
THERE'S WE NOW KNOW THAT.
WELL WE'VE ALWAYS KNOWN THAT IT
IS OUR TRANSPORTATION VEHICLES
THAT ARE THE LARGEST SOURCE FOR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BUT
THEY'RE ALSO OUR MOST
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTOR TO AIR
POLLUTION.
AND SPECIFICALLY -- THE DIESEL
POWERED THE PETROLEUM BASED
DIESEL POWERED ARE FROM THE
PARTICULAR MATTER POINT OF VIEW
THE MOST SERIOUS ONE AND IF SO
IF PART OF OUR OBJECTIVE IS NOT
ONLY. TO GET OUT OUR CLIMATE
PROTECTION GOALS BUT AS OUR AB
THIRTY TWO LANGUAGE IN EVERY
SUBSEQUENT WE ALSO INCORPORATE.
THE AIR QUALITY.
THE IT PUTS THEN.
THE THE ROLE OF OUR CLEANING UP
OR TRANSPORTATION FLEETS.
NO PUTS OUT A PRETTY HIGH
PRIORITY.
AND WHAT AID IS BENNY CONTINUOUS --
SECOND OMINOUS SAY CONTINUES
TWICE NO SORT OF AGGREGATION ME
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION IN THOSE TWO
CATEGORIES THAT WE WOULD THAT WE
DON'T SEE THOSE AS ESSENTIAL
THINGS THAT SHOULD BE IN
CONTINUOUS PREPARATION NOW.
THAT IS SOMETHING I THINK BOTH
OF OUR HOUSES SHOULD ALWAYS
SHOULD BE CONSIDERING FOR THE
FUTURE -- BUT I APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY OVERALL INCREASE IN
THAT CATEGORY AND WHILE THEY
DIDN'T BREAK IT OUT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
AN INCREASE IN BOTH OVER THE
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDING
SO CLOSER TO THE SENATE FOR
HIGHER.
DEPENDING ON WHAT WE LAND.
ON BOTH THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE.
AND ON THE CLEAN TRUCKS AND
BUSES THAT WHAT WE CALL THE
HEAVY AND MEDIUM DUTY VEHICLES.
AND ON THE CLEAN VEHICLES -- I
THINK IT'S ALSO WORTH IT GIVEN
THAT THERE'S MANY MORE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ON THE MARKET THEIR
RANGES EXPANDING THAT WE LOOK AT
INCREASING.
THE WHAT THE RANGE MILEAGES FOR
OUR REBATE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW
IT'S AT TWENTY AND MILES IN WE
MIGHT CONSIDER TWENTY FIVE OR
SLIGHTLY HIGHER WE WOULD CAPTURE --
A GOOD AMOUNT OF THE VEHICLES
THAT ARE ON THE MARKET BUT WE
WOULD ALSO BE INCENTIVIZING
THOSE THAT WERE REALLY GETTING.
A GOOD -- I DO A GOOD INVESTMENT
FOR IN TERMS OF RANGE IN SUCH --
BUT ON THE ON THE OFF ROAD WE'VE
ALWAYS HAD IT AT A MUCH LOWER.
OR RATHER IN THE THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY WE'VE ALWAYS FUNDED
THAT AT A LOWER LEVEL THEN THE
PASSENGER VEHICLE.
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
START MAKING IT ON PAR AND PART
OF THAT IS THAT.
THAT CATEGORY VEHICLES THEIR
TURNOVER IS FASTER PASSED WE WE
INDIVIDUALS DON'T BY PASSENGER
VEHICLES VERY OFTEN SO WE GET
FAR MORE BANG FOR OUR BUCK IF WE
INCREASE OUR INVESTMENT.
IN THE HEAVY MEDIUM DO DO THE
VEHICLE -- REBATES AND
INCENTIVES BECAUSE THE CHAIN
CHANT DATE WE REPLACE THEM MORE
FREQUENTLY SO WE'RE GOING TO GET.
BETTER REDUCTION IN BOTH AIR
POLLUTION AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTION IF WE FIND
OUT POP BETTER.
SO I'D LIKE TO MAKE THE CASE FOR
MY PURPOSE IN SAYING ALL THAT
WAS TO MAKE THE CASE FOR BOTH OF
THOSE -- ADDITIONALLY -- THE
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM.
WHAT THE RESEARCH NOW SHOWS IS
THAT SOILS HAVE?
A MUCH MORE SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE THEN
I OUR OUR FOR CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN HAS NECESSARILY ACCOUNTED.
FOR AND GIVEN THE THE RISE IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS NOT
ONLY IN OUR STATE I MEAN WE'RE
WE'VE.
THEY'RE NOT.
RISING TO THE LEVEL THAT.
IN OTHER PLACES BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT THINGS
LIKE THE WILDFIRES IN OTHERS IT
DOES.
SET MUCH OF OUR GOOD WORK SO
WHAT THIS REALLY TELLS US
GLOBALLY IS THAT WE NEED.
MORE THAN JUST DIRECT EMISSIONS
REDUCTION WE NEED ALSO TO
STRENGTHEN.
THE THE CARBON -- STORAGE AND
THAT'S OF COURSE IN OUR FORESTS
IN OUR OCEANS.
AND VARIOUS OTHER ARE CORAL
REEFS BUT IT IS ALSO OUR SOILS
AND THE HEALTHY SOILS RESEARCH
SO FAR THE CARD TYPE OF PROJECTS
WE FUNDED.
HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT IT'S
REALLY HAS A GREAT CAPACITY FOR
CARBON STORAGE SO I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THAT -- THE SENATE
VERSION IS IT THINK A HEALTHIER
FUNDING LEVEL FOR THOSE HEALTHY
SOILS -- AND IN THE
TRANSFORMATIVE COMMUNITIES WHICH
THE GOVERNOR'S -- RECOMMENDED I
THINK.
LET'S SEE IF I GET THAT RATE
TRANSFERRED COMMUNITIES.
IS HIGHER THAN EITHER OF OUR
HOUSES -- NOT SURE WHAT THE
DEBATE WAS IN OUR OUR TWO HOUSES
MAYBE THE ASSEMBLIES BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T BREAK IT DOWN IS MORE
LIKE THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUT I THINK THAT WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IS THAT -- SOME VERY GOOD WORK
IN THE AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDED SO FAR BUT THE ONE NOTE
IF WE DO.
GO WITH FUNDING LEVEL OF THE
SORT THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOMMENDING I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT WE EXPAND THE ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS.
TO THE TOP 15% OF CAL AND VIRUS
SCREEN THE REASON I RAISE THAT
IS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW YOU CAN IF
YOU'RE IN THE TOP 25% YOU CAN
APPLY.
SO YOU CAN GET A PLAN GRANT BUT
THEN OUR CURRENT FUNDING FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS.
RESTRICTED ONLY TO THE TOP 5% SO
BASICALLY WE'RE FINDING PEOPLE
TO PLAN.
THEY DO GREAT PLANS.
REALLY GOOD PROJECTS AND THEN
THEY CAN'T APPLY FOR MONEY TO
IMPLEMENTED UNDER THE STRUCTURE
WE'VE DEVELOPED SO I'D LIKE TO
SEE THAT STRUCTURE FIXED -- AND
THEN -- ON THE WASTE DIVERSION
AND RECYCLING FOOD WASTE I THINK
WE'VE RECOGNIZED.
THAT INCREASINGLY FOOD WASTE
SIMILAR TO YOU KNOW HEALTHY
SOILS BEING A GREAT.
CARBON STORAGE THAT FOOD WASTE
IS A HIGHER IN MOREAND MORE
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF OUR
METHANE EMISSIONS AND THAT THE
MORE FOOD WASTE WE CAN.
CAPTURE AN AND IN AFFECT EITHER
COMPOST RECYCLE OR OR UTILIZED
IN A WAY OTHER THAN IN THE
LANDFILL WORK CREATES METHANE.
THAT THAT IS A A GOOD USE THAN
WHAT WE'VE SEEN NOW IS A LOT OF
THE ENTITIES FOUR POINT TO THE
MONEY.
THAT IS IN THE FOOD WASTE
CATEGORY THEY'RE ACTUALLY
THEY'RE NOT JUST COMPOSTING IT
THEY ARE GETTING THAT FOOD BACK
OUT TO FOR NEEDED.
THEY ARE TAKING -- FOR EXAMPLE
OUT FROM FARMERS MARKETS FROM
GROCERY STORES AND SUCH PRODUCE
THAT IS BEEN DEEMED BY THE
SELLER NOT TO BE STE SELLABLE
BUT IS STILL.
SAFE AND AN EDIBLE AND THEY'RE
GETTING IT OUT TO WHETHER IT'S
FOOD BANKS FOR OTHERS SO IT'S
REALLY IT'S MEETING TWO VERY
IMPORTANT GOALS ARE HUNGER
CHALLENGES AS WELL AS OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS CHALLENGES.
SO I FEEL THAT THE SENATE'S --
LEVEL OF A REQUEST FOR THAT FOOD
WASTE IS -- QUITE IS IS VERY
JUSTIFIABLE -- AND THEN LASTLY I
WANTED TO RAISE THAT WE WE DON'T
HAVE AS FAR AS I CAN TELL IN OUR
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
ANYTHING TO DEAL WITH.
OUR EXISTING BANK OF
REFRIGERANTS SO WE'RE TALKING
NOW.
THE H. CFCS BE -- THE SHORT.
LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS.
SENATOR LARA WHEN HE WAS SENATOR
CARRIED A BILL ON THIS AND MADE
IT A PRIORITY FOR CARP TO START
LOOKING AT THESE VARIOUS SHORT
LIVED POLLUTANTS.
BUT THEY HAVE A VERY VERY HIGH
GREENHOUSE GAS POTENTIAL.
AND THE LATEST RESEARCH
INDICATES THAT JUST RIGHT NOW UP
AND DOWN STATE CALIFORNIA IN OUR
EXISTING AIR CONDITIONERS IN OUR
EXISTING REFRIGERATORS.
MEANING BOTH COMMERCIAL AND
HOUSEHOLD.
THAT SITTING IN THOSE UNITS.
IS ENOUGH OF THIS REFRIGERANT
MATERIAL.
THAT IF IT WERE TO BE RELEASED
AT ONCE NOW YOU KNOW I KNOW IT'S
HYPOTHETICAL IS NOT LIKELY BE
RELEASED AT ONCE BUT JUST HEAR
THE POINT.
THAT IF IT WERE TO BE RELEASED
AT ONCE.
IT WOULD CREATE A GREATER GLOBAL
WARMING.
AT THE GREATER HIT ON OUR FULL
CARBON -- CALCULATION THEN FROM
ALL OTHER SOURCES IN ANY GIVEN
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS IS STUFF THAT IF WE IF
WE FOCUS ON HOW TO CAPTURE IT.
INSTEAD OF ALLOWING IT. TO TO BE
FUGITIVE EMISSIONS [inaudible]
WE WOULD.
WE WOULD DO A GREAT DEAL TO
PROTECT OUR CLIMATE AND WE WOULD
NOT IF WE JUST IGNORE IT SO I
THINK IT'S ONE OF THOSE THAT
NEED ATTENTION AND IS NOT
ANYWHERE IN ANYONE'S PLAN.
SO JUST WANTED TO GET THOSE OUT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU I DON'T WANT TO START
ON TO A DEGREE WAS SENATOR
SCARES COMMENTS AND THEN JUST
ADD ADD SOME THINGS.
ON IT IS GOING BACK TO LA -- AND
FINANCE I THINK ONE OF OUR THE
REASON OUR THERE ARE PROPOSAL
PUT MORE MONEY TOWARDS LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION OBVIOUSLY.
IS THE ONE AREA WHERE WE'RE NOT
MAKING PROGRESS AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S THE
EVERYWHERE IF WE DON'T START TO
TURN THINGS AROUND VERY QUICKLY
WE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO MEET
ALL OUR GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
GOAL START WITH THAT WE SET OUT
ITS. 40% OF TIONS AND YOU'LL
KNOW THAT 80% OF THE ADMISSIONS
COMES FROM PASSENGER VEHICLE SO.
GOING INTO THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM -- WAS CONCERNED
BY THE REPORT THAT CAR PUT OUT
SAYING THAT.
EVEN IF WE APPROPRIATED THAT THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION WHICH IS THE
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THAT THEY MAY BE.
OUT OF MONEY WITHIN THE FIRST
FEW MONTHS OF THE FISCAL YEAR.
SOMETIMES THE FIRST QUESTION THE
THE OTHER QUESTION WAS ON SORT
OF SORT OF GIVEN THAT RATHER
THAN JUST GIVING.
MONEY TO A INCENTIVE PROGRAM
THAT'S SORT OF NOT REALLY ANSWER
PROGRESS MARK AND TITLE MY
PROGRAM WHERE YOU JUST GET
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
HE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
TODAY YOU GET TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS NEXT YEAR OR
EVEN THE YEAR AFTER -- IN A
RATHER THAN -- BAILING THAT
PROGRAM OUT PER SE UNDER THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE HAS THERE BEEN
RETHINKING ABOUT SHOULD BE SURE
WE KIND OF GO TO SEE THE R. P.
TWO POINT NO ONE REALLY RETHINK.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET TO OUR
FIVE MILLION?
A VEHICLE CALL CENTERS.
YEAH SO ON ON YOUR FIRST POINT --
YET WE HAVE SEEN THOSE
PROJECTIONS FROM CAR BUT I MEAN
THERE'S YOU KNOW AND AS IN MANY
CASES THERE'S KIND OF A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY AND I THINK THIS
KIND OF UNCERTAINTY AROUND.
YEAH THE TESLA MODEL THREE ROLL
OUT IN THE EXTENT TO WHICH SORT
OF SNOW THAT WILL YOU KNOW THOSE
HIGHER NUMBERS IN RECENT MONTHS
MAYBE WILL CONTINUE BUT IT
CERTAINLY -- AN ISSUE WORSE KIND
OF FUEL CONSIDERING WHETHER OR
NOT THEY THEY WILL HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY OR KIND OF HOW MUCH MONEY
WILL HELP IN THE IN THE UPCOMING
YEAR AND THEN I GETS TO YOUR
SECOND POINT I THINK IS YOU KNOW
IT AND WE THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT POINT. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE CONSIDERING IT
IS -- YOU KNOW HOW THAT PROGRAM
SHOULD BE STRUCTURED GOING
FORWARD AND IF THERE IS GOING TO
BE THE SORT OF LOWER FUNDING
AMOUNT THEN -- CARPAL LIKELY
HAVE TO MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO
ITS PROGRAM AND THAT COULD BE IN
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT WAYS
WHETHER IT BE.
CHANGING THE INCOME CAPS
CHANGING YOU KNOW WHICH CARS
QUALIFY WERE VARIETY OF OTHER
THINGS AND SO -- WE DO THINK
IT'S AN IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO THINK ABOUT
WHETHER IT WHAT WHAT CHANGES
CARDS IS CONSIDERING AND WHETHER
OR NOT THOSE TYPES OF CHANGES
ARE CONSISTENT WITH IT WITH THE
LEGISLATORS PRIORITY IN ITS
VISION FOR THE PROGRAM GOING
FORWARD.
THE TREES A CALORIE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I THINK THAT LINED UP
WITH THE EXPECTATION OF THE
FUNDING THAT WAS PUT IN -- FOR
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION THAT
THERE WOULD BE AN EXPECTATION
THAT THOSE. FIVE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS WOULD BE REVISITED
WHETHER IT'S INCOME LEVELS ARE
OTHER.
PARTS OF THE PROGRAM.
I SEE SO SO WHO TOOK IT SO GIVEN
THAT -- IT IS ASSUMING THAT WE
WE WOULD PAY OUT.
PEOPLE WHO WEREN'T PAID IN THIS
FISCAL YEAR UNDER THE CURRENT
CRITERIA WE WOULD DO THAT AND
THEN POTENTIALLY UNDER THE NEW
FISCAL YEAR HAVE TO REVISE OUR
CRITERIA THAT.
RIGHT AND IT I DON'T KNOW THAT
IT WAS SPECIFIC TO AT WHAT POINT
TO THOSE CRITERIA WOULD BE
REVISITED BUT YES I THINK THAT
TECHNICIAN WAS.
THAT AS THE SALES ARE INCREASING --
GIVEN THE LEVEL OF MONEY THAT
THOSE WOULD HAVE TO BE REVISITED
AT SOME POINT.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU CAN IN WAS
THERE -- WAS THERE A SENSE AND
HOW LONG THE PROGRAM WOULD HAVE
WOULD HAVE TO GO ON TO EXIST TO
GET TO OUR FIVE MILLION VEHICLE
GOAL LIKE LIKE ANY INCENTIVE
PROGRAM AT SOME POINT THAT HAS.
TO STOP I MEAN WE HAVE TO WHAT
WE HAD A PARTICULAR GOAL WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO STOP IT.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT I THINK WE
WERE ENVISIONING AT THE SIMILAR
TO YOU KNOW SOLAR WHICH WAS YOU
KNOW AND KIND OF THE BEGINNING
AS YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCELERATE --
YOU WANTED TO PROVIDE INCENTIVES
BUT THEN AS THE COMMERCIAL
VIABILITY BECAME MORE REAL THAN
THE NEED FOR THE SUBSIDY WOULD
DECLINE.
AND SO THE IDEA BEHIND THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION WAS IS THAT --
AS THE DEMAND WENT UP YOU COULD
KIND OF FOCUS SAID IN TAYLOR IT
MORE TOWARDS SAY THE LOW TO
MIDDLE INCOME.
EARNERS WHERE THE INCENTIVE HAS
A GREATER MARGINALIZED THAT ON
DECISION MAKING THAN SAY HIGHER
INCOME AS AN AS AN ILLUSTRATIVE
EXAMPLE.
NOW YOU ALSO MIGHT RECALL THAT
LAST YEAR -- THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION HAD AGAIN A
PORTFOLIO APPROACH WHERE IT
WASN'T JUST REBATES BUT IT WAS
ALSO AN INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT WHERE -- THROUGH AN
ENERGY COMMISSION PROGRAM --
THEY WERE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS
IN THEIR MISSION INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH HELPS.
AGAIN IN THE CONSUMER DECISION
MAKING PROCESS WHERE I THINK WE
TALKED ABOUT RANGING SOCIETY.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU CAN
GET ADDITIONAL CHARGING STATIONS
SPREAD OUT MORE THAT THEN --
CREATES -- MORE -- CONFIDENCE
FROM THE CONSUMER PERSPECTIVE
THAT THEY WOULD BE CHARGING
STATIONS AVAILABLE IN MAKING THE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES MORE
VIABLE AND SO.
WHAT I WOULD SAY THEN IS YOU
KNOW THERE IS I THINK IT'S GO
BIZ I HAS A -- KIND OF GROUP
THAT CONTINUES TO MONITOR THE
PROGRESS OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES COLLABORATES WITH
ENERGY COMMISSION AS WELL AS
THEIR BOARD.
AND WILL YOU KNOW -- THEIR BOARD
OF COURSE -- CONTINUES TO
JUSTICE PROGRAM YEAR BY YEAR
BASED ON KIND OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY.
IN THE COURSE WITH WITH RANGE
ANXIETY PART OF THAT ARE THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES FROM THE CAN
DOWN A MAKERS.
TO MAKE CARS THAT HAVE REAL
RANGERS NOW THAT WERE WERE
MOVING AWAY FROM COMPLIANCE CARS
AND ACTUALLY.
THEY'RE BUILDING WILL YOU KNOW
REAL CARS WITH REAL RANGES OF
TWO HUNDRED PLUS MILES I THINK
THAT'S SLOWLY -- MOVED AWAY I
THINK I THINK THE SOLAR EXAMPLES
A GREAT EXAMPLE I THINK THE ONE
BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SOLAR AND
CV OUR P. WAS.
THEY HAD AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM
THAT STARTED HIGH AND WENT
TOWARDS ZERO AND RATCHET DOWN
BASED ON VOLUME SO ACTUALLY CRY
THINK IT CREATED.
MILESTONES AND TARGETS THAT WERE
HIT ALONG THE WAY AND THAT'S
WHAT WOULD TRIGGER THE LOWER --
INCENTIVE.
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE SHOULD BE.
CONSIDERING AS WELL AS TAKING A
HARDER LOOK AT RATHER THAN JUST
HAVING A STRAIGHT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR IN ENTITLEMENT.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU MANAGER.
FOCUSING ON THE WORK FORCE
TRAINING PIECE AND I KNOW YOU
SAID IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
GOVERNOR BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS I
MEAN FIRST OF ALL.
I'M SORT OF ONE WHO WEEK TEND TO
USE THIS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND IS A BANK.
FROM TIME TO TIME AND I DO THINK
THAT THE SINCE PEOPLE ARE PAYING
FOR THIS. TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
CAN.
DO SO THE MONEY THAT WE SHOW
ABOUT THE DOOR NEEDS SHOULD BE
DIRECTLY RELATED TO GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION. FOR THAT REASON
I'M SORT OF SENSITIVE TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM YOUR VALLEY SAID
IN HIS COMMENTS ABOUT DIESEL
ENGINE REPLACEMENT A VARIETY OF
OTHER THINGS MAYBE WE SHOULD.
BEFORE MOVING THIS MONEY IN THAT
DIRECTION WHERE THERE'S A DIRECT
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE
EXPENDITURE.
AND THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
BUT THE QUESTION [inaudible]
WORKFORCE TRAINING.
HOW MUCH MONEY FLOWS TO THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THROUGH WE OWE A? FOR
TRAINING EVERY YEAR AND ONE AND
TWO WHY DON'T WE TAKE THIS
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OUT
OF THE THE WE OWE MONEY THAT
COMES TO THE STATE THAT IS THEN
DISTRIBUTED DOWN [inaudible]
TO VARIOUS REGIONS.
SO I CAN SPEAK BRIEFLY ABOUT THE
SECOND QUESTION AND THEN A
COLLEAGUE OF MINE CAN SPEAK TO
THE FIRST SO I THINK. FOR THIS
THE ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTANDS
AND IS ALWAYS ON THE PROPOSAL
THAT IT PRESENTS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET MAY REVISION VERY CAREFUL
ABOUT THE USES OF THIS MONEY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S FOR A
SPECIFIC.
PURPOSE WE TO BELIEVE THAT THIS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM AS
DESCRIBED IS ALIGNED WITH THAT
PURPOSE IT'S NOT A GENERAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY OPEN TO
EVERYONE SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
THOSE PEOPLE IN THOSE AREAS.
THAT ARE TRANSITIONING -- TO A
LOW CARBON ECONOMY AND SEVEN
THAT SENSE WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS
VERY MUCH ALIGNED WITH THE GOALS
OF THIS PROGRAM WHAT WHAT IS I
MEAN I'M NOT I DID SIT ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND GENERALLY DON'T
TOUCH CAP AND TRADE VERY MUCH
UNLESS WE HAVE TO VOTE.
WHAT WHAT WHAT DOES THAT REALLY
MEAN THOUGH TRANSITIONING TO A
LOW?
WOULD YOU SAY LOW.
OF A CARBON LOW CARBON ECONOMY
WHAT DOES IT REALLY MEAN IN
TERMS OF JOB TRAINING I MEAN WE
TRAINING.
SOLAR TECHNICIANS WHAT ARE WE
DOING RIGHT TO AND THAT THE ME
REVISION PROPOSAL THE THIRTY
FIVE MINUTE.
MILLION DOLLARS WAS TO SUPPORT
THEM HIGH QUALITY SKILLED JOBS
ACROSS A LOT OF AREAS OF
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
INVESTMENTS.
M..
LOOK WHO I AM MAKE SURE THAT THE
JOBS THAT ARE RELATED TO
REDUCING GHG EMISSIONS ARE DONE
BY WELL TRAINED WELL PAID
WORKERS AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
CAN ACHIEVE THE BENEFITS FROM
THOSE PROGRAMS BY HAVING THAT
HIGHS HIGHLY SKILLED.
TRAINED JOB FORCE.
WHAT WE LIKE THOSE WE LIKE THAT
CONCEPT -- WHERE I COME FROM I'M
JUST RYING TO FIGURE OUT WHY
IT'S COMING OUT OF THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND?
AS OPPOSED TO WHAT I WHAT I
SUSPECT IS A FAIRLY ROBUST
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT FLOWS TO
THE STATE FOR WORKFORCE TRAINING
AND DEVELOPMENT.
RIGHT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING UP AND
TRYING TO GET THAT THE ANSWER TO
YOUR FIRST QUESTION ABOUT HOW
MUCH COMES INTO THE WE ARE FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FOR THIS
AND YOU'RE RIGHT THERE ARE OTHER
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
THIS ONE IS PARTICULAR TO I AM
GETTING THAT SKILLED WORKFORCE
OUT THERE IN.
IN ADVANCING OUR GHG EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS AND MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE WORKERS ARE THERE SO
THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS.
EMISSION REDUCTION TARGETS.
I'M NOT BEING CRITICAL I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
OBJECTIVES HERE WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND AND WHAT WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING WITH THE
MONEY THEY WERE COLLECTING FOR A
WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
STATE. TO ADD ON TO SENATOR RUSS
POINT CAN YOU GIVE EXAMPLES OF
THE KINDS OF JOBS THAT THIS PART
OF MONEY WOULD TRAIN.
FOR MAYBE THAT WOULD HELP US
UNDERSTAND IT WOULD
DIFFERENTIATE FROM THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
BROADER TRAINING THE DANIEL
BRENDA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A
CENTER NIELSEN TO YOUR QUESTION
THE STATE RECEIVED ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
I'M SORRY SENATOR OFTEN FOR YOU.
MY HAVE.
CHEESE.
ENGINE EIGHTY ONE POINT TWO
MILLION FOR THE MAY TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN REVISED OF WHICH ONLY
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND IS
DISCRETIONARY AND THOSE FUNDS
ARE USED TO THE FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS EXISTING PROGRAMS IN
THE WORK FORCE DATA ARENA AND
STOPPING THOSE.
ALLY C. SO.
SO FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND IS
DISCRETIONARY SO THIS MILLION
FIFTY SEVEN MILLION IS
DISCRETIONARY I SEE.
WHEN AT ONE OF THE TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE OF THE CATEGORIES WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT IS -- IS THAT
THE CONSTRUCTION.
INDUSTRY WE'VE ALSO TALKED ABOUT
LOOKING AT A FOCUS ON WORKFORCE
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
REGIONS THAT HAVE TRADITIONALLY
BEEN MORE DEPENDENT ON FOSSIL
FUELS IT'S ALSO REGIONAL
APPROACH IN ADDITION TO KIND OF
THE THE SPECIFIC TRAITS -- MAYES
FOLLOWED BY THREE TO NIELSEN.
I'LL BE QUICK MADAM CHAIR -- AND
THEN I WANT TO JUST BOB.
MAYBE TALK A LITTLE ABOUT WHAT
MY IN THE LAST THREE OF MY
COLLEAGUES -- HAVE HAVE SPOKEN --
SENATOR SKINNER IS ABSOLUTELY
ACCURATE WHEN SHE SAID THAT BY
THIS POINT TO REDUCE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WE HAVE.
TO DEAL WITH THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR WHICH IS WHY I'VE BEEN
ARGUING FOR OF THE FOR THE
FARMER PROGRAM INCREASING THAT
THAT NUMBER.
WE KNOW THAT MOM CLIMATE CHANGE
IS REAL.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE HAVE TO SAY
THAT ANYMORE IN FACT THAT'S THE
THAT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS ARE
STILL A FEW OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE RIGHT NATIONALLY THAT --
THAT'S A BIG DEAL WHEN THEY SAY
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL BUT THE
FACTS ARE THE FACTS -- ARE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS HAVE
BEEN CONTINUE TO RISE AT THE
SAME TIME GLOBAL TEMPERATURES
ARE RISING THE POINT OF THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM -- WAS TO BE
ABLE TO USE THE MARKET MECHANISM
TO REDUCE THOSE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS -- OVER THE OVER TIME
THE REALITY IS THE FUNDS THAT WE
RECEIVE THROUGH THE SELLING OF
THOSE ALLOWANCES IS REALLY JUST
A BY PRODUCT IT'S ACTUALLY NOT
THE POINT OF IT.
TOM IT'S A BY PRODUCT.
BUT TO MINE -- TO CENTER RAS
POINT -- HE'S EXACTLY RIGHT THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A CONNECTION
BETWEEN THOSE DOLLARS THAT ARE
RECEIVED TO ACTUALLY REDUCING
THOSE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
YOU GET A BANG.
YOU KNOW YOU GET TWO BIRDS WITH
ONE STONE WANT ONE STONE.
SO BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL
AND AND THIS IS WHY I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT I WOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF ARE NOT SUPPORTIVE
OF A BECAUSE THE AND IN IT I
HAVE ANOTHER.
SHEET HERE THAT ACTUALLY SHOWS
THE LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
WAS SIX HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION.
AND CLIMATE SMART BAG WAS FORTY
FIVE MINUTE THINK THAT FORTY
FIVE MILLION MIGHT BE THE FARMER
PROGRAM.
BUT IT'S SEPARATE OUT
DIFFERENTLY THAN THE SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTY MILLION I'M WONDERING
IF IF THE GOAL OF THAT SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION WAS -- FOR
WHAT WHAT WAS TO INCREASE THAT
THAT NUMBER -- BUT BECAUSE OUR
GOAL SHOULD BE TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR TO BILL TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS -- AND I DON'T KNOW IF --
IF ANY WOULD IF YOU GUYS CAN CAN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION -- AND IF
IF THAT WAS THE CASE WE CAN
INCREASE THE FORMER PROGRAM AND
DO MORE INCENTIVES TO BE ABLE TO
THE DIRT THAT HAVE NEW VEHICLES
THAT ACTUALLY REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS I MUSED SUPPORTER
OF THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL -- SO I
I THINK PART OF THE ISSUE MIGHT
JUST BE KIND OF KIND OF HOW THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS ARE
CATEGORIZED IN I THINK THIS GETS
TO YOUR POINT LEAD AT LEAST
PARTIALLY -- SO YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE THE ASSEMBLY PLAN WHICH
INCLUDES -- SOME MORE MONEY FOR
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION --
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THAT PACKAGE
COULD INCLUDE.
THINGS THAT THAT THE FOR LIKE
THE FARMER PROGRAM -- AT YOU
KNOW WHICH IT WHICH PROVIDE SOME
INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR YOUNG --
TRANSPORTATION RELATED EMISSIONS
RELATED TO AGRICULTURE AND SO --
PART OF BY THINK PART OF JUST
KIND OF THINKING ABOUT THESE
PACKAGES IS KIND OF YOU KNOW ONE
JUST KIND OF THINKING ABOUT HOW
YOU KIND OF CATEGORIZE THOSE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS WHICH I THINK
COULD KIND OF FALL UNDER.
JUST BE CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE CATEGORY OR IT COULD
BE SOMETHING LIKE THE FORMER
PROGRAM COULD BE FUNDED OUT OF
THE THE LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PART AS WELL.
SHOULD WE BE ASSIGNING WHAT
THOSE DOLLARS ARE GOING FOR ITS
IT IS SAYING IT'S FOR ALL SIX
HUNDRED AND I'M SIX AND SIXTY
NOT ANYTHING SHE WOULD BE
ASSIGNING -- WHAT WHAT THE THAT
THAT MONEY SHOULD GO TOWARDS?
I I MEAN I I THINK CERTAINLY FOR
LEGISLATURE KIND OF HAS
PRIORITIES ON WHICH PROGRAMS IT
THINKS ACCOMPLISHES ITS GOALS
MOST EFFECTIVELY -- AND IT'S
KIND OF CONSISTENT WITH ITS
PRIORITIES WHETHER IT BE KIND OF
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS OR
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION REDUCTIONS
THAN.
SPECIFYING THAT -- IN KIND OF
THE ALLOCATIONS AND PROVIDING IT
TO THOSE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS WE
THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA RATHER
THAN YOU KNOW GIVEN MORE
DISCRETION TO THE ADMINISTRATION
OKAY AND AND THEN FINALLY A
MANAGER JUST WANTED ALSO.
ECHO SOME MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS
IT SEEMS INAPPROPRIATE TO DO
WORKFORCE TRAINING -- THAT
THIRTY FIVE MILLION IS AN AWFUL
LOT OF MONEY SEEMS NAPPROPRIATE
TO BE USING TO G. R. F. MONEY.
FOR WORKFORCE TRAINING A BIG FAN
OF WORKFORCE TRAINING WE NEED
MORE OF IT NOT LESS OF IT BUT TO
USE YEAR AFTER HOURS TO DO SO I
THINK IT'S AN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU ARE CENTER NIELSEN WHO
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY MR MCCARTY
SINCE NIELSEN.
SPEAKING OF THE SOILS.
MY COLLEAGUE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THE THE SWELLS AND THAT IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT.
THESE CATACLYSMIC FIRES.
A VERY HARMFUL TO OUR SOILS.
THEY STERILIZE.
SOME OF THE LANDS THE HE GETS SO
HOT.
THAT THAT LAND WILL BE STERILE
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME.
SO WHAT IS THE PREMIUM THERE IT
IS.
MAINTAINING AND CLEANING UP OUR
FORCES IN AWHILE LANDS IN OUR
URBAN INTERFACE.
THE LAST TWO ADMINISTRATIONS
INCLUDING THIS ONE HAVE BEEN
GOOD ABOUT FINALLY AFTER DECADES
ATTENDING TO THIS AREA ARE
PAYING SOME ATTENTION TO IT.
BUT AS WE LOOK AT THIS CAP AND
TRADE I'M NOT CONVINCED THAT
IT'S SUFFICIENT [inaudible]
EVEN NOW.
AND YOU DO NOT COMPARE IT WITH
THE POLLUTION.
THAT THESE FIRES.
THEY HAVE CREATED.
IMPOSED ON US.
SO WE DO NEED TO GET THE FIRES
UNDER CONTROL AND UNDER CONTROL
MEANS MANAGING OUR FORCE AND
WHILE LANCE SOME OF IT GETS BACK
TO THE KIND OF PLANES THAT WE
PUT THE FIRES OUT BUT MOSTLY
IT'S PREVENTION THAT WE SHOULD
BE FOCUSING ON IT I'D LIKE TO
SEE.
A LOT MORE ATTENTION EVEN IN
THIS BUDGET TOWARDS THAT END.
WHERE DO WOOD AND AND I WOULD
SEE THIS TO BE A IT'S GOT TO BE
A DECADES OF SUSTAINED EFFORT?
IS THE ADMINISTRATION.
REALIZING AND DIRECTING ITS
ENERGIES TOWARDS THAT SUSTAINED
PROGRAM OF DIMINISHING.
THESE GREAT ACCUMULATIONS.
A FUEL SUPPLIES OF THEM WE
COULDN'T AGREE MORE THAT THE WE
WE MIGHT RECALL SB NINE NO ONE
WHICH THE CAP AND TRADE PACKAGE.
SUPPORTS WAS ACTUALLY NOT JUST
TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN NINETEEN
TWENTY BUT IT WAS A MULTI YEAR
COMMITMENT AND IS ACTUALLY A
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS. TO GET TO THE VERY
ISSUE THE THAT YOU'RE RAISING
AND SO I THINK ONE OF THE IT IS
SOMETIMES IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CONTEXTUALIZE OF THE THE
PACKAGES ACCURATE.
AS THE NUMBERS ARE FOR THE LA
DOES IT DOES REFLECT JUST KIND
OF A ONE YEAR SNAPSHOT -- BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO DISTINGUISH
SAID THERE ARE A COUPLE PROGRAM
CATEGORY SUCH AS A HEALTHY FORCE
THAT ACTUALLY WE SELECT A MULTI
YEAR COMMITMENT WHERE'S MY IN
SOME OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS ARE
MORE ON A ON A ONE TIME BASIS SO --
GETTING YOUR POINT IN TERMS OF
THE OVERALL INVESTMENT THE
OVERALL COMMITMENT GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE SITUATION IT IS
A BILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS.
TOWARDS THAT END IN PART.
IS A NEED TO FOCUS ON CO
GENERATION CAPACITY.
THESE FUELS NEED TO GO SOMEWHERE.
AND OVER DECADES WE HAVE.
PRETTY MUCH DIMINISH THE TIMBER
INDUSTRY SO GETTING RID OF LARGE
TREES AND LOGS.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT NOW.
AND WE HAVE NOT ENCOURAGED IN
FACT WE DISCOURAGE COGENERATION.
WHICH CREATES A CAPACITY TO
REMOVE SOME OF THESE PORTION
WHILE AND FUELS.
THAT IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE A
PART OF THE FUTURE THAT'S NOT A
PART OF ANYTHING HERE BUT THAT
DOES NEED TO BE A PART OF OUR
DIALOGUE AS WE PROCEED.
SO MARK ME AS YET CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW FAR WE'RE GOING AND
HOW MUCH FURTHER WE NEED TO GO.
AND BIG RUPEE I COMPLIED WITH
OTHER THINGS TOO THAT CONTRIBUTE
TO POLLUTION.
BUT THE MAGNITUDE OF THESE FIRES
[inaudible]
REGULAR [inaudible]
IN MY MR MCCARTY.
YES THANK YOU -- YOU KNOW CAP
AND TRADE IS A POPULAR TOPIC BY
WE SPENT.
AN HOUR HERE RIGHT NOW THAT'S
WHY LEADERS DOZENS OF BILLS
INTRODUCED EVERY YEAR CAPTERRA
BUT HE HAS AN IDEA.
THIS KIND OF IS IS IS THE P.
BANK SO -- THAT I'D LIKE TO ONE
DAY HAVE A CONVERSATION LIKE MR
MORE LIKE SAID ABOUT THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION NUMBER
OF TALKING ABOUT.
BUT 40% RIGHT HERE.
THERE ARE 60% THERE'S BIG
PROJECTS THERE THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT BE HELPING.
WITH WHAT OUR ULTIMATE GOALS ARE
TRYING.
TO ADDRESS OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT
IN CLIMATE CHANGE AND SO.
I GUESS WE'LL HAVE A DISCUSSION.
NEXT YEAR IS THAT ACCURATE.
ON THAT.
ON THE CONTINUOUS FEES -- HIGH I
MEAN BUT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE
THINK THE THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION ANYTIME WE
WOULD LIKE ON KIND OF ON LIKE ON
THE CONTINUES APPROPRIATIONS AS
WELL AS THE DISCRETIONARY
EXPENDITURES AND KIND OF WHERE
IT WHAT IT'S PRIORITIES ARE.
IT DOESN'T COME UP NEXT YEAR.
CONTINUOUS THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS ARE JUST ARE
CURRENTLY IN LAW THERE IS NO
SUNSET DATE ON THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS FACTION.
BUT THE BIG THING IS IS I I WANT
I CAN KERR WITH WHAT -- CURTAIN
SPECIALLY CENTER SKINNER SUMMER
TING AND IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
CHALLENGE IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
REALLY FOCUSED ON ON MOBILE.
SOURCES AND I THINK WE SHOULD
FOCUS OUR RESOURCES.
THERE -- CAN I AM I AM ALL IN IT
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW THE
AUTOMOBILE ISSUE AND FOCUSING ON
HAVING CLEANER.
PASSENGER CARS -- AS AS WELL AS
INDUSTRIAL INCLUDING AG CAR CARS
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ALWAYS THAT
THE REBATE PROGRAMS BUT IT'S THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO I KNOW THAT --
MISTER TEENS TALKING ABOUT THAT
FOR EXAMPLE I'M GOING TO THE
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION IF YOU ARE
LIKE MANY OF US WE HAVE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE DRIVING THERE.
I'M NOT SURE IN A PARK IN TURGID
THAT'S THAT'S MY CHALLENGER
KNOCKS THE DAD'S.
A RANGE OF TWO HUNDRED MILES
THAT'S JUST ABOUT THE DISTANCE
AND SO.
THOSE ISSUES ARE REAL NOT JUST --
THE REMAINS SO I THINK THAT WE
NEED.
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND
UNDERSTAND FROM WE TALKED
EARLIER FROM THE FROM THE
FINANCE FOREST'S COMPARISONS.
TO THE SOLAR INDUSTRY AND
INCENTIVIZE AND JUMP START --
THIS ANTI AND BUT WE DO HAVE
THAT -- THE MONEY IN THERE FOR A
ARE BE TO DO THE RESEARCH ON THE
INDUSTRY AND COURSE THERE'S
ISSUES ON BATTERIES AND SO FORTH
BUT FROM THE LA -- WHAT WHAT
OTHER?
WHAT ELSE YOU WOULD BE DOING TO
IT IF WE ARE TO GET TO THIS
MAGICAL?
CALL WHICH IS THE LOFTY AT A
FIVE MILLION CLEAN VEHICLES IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS PLUGGING ALONG AT THIS IS
THIS ADEQUATE THIS GOING TO GET
US THERE WERE WHAT ELSE --
SHOULD BE DOING OTHER THINGS WE
OUGHT TO BE TAKING A LOOK AT I
MEAN I I THINK THAT'S A GOOD AND
AND DIFFICULT QUESTION AS THERE
IS -- THE STATE I THINK IS
ALREADY DOING QUITE A BIT SO WE
HAVE SEVERAL DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
I MEAN ON IN THIS PACKAGE WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROJECT AND KIND OF YOU
KNOW THE INCENTIVES THAT ARE
PROVIDED THROUGH THAT -- NO
STATE HAS OTHER PROGRAMS TO AND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER -- FOR THE
EASY CHARGING -- YOUR CARD HAS A
A REGULATION THAT REQUIRES --
MANY FACTORS TO PRODUCE A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES.
THE STATE HAS A LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD PROGRAM WHICH YOU KNOW
INTO PROVIDING SOME SUBSIDIES --
FOR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AS
WELL SO THERE THERE'S KIND OF A
A SUITE OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW -- THAT
ARE ARE ARE MEANT TO ENCOURAGE.
YOU ADOPTION OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES I THINK THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER OR NOT.
THAT'S ENOUGH I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE HAS BEEN SORT OF AN
ANALYSIS OF OF WHAT EXACTLY
WOULD BE NEEDED TO KNOW WHAT WE
WOULD NEED TO PROVIDE IN TERMS
OF INCENTIVES OR OR OTHER
PROGRAMS TO KIND OF ACTUALLY HIT
THAT GOAL -- SO AT YOU KNOW IT I
THINK THEY'RE KIND OF MORE WORK
TO BE DONE AND KIND OF THINKING
THROUGH YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
LEVELS OF FUNDING MIGHT BE
NEEDED FOR EXAMPLE. EIGHT SEVEN
OTHER PROGRAMS HE HERE IF WE PUT
IT ALL TO THAT FOR EXAMPLE IN
THEM.
HELLO CARBON TRANSPORTATION FUND
FOR TWO YEARS YOU KNOW WOULD
THAT GET US TO A POINT WHERE WE
GET.
TO DEFINE ON FIVE MILLION CARS
OR YOU SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT KNOWING THAT
THIS IS THE SINGLE BIGGEST
FACTOR WE NEED TO ADDRESS.
I MEAN I THINK.
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST THIS PUTTING
MORE MONEY INTO THAT PROGRAM IS
IS ONE OPTION WORTH CONSIDERING
AND I THINK THAT JUST THE THE
JUST TO POINT THESE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD PROVIDE
VALUABLE BENEFITS WOULDN'T GET
THAT MONEY BUT I THINK THINKING
BIG.
AND BIG PICTURE ABOUT KIND OF
WHAT THE STATE'S ROLE IS AN
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND HOW THE STATE CAN
KIND OF YOU KNOW ADOPTED
POLICIES OR PUSH TECHNOLOGIES
WHICH THEN CAN BE KIND OF
EXPORTED TO OTHER JURISDICTIONS
AND YOU MAY BE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES IS KIND OF ONE OF THOSE.
EXAMPLES IN KIND OF THINKING
ABOUT HOW THE STATE CAN -- CAN
KIND OF PUSH THOSE TECHNOLOGIES
FORWARD AS IT IS ONE OF VERY
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION AND
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT KIND OF HOW IT COULD DO
THAT MOST EFFECTIVELY BUT AS FAR
AS TO HOW MUCH MONEY WOULD BE
NEEDED TO DO THAT.
AND AND WHAT'S NEEDED TO KIND OF
MEET THAT FIVE MILLION -- SAID
OF GOAL -- WE'RE NOT AWARE OF
ANY KIND OF PARTICULAR ANALYSIS
ON ON THOSE ON THOSE NUMBERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR MCCARTY SENATOR SKINNER ONCE
YOU KNOW THAT SERVICES WILL NOT
TWO HUNDRED MILES AWAY.
MISTER KING JUST SEND YOU A LINK
SO YOU'LL KNOW WHERE TO PLUG IN
FOR SAN FRANCISCO SEE LONGEST
RANDY.
THIS IS YOUR CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE TAKING CARE OF YOU.
ROUND TRIP YET THEY GOT YOU THEY
GOT YOU HE JUST SEND YOU THE
LINK FEEL NO WHERE TO PLUG IN.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON THIS.
VERY MEATY CRITICAL ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEEDLESS TO
SAY WILL BE HOLDING THIS ITEM
OPEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE.
THIRTEEN ANOTHER ME THE ISSUE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER.
LA -- HAS PREPARED -- A DOCUMENT
FOREST'S AND WHEN THEY'RE READY
THEY CAN BEGIN TO WALK US
THROUGH IT.
AGAIN ISSUE.
THIRTEEN JOHN MY RENTAL
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
I WILL BE SPEAKING FROM A
HANDOUT THAT HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE
IT YOUR BINDERS UP THERE.
IF NOT THE SERGEANT HAS COPIES.
SO THAT -- GOVERNOR PROPOSES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
ESTABLISH A SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM TO
INCREASE SAFE DRINKING WATER --
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIANS.
THE LEGISLATION WOULD ESTABLISH
A SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUND.
AND PRIORITIZE USE THE FUNDS TO
CSUS DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THERE
SIR BY WATER SYSTEMS THAT DO NOT
PROVIDE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES VARIOUS
CHARGES ESTIMATED TO GENERATE
ROUGHLY A HUNDRED TWENTY SIX TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION
ANNUALLY WHEN FULLY IMPLEMENTED --
TO FUND THE NEW PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES MONTHLY CHARGES ON
WATER SYSTEM CUSTOMERS TO
INCREASE FERTILIZER MIL FEES --
TO GENERATE REVENUES OF
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY MILLION
ANNUALLY.
IMPOSES CHARGES ON MILK
PRODUCERS ESTIMATED TO GENERATE
FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY AND ALSO
IMPOSE CHARGES ON CONFINED
ANIMAL FILL FACILITIES THE CIVIC
FLUIDS DAIRIES -- AND THIS WOULD
GENERATE UP TO ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ANNUALLY.
THE GOVERNOR ALSO PROPOSES FOUR
POINT NINE MILLION AND ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT AND THIRTY
POSITIONS FOR THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AGRICULTURE
FOR STATE ADMINISTRATION -- AND
TO BEGIN IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM IF YOU TURN THE PAGE --
YOU'LL SEE THAT THE SENATE
REJECTED THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
AND I DROPPED THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE LEGISLATION TO
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND --
DEFINED THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FIND IN ITS
CONTINGENT ON ENACTMENT OF THE
SENATE BILL.
TWO HUNDRED WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH THAT SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND
TO HELP WATER SYSTEMS PROVIDING
ADEQUATE AND AFFORDABLE SUPPLIES
SAFE DRINKING WATER.
THE ASSEMBLY SET ASIDE FOUR
POINT NINE MILLION GENERAL FUND
PENDING FUTURE AGREEMENT ON THE
ESTABLISHMENT THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM.
AND DEFERRED ACTION ON THE
CREATION OF THE PROGRAM IN THE
FOR THE ISSUE TO THE LEGISLATIVE --
POLICY COMMITTEES FOR FURTHER
CONSIDERATION.
SO WE WE NOTE THAT BOTH HOUSES
HAVE SHOWN CONSISTENT INTEREST
IN MOVING FORWARD.
ON THE POLICY TO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO CLEAN AFFORDABLE ACCESSIBLE
DRINKING WATER AT ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
AND THEY'RE CURRENTLY BILLS IN
BOTH HOUSES THAT WOULD IMPLEMENT
PROGRAM SIMILAR TO WHAT IS BEING
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR.
WE HAVE LOOKED AT ALTERNATIVE
FUNDING SOURCES FOR THE THE
PROGRAM A SPECIFIC WILLIE WE'VE
LOOKED AT BOND FINDING BUT WE
DON'T THINK IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE.
BECAUSE BOND PROVIDE ONE TIME
FIND SOURCES AND SHOULD NOT BE
RELIED ON AS A SOURCE OF FUNDING
FOR AN ONGOING PROGRAM -- AND
ALSO WE LOOKED AT SPECIAL FUNDS
HOWEVER WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
IDENTIFY SPECIAL FUND WHERE IT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO USE THE
FUNDS FOR THESE PURPOSES.
AND IT ALSO HAS A SUFFICIENT
BALLOTS THAT IT COULD PAY FOR
THE PROGRAM -- WHEN ALTERNATIVE
THAT WE HAVE LOOKED AT IS THE
GENERAL FUND AND WE THINK THAT'S
AN APPROPRIATE -- FUNDING SOURCE
FOR THE PROGRAM.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT --
HISTORICALLY WE'VE HAD CONCERNS
ABOUT CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS
BECAUSE THEY TEND TO CONSTRAIN
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT HOWEVER IF
THE LEGISLATURE DID.
CHOOSE TO GO THIS ROUTE.
THERE ARE SOME OPTIONS THAT
COULD HELP WITH OVERSIGHT AND
FUTURE FOR EXAMPLE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S HEAR
FROM FINANCE. TO BRIEF COMMENTS
FIRST THE GOVERNOR CONTINUES TO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED A DEDICATED
ONGOING SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER.
AND THE SECOND IN IS MAY
REVISION PRESS CONFERENCE THE
GOVERNOR EXPRESSED AN INTEREST
IN WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU TO
FIND WHERE THAT ONGOING SOURCE
CAN BE WE CONTINUE TO STAND
BEHIND OUR MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
A ONGOING CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS
INDEED QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS MR
OBERNOLTE.
SO I WOULD HOPE I SPEAK FOR
EVERYONE ON THIS DíAS THAT.
WE ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE WE NEED TO
PROVIDE CLEAR AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER TO CALIFORNIANS
AND THE TO THE EXTENT THAT THEIR
PLACES IN THE STATE WHERE THE
DOES NOT OCCUR.
I SHOULD BE A PRIORITY FOR US.
BUT WE DON'T WERE RIGHT NOW IN
HERE WHEN WE'RE PROJECTING A
TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
SURPLUS AND THAT'S WHY SHE IS SO
DIFFICULT. TO TALK ABOUT
IMPOSING NEW TAXES ON
CALIFORNIANS.
I THINK THE SITUATION MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT IF.
WE WERE.
HEY FACING A DEFICIT AND WE WERE
HAVING OF CUT OTHER -- OTHER
PLACES BUT WHICH IS REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO GO BACK TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND EXPLAIN TO
THEM WHY.
WE HAD TWENTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS EXTRA AND YET WE ELECTED
TO ADD A TAX -- AND THE OTHER
THING I WANT TO SAY ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS THAT THIS
THE TAX AND PARTICULARLY THE TAX
ON THE COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS.
WHICH IS THE BULK OF THE REVENUE.
IT'S IT'S A PARTICULARLY
REGRESSIVE TAX MEANING THAT IT'S
DISPROPORTIONATELY BORNE BY THE
PEOPLE WHO CAN LEAST AFFORD TO
PAY AT THE ONE WHEN WE ENACT
THOSE KIND OF TAXES INVARIABLY
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS RAISING THE
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH THAT I THINK A
LOT OF US HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
BECAUSE MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE ALREADY FACING CHALLENGES.
IN AFFORDING THEIR BASIC
NECESSITIES AND OF WHICH WATER
IS ONE OF THEM SO -- I I'M
REALLY HOPING THAT WE CAN COME.
TO SOME KIND OF AGREEMENT THAT
WERE WE FIND A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND THIS ON
THE GENERAL FUND SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO IMPOSE THAT TAX.
ON CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE IT'S A
VERY DIFFICULT THING TO JUSTIFY.
THANK YOU MISTER TING.
THANKS I MEAN I I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
PAIR THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO
PROVIDE CLEAN AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FOR EVERYBODY IN
THE STATE AND FACT I'M.
SORT OF LITTLE BIT SHOCKED THAT
SIX YEARS AFTER BEING UP HERE WE
DOES MY SEVENTY WE HAVEN'T DONE
IT YET -- HAVING SAID THAT YOU
KNOW AS WELL NO.
ONCE WE WAIT AND TELL WATER
ISSUES ISSUES ARE.
THEM MOST COMPLEX IN THE STATE I
DON'T THINK THERE'S AN ISSUE
THAT'S MORE COMPLEX OR MORE
CHALLENGING THE STATE THAN WATER.
HAVING SAID THAT THE THE WATER
WASN'T POLLUTED BY.
THE ENVIRONMENT OR BY NATURE THE
WATER WAS POLLUTED BY.
PEOPLE.
AND I THINK THAT THE BIG THE BIG
CHALLENGES I THINK THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE.
IS IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
REMEDIATION.
DONE BY THE PEOPLE IN THE
ENTITIES THAT.
CREATED THE POLLUTION I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES ON IS THAT MAKING
SURE THAT AGAIN.
WITH MUCH OF OUR REMEDIATION
WHICH HAS BEEN A LONG LONG TIME
DISCUSSING CAP AND TRADE THAT
THERE ACTUALLY IS -- ENSURING
THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE.
MEDIATION BY THE POLLUTERS WHO
BECAUSE THE POLLUTION WHO
POLLUTED DRINKING WATER WHO MADE
IT SO THAT THE WATER WAS NOT
DRINKABLE THE WATER DID NOT
START OFF THAT WAY.
ALSO THE OTHER PIECE OF IT IS IS
WE HAVE ON MANY SMALL WATER
DISTRICTS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
WHO REALLY.
HAVE PROVED.
INADEQUATE TO REALLY DO THE JOB
OF MANAGING WATER OR TO
DISTRIBUTE THE WATER TO
HOUSEHOLDS TO DIFFERENT PLACES.
I THINK THAT HARM IN ORDER TO
ASSURE THAT WE ACTUALLY FIX THIS
PROBLEM WE CAN'T.
JUST -- PAY MONEY AND ASSUME
THIS'LL BE CLEAN CLEAN UP WE
HAVE TO ENSURE AGAIN THAT THE
POLLUTERS A PAYING PLAYERS ARE
POLLUTING LAST AND THEN ON TOP
OF THAT THAT.
THERE IS SOME CONSOLIDATION OF
MANY OF THESE WATER DISTRICTS
WHO AGAIN DID NOT SOUND THE
ALARM BELLS TO NOT REALLY RAISE
THE ISSUE.
INTEL REALLY GOT TOO LATE I
THINK THERE HAS TO BE A SORT OF
A MUCH -- A MUCH BROADER FIX
THAT THE HOPE IS THE ISSUE THAT
WE CAN.
REACH THAT WHETHER TO THE BUDGET
OR WHETHER IT'S THROUGH A
SEPARATE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BY
THINK THE HOPE REALLY IS -- THAT
WE CAN GET TO THAT GET TO THIS
ISSUE THIS YEAR.
AGAIN IT'S NOT AS SIMPLE AS JUST
APPROPRIATING MONEY BUT IT'S
IT'S REALLY TO THE CONSOLIDATION
OF THESE WATER DISTRICTS THAT
THERE IS -- GREAT RESPONSIBILITY
TAKEN BY THOSE WHO BELIEVE WE'RE
A SLEEP.
SLEEP AT THE WHEEL AND THEN
AGAIN MAKING SURE THAT THE
POLLUTERS WHO POLLUTED THE WATER --
HAVE TO PAY FOR SOME OF THAT
REMEDIATION. FOR THE NIELSEN.
THIS IS A BIG ISSUE AND I
CERTAINLY WOULD ARGUE FOR THE
FOR THE SENATE HAS BEEN ON THIS.
THE DEDICATION OF A GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION. FOR WHERE WE'RE
AT NOW -- THAT I THINK WE'RE
PRETTY MATURED AND CERTAINLY BE
TALKING ABOUT A TAX INCREASES
AND THOSE ARE NOT WIRED TO
WILDLY EMBRACED.
AND MANY THINGS HAVE BEEN DONE.
THROUGH MANY AUTHORITIES TO GET
OUT OUR ISSUES OF WATER SUPPLY
[inaudible]
WATER QUALITY [inaudible]
REPLENISHING AQUIFER'S
[inaudible]
SERVICE STORAGE.
CONVEYANCE SYSTEMS.
IT'S A VERY COMPLICATED
[inaudible]
AREA.
THE END YES THERE ARE PROBLEMS.
BUT WE HAVE TO BE REALISTIC
ABOUT IT.
AND IN TERMS OF JUST THE
SPECIFIC TAX THAT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED.
THERE'S BROAD AND VERY STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THAT I JUST NEED
TO GET THAT ON THE RECORD.
THANK YOU SIR. FOR TO EVER --
AND I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THE BEEN SEVEN YEARS NOW AND
EVER SINCE I CAME UP HERE THE
DISCUSSION HAS BEEN ABOUT WATER.
AND I HAVE BEEN -- SHOCKED AND
EMBARRASSED. TO BE A CALIFORNIA.
AND TO HAVE PEOPLE IN THE STATE
WHO DON'T HAVE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER.
YOU KNOW I CAN GO TO THIRD WORLD
COUNTRIES AND SEE THINGS
SOMETIMES LIKE THAT BUT MORE
THAN LIKELY SEE THINGS BETTER
THAN THAT.
AND SO THAT TO ME IS VERY
ALARMING AND WE'RE STILL
DEBATING THE ISSUE.
AND TALKING ABOUT TAXING FOLKS
WHICH IS.
YOU KNOW WHICH ARE WHICH ARE THE
GYM WITH THE FOLKS WHO CAN LEAST
AFFORD IT BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THE AREAS ARE IN THE STATE WERE.
WE LOOKING AT FOLKS WHO DON'T
HAVE CLEAN DRINKING WATER AND ON
THAT WATER TO BE THEN.
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AND
AND AT SOME POINT I YOU KNOW I'M
GETTING TO THE POINT WHERE THEY
HAS TO COME SOME -- OF
RESPONSIBILITY AT THE STATE
LEVEL FOR US TO BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
ARE THAT ARE RIGHT THE PEOPLE
OUT A HALF.
IN CALIFORNIA IN THE SAME WAY WE
THINK EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO A QUALITY SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW A QUALITY KIND OF OF OF
LIVING ENVIRONMENT OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CAP
AND TRADE A LOT.
BUT ALSO BE SOME OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL THINGS AND I ALWAYS
THOUGHT WATER CLEAN WATER WAS
ONE OF THOSE FUNDAMENTAL THINGS.
THAT WE BELIEVED IN BECAUSE THE
IMPACT OF NOT HAVING CLEAN WATER --
IN THE STATE LIKE THIS COULD
HAVE SOME DEVASTATING EFFECTS ON
OTHERS WITH REGARDS TO HEALTH.
AND ALL THOSE THINGS IF WE JUST
CONSTANTLY KICK THIS CAN DOWN
THE ROAD IGNORE IT -- WE
RESPONSIBILITY TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AND THAT MEANS DEALING
WITH THOSE WHO DONE THE
POLLUTION IF THAT MEANS PUTTING
THE RESOURCES FOR WORK.
THAT WE HOPE TO RECAPTURE IF
THERE ARE FOLKS WEAKENED A
DIGNIFIED THAT HAVE THIS A AN
ISSUE.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE NO CALIFORNIAN
SHOULD EVER EVER LIVE WITHOUT
CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
I MEAN WE SPEND LOTS OF TIME
MANY OF US WHO ARE PHILANTHROPIC
GOING TO THIRD WORLD COUNTRIES
BUILDING WELLS AND ALL THIS KIND
OF STUFF TALKING ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF CLEAN WATER.
ON PEOPLE'S HEALTH AND AND
THEY'RE ALL THE THINGS THAT GO
ALONG WITH IT AND THEN WE COME
HOME AFTER DOING THESE WONDERFUL
EXPERIENCES IN ANOTHER COUNTRY.
THE BUILDING WELL SOME PEOPLE
HAVE CLEAN WATER AND NO HAVE
CLEAN WATER HERE -- AT SOME
POINT WE HAVE TO BITE THE BULLET.
AND WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM WE KNOW WHAT
THE SOLVE IT IS COMPLICATED BUT
A LOT OF PIECES TO IT.
BUT IT'S THE SAME TIME WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF
CLEAN DRINKING WATER IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND TO NOT DO THAT IS REALLY
REALLY IN MY MIND IT'S
EMBARRASSING AS A STATE WITH ALL
THE HIGH TECH STUFF WE HAVE IN
ALL THE WEALTHY PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE BEAUTIFUL PRISTINE
ENVIRONMENT WHICH WE HAVE WE
HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE WATER THEY
CAN'T DRINK THAT WAS STILL
TAKING WATER INTO COMMUNITIES.
OF WHERE THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
TURN ON THE TAP AND SEE CLEAN
WATER AND TAKE A BATH.
AND SO I YOU KNOW I YOU KNOW I I
I SEE THIS AS A BUDGET ISSUE
THAT OUGHT TO BE IN THE BUDGET.
BECAUSE TO ME THIS IS
FUNDAMENTAL FOR CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRYING TO GET EVERYBODY
HEALTHCARE TRYING TO GET
EVERYBODY IN PRESCHOOL TRYING TO
GET EVERYBODY AND WE WOULD WOULD
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DOING.
AND YET WE ARE NOT THINKING THAT
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE ABLE TO TURN
ON THE TAP.
AND GET A CLEAN GLASS WATER.
NO WE DON'T WANNA BE FLIPPED BUT
WE'RE MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION.
AND AND AND AND SO TO ME IT'S
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT AND IT IS
A RESPONSIBILITY OF US WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT OF HIS BUDGET FIND
THE MONEY.
GET IT DONE AND IF WE NEED TO GO
AFTER THE PEOPLE WHO DID IT WE
GO AFTER BUT NO CALIFORNIAN
SHOULD EVER HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
WATER THAT THEY CANNOT DRINK IN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITY.
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
THANK YOU FOR THE SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF A MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AND I AM COMFORTABLE.
WELL I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
HOLD THIS OPEN -- AND I KNOW
THAT.
THE BOTH HOUSES REJECTED THE
BROAD TAX ON EVERY INDIVIDUAL
WATER USER WHICH HIGH AGREED
BECAUSE I FEEL THAT.
THE MILLION PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
WHO FOR NOW DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE AND HEALTHY DRINKING
WATER.
IT IS DUE [inaudible]
TO SOME POLLUTERS.
AND IT'S NOT THE SAME POLLUTER
BUT IT IS KNOWN POLLUTERS.
AND SO TO ASK EVERY OTHER
CALIFORNIA. TO COVER THE COST OF
THESE KNOWN POLLUTERS IS NOT
APPROPRIATE IN MY MIND NOW
SOMEONE COULD SAY WELL FOR USE
GENERAL FUND IN EFFECT WE'RE
DOING NOW WE'RE BASICALLY HAVING
THE TAXPAYER.
SO I GT THAT.
AND I WOULD ULTIMATELY WANT TO
SEE US.
IN APPLYING THE PRINCIPLE OF
POLLUTER PAYS.
HOWEVER.
THERE IS OF THE PROPOSALS THAT
HAVE BEEN FLOATED SO FAR AROUND
POLLUTER PAYS.
READ LEASES THAT POLLUTER FROM --
A GOOD DEAL OF RESPONSIBILITY
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S A FAIR
WAY TO GO SO.
I HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
THESE CONVERSATIONS AND WORK
THIS OUT SO THAT WERE NOT
NECESSARILY ASKING EVERY
CALIFORNIANS THROUGH THE GENERAL
FUND OR THROUGH A FEE ON THEIR
WATER.
BUT RATHER WE ARE APPLYING THE
POLLUTER PAY PRINCIPLES BUT IN
THE MEAN TIME.
IF WE HAVE TO FALL BACK THEN I
WOULD RATHER USE THE GENERAL
FUND.
THANK YOU SENATOR OFF.
THANK YOU MANAGER OF THE MONEY
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- IS
NOT GOING TO BE USED FOR CAPITAL
PROJECTS CORRECT BECAUSE HIS
BOND MONEY FOR THAT IS THAT
RIGHT.
SIR DO I GO TO PART OF FINANCE
THAT'S CORRECT THERE IS
CURRENTLY BOND FUNDING AND
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT GOES FOR
THE CAP INFRASTRUCTURE.
AS A PRIMARY FOCUS ON THE
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE ON
OTHER KIND OF EMERGENCY DRINKING
WATER NEEDS -- WHERE THE BOND
FUNDING AND FEDERAL FUNDING
CANNOT REALLY BE USED FOR SO THE
THE MONEY THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT WILL BE USED?
TO HIRE PEOPLE TO MANAGE PROVIDE
MONEY TO HIRE PEOPLE TO MANAGE
CLEAN UP IN THE SMALL WATER
COMPANIES.
THAT COULD BE PART OF IT -- SUBS
SUBSIDIZED SUBSIDIZE WATER BILLS --
IF A PART OF THE WATER SYSTEMS
TO PAY FOR THEIR ONGOING
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE I SEE
[inaudible]
SO NO [inaudible]
IF IF IF WE HANDED YOU A CHECK
FOR A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TOMORROW DO WE HAVE A
LIST OF WATER COMPANIES.
THAT NEED IMMEDIATE ATTENTION
AND THE COST FOR EACH OF THOSE
COMPANIES -- THE WATER BOARD --
HAVE A LIST OF THOSE WATER
SYSTEM THEY ARE CURRENTLY NOT
MEETING DRINKING WATER STANDARDS
SO THAT WOULD BE KIND OF ONE OF
THE KIND OF PRIORITIES LOOKING
AT WHO CURRENTLY IS NOT MEETING
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS -- BUT
THERE ARE OTHER SYSTEMS ARE NOT
REGULATED BY THE WATER BOARD SO
THERE IS CURRENTLY -- CONFERENCE
OF ASSESSING BE CONDUCTED BY THE
WATER BOARD WITH FUNDING THEY'LL
PROVIDED LAST YEAR THROUGH THE
BUDGET -- AND THAT ASSESSMENT
WILL HELP CAN GET TO WHERE ARE
SOME OF THOSE PRIORITY TO NEED
AS PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PLAN -- THAT TO BE A A BI ANNUAL
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THAT KIND OF
HIGHLIGHT THOSE PRIORITY AREAS
AND THAT'S ALWAYS BASED OFF OF A
BI ANNUAL ASSESSMENT THE WORLD
WE KIND OF EVALUATING WHAT THE
NEED IS.
AT AND HARD BEING THE DOLLARS
TOWARDS THAT NEED WHEN WAS THAT
ASSESSMENT -- STUDY BE COMPLETED.
I THINK IT'S BEING PHASED IN --
THERE'S MULTIPLE PIECES OF THAT
STUDY SO -- WE ANTICIPATE WITHIN
A YEAR AND A HALF WILL COMPLETE
EVERYTHING THERE ISN'T A DEFINED
DATA WHEN EACH COMPANY WILL BE
COMPLETED BUT THERE MIGHT BE
SOME COMPONENT THAT I BE
COMPLETED BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR.
BUT SENT ITS MULTIPLE COMPONENTS
OTHERS MIGHT LIKE UNTIL THE
FOLLOWING YEAR AND DO YOU EXPECT
WHEN THAT WHEN THAT ASSESSMENT --
STUDY IS COMPLETED THAT THERE
WILL BE.
A BOTTOM LINE HOW MANY WATER
COMPANIES NEED ATTENTION AND HOW
MUCH MONEY IS GOING TO BE
REQUIRED TO FIX THE PROBLEM.
I THINK IT WOULD DEFINITELY GIVE
US A LOT OF BETTER SENSE
CURRENTLY ARE PROPOSAL WAS BASED
OFF OF PREVIOUS AT THAT FROM
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE DID
HIGHLIGHT APPROX ME HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS AND THAT
IS THAT'S ALSO HIGHLIGHTED --
HOW MUCH OF THAT IS THAT
POTENTIALLY DUE TO POLLUTANTS
FROM NITRATES WHICH IS GOING ON
WITH THE V. AGRICULTURE CHARGES
THAT WE HAVE WITHIN OUR PROPOSAL
AND THEN WHAT CHORE -- POLLUTION
IS MORE NATURAL CONTAMINATED
POLLUTION WHICH IS MORE
CONSISTENT WITH THE THE WATER
CHARGES ON THE CONSUMERS.
YOU KNOW WE HAD A LESSON LAST
YEAR THE YEAR FORGET THE YEAR
BEFORE ON TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
AND AND IN THE IN THAT
PARTICULAR LEGISLATIVE EFFORT
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION.
THERE WERE A LIST OF PROJECTS
AND DOLLAR TOTALS -- WHERE WE
KNEW AND THE ADMINISTRATION --
SPECIFICALLY HOW MUCH MONEY WAS
GOING TO BE REQUIRED TO FIX THIS
BRIDGE OF THAT ROAD -- EVEN THAT
WAS DIFFICULT A DIFFICULT SELL.
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN OUR
CONSTITUENTS -- WHEN WE MOVE
AWAY FROM -- GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION WHEN WE MOVE
TOWARD A FEE OR A TAX OR
WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL IT.
THAT'S WHERE WE REALLY RUN INTO
TROUBLE BECAUSE AT LEAST DOWN
WHERE I COME FROM.
I REALLY DON'T WANT TO TAKE
MONEY.
AND SEND IT TO SACRAMENTO TO LET
IT SIT UNTIL WE FIGURE OUT HOW
MUCH WE NEED AND WHERE IT'S
GOING TO GO.
YOU KNOW THEY EXPECT EVEN THE
ONES THAT ARE WILLING TO
COOPERATE EVEN THE ONES THAT
FEEL THE WAY.
WE DO UP HERE THAT CLEAN
DRINKING WATER IS A RIGHT AND WE
NEED TO FIX PROBLEMS WHERE THERE
IS A LACK OF CLEAN DRINKING
WATER.
EVEN PEOPLE WHO SHARE THAT VIEW --
DON'T LIKE THE CONCEPT OF
SENDING MONEY TO SACRAMENTO
WITHOUT A PLAN.
AND THAT'S WHY I GUESS MY
QUESTION I THINK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE.
TO FIGURE THIS THING OUT EVEN
WITH THE GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION I THINK WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW MUCH MONEY WE
NEED OVER WHAT PERIOD OF TIME.
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE
AND UNTIL WE KNOW THAT I DON'T
KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE HAVE MUCH OF
A CONVERSATION.
ABOUT FEES OR TAXES.
FRANKLY EVEN THE GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION BECAUSE I'M SURE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS.
IN THE SENATE SIDE IS NOT GONNA
BE ENOUGH TO FIX THIS PROBLEM IS
IT.
WELL I WOULD SAY THAT THE
MESSAGES PROPOSAL IS BASED OFF
OF AN ASSESSMENT CONDUCTED TWO
YEARS AGO WE DID ESTIMATE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS -- NEEDED
ON GOING ON GOING YES SO THAT
MITCHELL PROPOSAL IS.
CONSISTENT WITH THAT ANALYSIS
HOWEVER WE ARE CONDUCTING
ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS TO GET KIND
OF MORE GRANULAR DETAIL AND THAT
WOULD HELP US IDENTIFY WHAT
WOULD BE THOSE KIND OF PRIORITY
AREAS.
BUT THERE MIGHT BE DIFFERENT
APPROACHES IN SOME AREAS WE
MIGHT FOCUS ON CONSOLIDATION IN
OTHER AREAS WHERE THERE'S NOT A
CLOSE ENOUGH WATER SYSTEM THAT
WE CAN CONSOLIDATE.
THEN WE WOULD BE FOCUSING ON
SUPPORTING THEIR OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE AS THOUGH IT'S NOT
UNTIL YOU GET TO THE GRAND YOUR
DETAILS AND WHEN YOU WOULD FOCUS
ON WHAT SPECIFIC STRATEGY TO
FOCUS ON WHAT SPECIFIC AREA.
BUT WE DO HAVE AN INITIAL SENSE
BASED OFF OF THE PREVIOUS
ESTIMATE OF WHAT IS THOSE THOSE
NEEDS AND THAT'S WHY ARE
PROPOSALS BASED OFF.
WELL YOU I'M YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE TRYING TO HELP BUT YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND THE CONUNDRUM WE FACE --
WHEN WE'RE NOT ABLE TO TALK TO
CONSTITUENTS DIRECTLY AND
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT WHERE THIS
MONEY'S GOING?
AND HOW MUCH OF IT IS GOING. TO
A PARTICULAR PLACE IT'S A RATHER
GENERAL CONCEPT FRANKLY.
I READ THE MEDIA AND READ THE
NEWSPAPERS EVEN THE NEWSPAPERS
ARE CONFUSED -- ABOUT WHETHER IS
CAPITAL PROJECTS ARE OPERATING
SUBSIDIES.
THERE WAS AN ARTICLE I THINK
THAT WAS -- AN OP ED BY THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION FOLKS WAS TALKING
ABOUT CAPITAL PROJECTS AND BEING
PLENTY OF BOND MONEY AND WHY DO
YOU NEED TO HAVE THIS SORT OF
CONVERSATION WELL.
BONWIT THERE IS PLENTY OF BOND
MONEY AND PROJECTS AND NOT THE
ISSUE HERE SO I THINK THERE'S A
COMMUNICATION PIECE THERE'S A
ASSESSMENT PIECE.
AND THEN OF COURSE WE GET INTO
THE FEE TAX OR GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION DISCUSSION I JUST
WANT YOU TO KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO
HELP WE JUST HAVE A PROBLEM
THANK YOU MANAGER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT WAS A
IMPORTANT ROBUST CONVERSATION I
HEAR THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY.
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES -- ON ONE
ECHO ON THE SCANNERS POINT ABOUT
IN ANY CONTEXT IN WHICH WE HAVE
A POLLUTER PAYS KIND OF
PRINCIPLE -- IT IT SHOULD NOT
AND CANNOT YOU KNOW INCLUDING
THE ALLOWANCE FOR THE POTENTIAL
CONTINUATION OF POLLUTION OR IN
THE PROPELS IMMUNITY I JUST
THINK FUNDAMENTALLY THAT'S NOT.
A HEALTHY APPROPRIATE DIRECTION
TO GO AND I'M SURE EVERYONE'S
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT HAVING ACCESS
TO WATER BE IN A FUNDAMENTAL
PERSONAL RIGHT -- YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S IT'S IRONIC THAT
PEOPLE ASSUME WATER STREET.
AND EVEN THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER ARE PAYING A PREMIUM FOR
IT.
A AND SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
THAT'S EVEN MORE OFFENSIVE FOR
LOOK FOR TO THIS CONVERSATION I
AGREE WITH YOU DOCTOR WET WEBER.
IN OUR STATE BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES AS OF A
LEGISLATIVE BODY AND SO THIS IS
THE PLACE.
TO SOLVE THIS PROB PROBLEM.
ALBEIT TEMPORARY -- BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT PLACE FOR US TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION.
COLLEAGUES IT'S ONE 12-1 T. I
THINK I THINK WE CAN GET THROUGH
THREE MORE ISSUES.
AND SO WE'RE GONNA STOP ISSUE.
SIXTEEN LET'S SEE IF WE CAN DO
IT ISSUE.
FOURTEEN ADJUSTMENT TO PAYMENT
TERMS FOR FEDERAL AGENCIES.
LA JOH THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED
TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION TO
ADDRESS AN ISSUE WITH ADVANCE
PAYMENTS TO DEPARTMENT TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL -- THE SENATE
HAS NO PROPOSAL.
FINANCE ALTERNATE OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE.
DO YOU THINK OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND GIVEN THERE'S A
ANOTHER DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL REFORM TRAILER BILL
WOULD LIKE TO FULL THIS TRAILER
BILL DISCUSSION INTO THAT LARGER
TRAILER BILL DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
NO.
SIXTEEN THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON ISSUE.
FOURTEEN WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THAT ITEM OPEN THANK YOU ISSUE
FIFTEEN TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE FOR
CERTIFIED RECYCLING CENTERS.
LA -- WHEN YOU'RE READY?
I'M SO THE ISSUE HERE THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED I'M TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO OUR THREE SCOTT
RECYCLE TO SEE -- EXPAND.
UP TO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE PENALTY ACCOUNT OF THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
FIND IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE TO LOW
VOLUME RECYCLERS.
THE GOVERNOR AND THE SENATE HAD
NO PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU FINANCE ADMINISTRATION
IS COMFORTABLE WITH THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
FURTHERMORE Là.
AND I'M SURE -- WE HAVE A
SYSTEMIC TREND HERE THAT.
IS IS.
FOR INTERESTING AND THAT.
FOREIGN COUNTRIES AREN'T BUYING
OUR PLASTIC ANYMORE IN OUR GOODS
IN THE SHIPPING THEM BACK SO.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE LOOKING AT
A BIGGER PICTURE AND WE'RE
GETTING.
BILLS SPREAD OUT.
HAVE THAT OCCUR.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE IT'S SUCH A
BIG PROBLEM AND I I DON'T KNOW
IF THIS IS.
NECESSARILY THE SOLUTION BUT
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE.
PURSUED.
I'LL LEAVE THAT TO A MR PRESS
ONE IF AND TO FIX IT THANK.
THE HELP BUTTON THROUGH THIS ONE
UP THIS ONE A FUN.
THIS ONE OFTEN.
LEAVE IT TO MISTER THIS ONE OFF
AND I'LL GIVE THEM A LITTLE MORE
TIME TO COME UP WITH A SOLUTION
SO WILL HOLD THE ITEM UP AND
ISSUE SIXTEEN HEALTHY STORES
REFRIGERATION GRANT PROGRAM LA
JOH.
THE ASSEMBLY ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS
GEOGRAPHIC RESTRICTIONS THE
DEFINITION OF THE DESERT.
IS A FINE BY THE HEALTH THE
STORES REFRIGERATION GRANT
PROGRAM THE SENATE HAD NO
PROPOSAL.
EXCELLENT FINANCE YOUR TO WEAR
COMFORTABLE WITH THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL.
EXCELLENT WITHOUT THE SENATE IS
PREPARED TO ACCEPT THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY. FIVE OH
SENATE [inaudible] FOUR ZERO
WITH THE OUR ONE THIRTY HAVE
ARRIVED WE WILL ADJOURN TODAY'S --
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WE
WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT FOUR
FIFTEEN PM MONDAY JUNE THIRD FOR
FIFTEEN HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND WE
STAND ADJOURNED